[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
bobby
yeah robert
can you read devretsky's endgame manual
to us one more time yeah
now we gotta get up
[Applause]
[Laughter]
it was you like i was i was gonna do it
but
[Laughter]
that's what i said
i told you
let's do it all right
you know what they say though what
happens in salt lake
it stays in salt lake
exactly
cheers to my super gm friends it's been
good the world championship
on chess.com
[Applause]
let's do this
[Music]
yeah that was that was i was
yeah i'm i'm great
round two
bobby
yes robert
can you read devoretsky's endgame manual
to us one more time yeah
okay okay
i just actually didn't expect you to do
it that time because it's funnier like i
thought you was a one time
yeah yeah please okay okay i'm just
trying to add live with what feels
natural yeah
of course it feels natural wait so we
should expect that next yeah
okay just so i'm mentally prepared yeah
okay
what is this
it's eggs
i want an omelet with brie just [ __ ]
eat it
you eat it
we could turn a little bit on the
shoulder there
the
faster card and unibrow i just want to
thank my sponsors uh very much for all
they do to to promote chess
um sounds like a great future credit
card faster card yeah wasn't it fast or
hard
y'all are respecting the wood a little
too much
not fast or hard bobby oh boy i i can't
be with you anymore
okay
i mean i think it's i think it's
hilarious don't you think people would
would buy this
i don't think anyone's going to buy that
hey that's the stupidest person in my
life
okay
i guess that's it
all right that's it that was great
keep it rolling okay
same thing
who is that guy who's that
he didn't come in with you guys
no
we're gonna be right back bobby
that's robert
can you read deboratsky's in-game manual
to us one more time yeah yeah
i'm sorry
[Music]
that's so funny
isn't it cool when i predict the moves
you're gonna say because we all see
things in the same way in the same speed
on this show
isn't that cool when we do that
it doesn't make me very happy
[Laughter]
and let's bring up the analysis board as
we do that so if fun can give us her
thoughts on the
on the pet drop go aheady fun
uh well yeah actually that's a very good
question because i was firstly trying to
yeah danny
my throat's still dry
you're like you've already you've had
five glasses of water okay you remember
what happened last time
my throat's still dry
you've already had five glasses of water
and you remember what happened last time
it was an accident you peed your bed
[Laughter]
you're looking fresh man all six of them
again dude your haircut just looks great
wait did we start the bit
[Laughter]
you're not supposed to say that
you're not supposed to say if you start
the bit if black's a6 pawn was
transported let's
say night guys
good night dad i've been bobby bobby
[Laughter]
you know one more time maybe one of you
guys
i said i said it should i not said it
i think it's funny people say good night
dad i mean bobby but we need to be in
sync
[Music]
hello and welcome to round nine of the
tata steel chess tournament my name is
fiona style anthony and i'm delighted to
be joined once again by grandmaster
daniel naradetsky dania we're gonna jump
straight into the playing hall uh as the
round is about to get on the way but how
are you today
i am feeling great fiona good afternoon
to you this is an absolutely huge round
there's no going around it this is round
nine we have the face-off between the
two leaders and we're obviously going to
spend a lot of time on that game magnus
carlson against mom and darf i can't
wait for that game and of course the
others as well
i am so excited i saw that in the chat
and the prediction is will that game and
decisively or not i made the same
prediction faline loved the same poll
earlier on my instagram people are very
taunt actually i don't know about the
prediction here but i had more people
predicting a decisive result which is of
course what the fans are hoping for
this is another excite there
sorry dania did you see the
the handshake fail between pragnanda and
kayaking
that was hilarious
it was very funny for pregnant i saw
that earlier his second and coach
ramesh has tweeted that he finally
tested negative so he is out of
isolation which is fantastic news both
for himself and for prague
um and yeah we'll see i mean there's
another matchup we just saw earlier
which i'm also excited about you're the
event for race against dubois
two players of team magnus and who both
are so creative
exactly explosive
but i i just wanted to say that you know
is there a possibility that carlos
mohammed yarb ends in a draw yes and i
think fans should not exclude that
possibility magnus is not going to be
playing one h4 and nor is he going to be
sacrificing a queen within six moves i
think he's going to be taking calculated
risks
and we know that magnus plays the
position but i am cautiously hopeful
that we're gonna see something amazing
on the board today
yeah i'm curious if the game will jump
to life uh
after the middle game or if we get
something crazy from from the get-go
yeah it's hard to say in the other games
we have gary shanklin we have duda es
panco it's not like uh the other players
are going to produce boring chess and
we'll definitely look at all of the
games it's just that carlos and mohammed
yarov definitely the most impactful game
for the tournament standings as they are
leading the tournament both of them with
five and a half out of eight
indeed and well maybe we can bring up
the bird's eye view for a second i'm
curious have moves been made anywhere
sometimes have been made magnus carson
always takes some time
yeah he's late he's fast he's late and
then he adjusts all the pieces writes
down
everything on his score sheet
and then he makes a move but what do we
have going on elsewhere
well we see another french in grandelias
tarjana
we see um i ray lopez and then forest
dubai that's not surprising
okay carlson has finally made a move um
i suppose we can stay on the carlson
game and see what opening
uh we have back there
except mohamed yarb is thinking on the
first move i'm sorry about that i didn't
expect that little wrinkle he's gone
knight f6 so we'll there we go soon get
an ancestor what kind of direction we go
and go in here
first question is will magnus play c4
the answer to that is no he plays knight
f3 the more conservative move that
doesn't mean anything though uh
obviously knight f3 has tremendous
transpositional potential
uh we could basically see any opening
other than a nimzo indian
this is the key moment from amador will
he play g6 or will he play d5
what do you expect
d5
i think we might see a ragosan
but
called it what do i know
there it is yes
that's correct
i feel vindicated
and here comes
c4
and now another moment of decision
mamadiarov can take on c4 we could see a
slav with c6 but he has been resorting
to the ragazin
uh when mohammed yarb is looking to play
something very solid that of course is
e6
knight c3 bishop b4
not knight c2 c3 bishop before yeah i
mean it could of course be that shakira
that he just wants to take the game into
more solid uh territory
i think that would uh make sense what do
you think
yeah i mean mommy darb is playing black
uh he is obviously a very combative
player and he's beaten magnus before in
fact not just once
with that being said he's not gonna
force anything
and uh if the position demands solid
play and if he has the capacity to make
you know a relatively easy draw he's
going to do that and no we don't have
knight c3 we have a catalan
once again i mean magnus he's been
playing the catalan pretty consistently
here
as white if i'm
if i'm not mistaken then well we'll see
uh which direction social he takes on c4
yes he does he takes on c4
the catalan is among the most
theoretical openings in existence both
sides but especially black has a very
vast choice of different systems
and takes c4 is one of so many
possible moves
so here what do we expect some big
theoretical battle or do you think one
of the players is going to
to try and bring us first surprise er in
the near future
well magnus rarely goes down the
absolute main path um what he likes
doing is he likes playing a very
mainstream opening you know there's two
approaches to playing offbeat people
think about playing one before that's
not magnus's style magnus likes playing
mainstream openings and then finding
rare ideas early in those openings
um mom and dad though going for not the
most common system dc4 and now bishop
before check
now generally if i remember correctly
this leads to
the line i mean white usually plays
bishop d2 here
and then black's main move is to support
the bishop on b4 with the move a5
um and this leads to an interesting
struggle where like many lines of the
catalan why doesn't rush to recover the
the c4 upon white's top priority
is to control the center and get active
development
so you get a very very complex struggle
castles castles and here i see that
white's main move is to reposition this
bishop to g5 we'll see if they go down
this line or something else but
many many possibilities here yeah we do
have bishop d2a5 by the way
okay so we'll see uh what magnus is
still busy playing with his face mask
which now goes into the the side
uh pocket
and uh actually well uh kudos to our
team working behind the team because
we're gonna quickly show you the rewind
of the hand uh shake fail between prague
and karjakin which was another example
very funny to start today with sorry
dania didn't you i think that's
something everybody can relate to in
these times and days
everybody hi do i am i supposed to put
my hand out is it a fist bump you never
know
for sure and well as magnus takes uh his
first uh thing of the game maybe we can
quickly bring up the the bird's eye view
let's do it
okay
well we have actually uh report uh
report vidit is still on the second move
as rehard playing g3 on move two
not the most common response to d4
knight f6 and another rarity in duda
against
espanko shall we have a quick look at
that one even though it's only three
moves here
okay
so
well what else what is there to say
we've seen quite a bit of innovation in
this position in this tournament we saw
g4
by mr mohammed yarov
and now we see bishop f4 by duda which
is a little bit less uncommon but you
don't see this move
very often in a nimzo structure and i
wonder if jan will follow this up with
the move knight d2 because if he goes
knight c3 then we've transposed into a
nimzo indian with bishop f4 that doesn't
make any sense to me i'm expecting
knight d2
and then what could be
what could be the idea behind having
developed
this way we see we're already on almost
new
new territory here
and i only see one game in the database
castles
castles and now i see the move knight
gf3
as as being played but something tells
me that duda might be going for an early
a3
i mean it seems like the point of knight
d2 is to force black to to trade uh the
bishop for the knight as black often
does in the nimzo but in the nimzo white
has to recapture with a pawn and
obviously that's a problem here white
preserves the integrity of his pawn
structure so we might see a situation
like this
very curious to me that here there are
at least a narrow data database and no
games
in what looks like
not such a strange position
no i would imagine that bishop f4
i mean is something that somebody might
play if they're i don't know a london
player who's accidentally played c4
obviously duda does not belong to that
category and 92 has indeed been played
but andre responding with knight c6
now that's interesting
now that is interesting because that
blocks the c pawn yeah knight c6 in
general quite rare that we see the
knight developed there uh attacking the
pawn on on d4 i guess the most natural
response is to develop the knight to f3
absolutely i don't think we're going to
see three that walks right into
uh the very nasty move knight e4
so knight gf3 is to be expected
and something tells me that the point of
knight c6 is to orient
uh black is orienting himself toward e5
i think andre is going to go d6
and for instance we might see a3 bishop
takes the two queen takes d2
and the point of putting the knight on
c6 is is to prepare the e5 pawn break
as early as possible and that makes
sense given that what is position the
bishop on f4 because now e5 is going to
come with tempo
i wonder if andre has analyzed this
before he
took about five minutes which is not as
long as i would have expected him to
take if this was completely new to him
yeah i agree i'm also surprised to see
uh to see him play
quite quickly
and well i'm also curious to see how
he's recovered on the rest day from
what was really quite a painful loss
against danish giri
two days ago he seemed to be taking it
while i saw he posted a picture of the
game the same evening on his social
media channel saying first loss of 2022
um but didn't seem to two-phase dania
let's have a quick look uh at the
pairings that we have uh today going on
elsewhere this one anushkiri he's one
tree on the trot he's playing sam
shankland that would be for sure an
interesting game as anish tries to make
his way back to the top you're the
inventor racer against duboff i
highlighted that one before niels
cornelius he's been struggling can
fabian do something with the black
pieces a report against with it we saw
that got off to a slow start but all in
all some very very exciting uh matchups
once again
absolutely and you mentioned fabiano
caruana trying to do something with the
black pieces fiona that is particularly
important he's on 50 and what's exciting
about this part of the tournament
uh is that the players who form the
peloton 50 even plus one they now have
to take pretty serious risk with both
colors and i see i think we see that
reflected in
in fabiano's choice of opening i feel
like robert hess might have something to
say about it i was gonna i was literally
just gonna ask you that
he has played a french
what's funny is the i played the french
three times in my chess career i have a
record of zero and three and one of
those losses actually came against fabi
um in the 2017 u.s championship never
again
that's very funny do you remember
fabiano playing the french in recent
memory i do not i i honestly
i mean i might look this up during the
break but
i don't know if he's ever played the
french i'm something tells me that he
has just because he's played so many
games but
it probably has been a while
yeah so for sure fabiano he is out for a
fight today and neil's choosing the
the advanced variation
just like in karjakin report by the way
interestingly enough two fringes and two
advances
there should be two
okay this is one of the viable bishop d7
is not the most popular
we were discussing this in the uh
karjakin game queen b6 here
is is the the most popular theoretically
and knight h6 was previously played in
this tournament
okay so bishop b2 knight g7 this time
the knight swinging to g6 less common
than positioning the knight on f5 but
obviously
i'm sure fabi has studied this very very
carefully bishop e3 bishop b7 and white
completes his development and then plays
rookie one and fabi begins queen side
expansion of the move a5 fiona that's
that's pretty typical in the french you
often see these kinds of moves
black definitely wants to play a4 and if
allowed black wants to push the spawn
all the way to a3
let me ask you here dania because i have
no experience in the advanced french on
either
side and i always
wonder when i look at this position i
kind of
like the look of it for white but then i
take a second look and i think okay if
it were me playing what do i do next and
very often it isn't so clear to me what
the plan is for white so can you maybe
try and
help me out and give some explanations
welcome to the club and that's one of
the
one of the top things about this
position the computer always says
white's better partially because of the
space advantage white does have a space
event white has a pawn on e5
now black's plan is generally pretty
clear-cut black wants to play on the
queen say a4 and queen a5
black has a lot of improving moves one
of the things to pay attention to is who
releases the central tension first will
it be black playing c takes d4 or will
it be white playing d takes c5 that also
happens sometimes now in terms of a plan
i've generally seen white play on the
king side as we see
uh grindeli is playing a3 taking the b4
square under control and this maneuver
knight f1 knight g3 and perhaps even
knight h5
fiona can serve to bring this very
important attacker onto the king's side
i've often seen games where white
sacrifices on g7 you sometimes see white
pushing this h pawn up the board even
sacrificing it and this bishop from e2
i think nils is actually preparing to
reposition it to d3 so white is
definitely thinking violent thoughts on
the king side
i like that um
i'm now i'm a lot more excited and now
we've gotten some information dania that
fabiano has played the french actually
last a year against arianteri here in
vaikanse
waited again sorry atari i wonder what
variation that was
yeah probably aryan didn't play the
advance because
the advance has not been you know that
popular at the top for for many years
now and it's fascinating to see that
both players who face the french have
have defaulted
to the events because there is no way
that niels expected the french it was an
exchange
variation
oh god
i kind of regret having asked that
and that game ended in a draw
wait wait wait are you saying that an
exchange french internet run no
that is i find that hard to believe
fiona stop spreading false news
all right well here at least today we've
got
plenty more action uh in fact another
single pawn has been exchanged here yet
nope
and my guess is that either c64 is going
to happen as our first exchange or
or we're going to see black playing f6
yeah so very often right black is going
to try and open uh try and get this f6
break in and how how does wright react
to that
yeah generally white has to take on f6
and you know if flag plays it here
then
black is going to lose well he takes f6
bishop f6 you don't always want to take
this spot on c5 even if it's free
because it gives white a big pawn it
gives black a big pawn center
but this is a double-edged sword because
the e5 square is now very weak
and the bishop on e7 it used to control
the c5 score so the white now has this
move knight b3 and the knight is heading
over to c5 the other night might go to
e5
so i would say it's premature right now
but at a later stage anybody who plays
the french knows that f6 is an idea
virtually in every variation
yeah so
would you say this is quite a concrete
position where at every turn again the
players are going to have to to think
okay is f6 now do i continue on the the
queen side or do you think fabio still
this is still familiar territory here
no i think somewhere around here he's
probably familiar with the general ideas
but not this specific position which is
um as evidenced by the fact that he's
taking his time uh it this is what i
think a complex position is this is what
i think it means for a position to be
complex there's a lot of ideas
and you have to consider those ideas on
every move do i play c takes d4 do i
play c4
do i play a4 you know when do i play f6
and white has to ask himself the same
questions from the other side am i do i
want to allow c takes d4 in this
particular version but
now that i'm looking at this position
for a couple of minutes i'm beginning to
white's position is beginning to grow on
me i like this idea of maneuvering the
bishop to d3 and then heading heading to
h5 with the knight fabia is going to
have to prove something on the queen
side
yeah it's a it's also an interesting
match-up from the tournament situation
because uh fabiano i think as uh
as confirmed by his opening choice he is
looking here to fight for the for the
full point with the black pieces but
niels uh he's not had a good tournament
he's on two out of eight and he is
almost in a spot where he has nothing to
lose at this stage like he might as well
go all out from that point of view i
think it's a very exciting matchup
and you know that's what makes nils
great um that's what makes
you know that's a raises everyone's
eyebrows in a good way he he plays
uncompromising chess
every game and it doesn't matter where
he is in the tournament standings he's
like a renaissance man you know he's he
would fit right in at the cafe de la
rajancin
in the 1800s you know and the 1700s with
philidor and i love that about him he's
got that spirit by the way dania and
then we'll move on from here we're
getting some more information that
fabiano played the french against mvl as
well in the speedchest championship
that was
so the match
their most recent match from november
2021 and that went down this same line
until move 10 where fabiano didn't
choose a5 but rook c8 instead
fascinating so they're following an scc
game yeah uh roxier makes sense no and i
mean that in a good way
it just tells you that these players
take the sec very seriously they play
their main main lines against it
i'm curious if niels is familiar with
that as well but i wouldn't be surprised
if he was i guess rick c8 commits very
early to the c file and after a3 the
issue for black is that
and the computer confirms this after cdc
demand you would love to play knight b4
here and there's a small problem with
that move and
if you if you're not playing knight
before then one could ask what is the
rook
really doing on c8 so a5 is definitely
some home cooking
and uh it's almost certainly an
improvement a conscious improvement over
c8
very interesting we'll come back here
for sure for now let's go back to
the bird's eye view i notice at first
sight an unusual very unusual pawn
structure in pragnanda against karjakin
yes
and an unusual uh peace imbalance do
bishops against two nights this early
well we have something pretty crazy
going on and report vitted as well it's
some sort of souped-up catalan
weird pawn box line
uh that i think vivid is intensely
unfamiliar with i'll give you the choice
fiona we also have a pretty conventional
rye lopez in ven forest against duboff
so we could get to that game a little
bit later when i i wanted diverges from
theory uh what catches your eye more
pragnanda or report
pregnant and that just because more has
happened although
maybe we start with reports in so little
actually has happened uh so we can
people talk through that and then we'll
go from report to pragmata indeed that's
in the upper left of your screen let's
switch to that game
and we only have four moves played and
yet vidid has already burned 17 minutes
how did this all happen well after
knight f6 rehard playing g3
uh the reason traditionally this move
has never been recommended as a testing
theoretical move is that black can play
d5
and now black can kind of play a london
setup with bishop f5 fiona followed by
e6 and h6 and you basically get a
reverse london system which is not that
appealing
uh but this line has been revived in
recent years and just really really
quickly let me show one of the reasons
why um a lot of players have started
playing this new ish setup where white
plays c4
uh and then
you know white goes knight c3 black puts
together the kind of london setup and
then later on in this type of position
white brings the knight back to d2 and
then essentially goes for the e4 pawn
break
and this idea has really enlivened uh
this line and that's why i bid it uh i
think deciding against d5 may be fearing
preparation so he goes uh sorry
refraining from bishop f5 and in this
position he goes c5 to which rehard
responds c4
and this is the position on the board i
mean how can we have a quick look at has
this been
seen before i guess maybe yes but it has
not it has i don't know well actually
we've transposed into a position with
over 100 games and most of those
continue e6
and here's the hilarious thing this is
potentially a transposition to a
semitash
so if white plays knight f3 here
i mean this is going to be there
yeah there's literally 2 000 games now
so this is either a cemetery or a
catalan
it's a catalan of black takes on c4
and white castles and then it's a
semitash
if black goes knife c6 and then
if you have cd ed knight c3 this is the
mainline samutara so a lot of
transpositional potential
in this ridiculous variation
very funny so maybe vidit taking quite a
bit of time to to figure out
what he wants to retranspose so i guess
he could also play a move that would
lead us to new territory can we maybe
quickly look at what either capture in
the center is any of them
terrible is any of them any good what do
you think
well the engine likes d take c4 we'll
look at that in a second c takes d4 is
also
a distinct possibility now i see that
most of the time white plays knight f3
i don't understand anything about this
position i mean dc4 i guess
wow dc4 queen takes d4 is the main line
so white essentially gives up a pawn and
goes for this end game this is a common
occurrence though the pawn on c4 is a
weakness white can recover it by going
by going knight a3 and this bishop on g2
causes
a lot of problems in black's position it
makes it hard to develop
um
okay
so i would say that's a little bit less
appealing do you take c4 is really
interesting
and here again most people have got
knight f3
and once again we've transposed to a a
line of the catalan
that normally occurs via the move order
i don't even want to attempt to show a
move or transposes you i think
everyone's head is hurting anyway
um suffice it to say this is the
mainline catalan e6 castles
knight c6 and
i think many people have seen this
position before queen a4 is a movie here
95 welcome to modern chess
and with it he has captured i think on
d4
okay so he waited for me to say that and
now he makes me you know look like a
fool right
um
i mean he did spend a long time though
and
didn't seem too
uh
too convinced i'll say that to make you
feel better than you
thank you i appreciate that it does now
i i do want to point one thing out which
is that queen takes d4 is a no-go uh
because it walks right into knight c6
and that's not in the spirit of the
variation i felt like c takes d5
uh is interesting here but in any case
rehard goes knight f3
and so
we are
probably going to see d takes c4 in this
position and then i wonder if freehard
is in fact going to play queen takes d4
yeah well with it
we saw some excellent preparation by him
two days ago in his game against niels
grandelus if you missed that you can
check out our rapid recap video on the
chess.com youtube channel but today
clearly he is the one that's been taken
by surprise
we will let him
uh ponder
under his next move for now shall we
move on to to pragnanda
absolutely let's move on to mr prague
and that is the position with two
knights against two bishops this kind of
structure can only really occur in the
london system and that is indeed
what we saw let's quickly run through
uh the moves so we had what started off
as a traditional london prague
going e3 knight c6 this is all very
standard fare and curry i can going
knight h5 which is a relatively new move
um it is the engine's recommendation i
believe at a pretty tight at a pretty
high depth so we've seen this move
played quite a few times by decent
players recently yeah decent players
like sergey koryakin prague responds by
taking on c5
sergey chops off the bishop
and so we get the structure where white
is up upon but obviously
white has serious weaknesses all across
the board
and
through the move a6
uh kuryakyn essentially forces prague
into
trading the knight on c6
takes takes queen d2
castles and now to make matters even
more interesting h4
by prague
just uh going for h5 going for the king
side attack
what a position okay so i have a few
questions here um first of all how do
you feel
about a white extra white extra pawn
um i guess here it's not a matter of
black winning it back for now it seems
like white can hold on to the extra pawn
on on well both both of those weird
pawns on c5 and f4
and i think people need to understand
that black isn't playing this line in
order to you know just like in the
catalan this is a sacrifice you know
black is sacrificed upon in for the for
long run compensation two bishops and an
initiative
black could try the move bishop h6
uh but the point of this move was not to
win
the pawn because white simply has the
move g3 the engine was
initially recommending this crazy
follow-up e5 another sacrifice
and if knight takes c5 black actually
wins to the move rookie a this is a
funny position black threatens rook
takes c5 because of the pin
and if you move the queen then obviously
you run into f6 so
that's something sergey could consider
uh after e5 prague
doesn't have to take in fact you can go
h5
with a very chaotic position but the
second option i was contemplating here
is just going bishop g4 and sticking
this bishop onto this weak square
uh but here prague will play most
probably knight bd4 and the knights
support each other
this other knight has access to the e5
square potentially so
if black isn't precise here yeah for
sure he can slip into a situation where
you know he doesn't have full
compensation for the pawn
and well i guess if i were a sergey
karjakin for now the time situation
indicates that
like i don't think that karjakin is in
any prep here at least nothing that he
has seen
recently i don't know what the chances
are that he's seen this position before
but bishop h6 is a move i guess that you
especially if you follow it up with the
pond
pun
sacrifice with e5 that you're less
likely to make if you
feel your opponent is still in prep or
would you disagree
for sure no i i think korea can probably
seize this idea i just want to go back
through this line because
when you're calculating and you're out
of prep and you see this move h5 and
imagine
going down this line allowing h takes g6
and according to the engine
the ridiculous f takes g6 leads an
advantage for black the idea being you
just give away this bishop like you
normally do in chess and then play f
takes g3 the point is that the knight is
hanging this pawn on g3 is incredibly
dangerous and after knight bd4 black
gets this last piece out of bishop g4
and all of a sudden white's position
collapses i mean the attack is coming
from all sides the knight is hanging the
king is caught on the crossfire and
black is better
uh but
you know when you're analyzing with an
engine all of this looks relatively
logical yeah i mean ftxg3 makes sense
but it's impossible to put yourself in
the shoes of someone who's never seen
this position before and it's so easy to
abandon this line when you see the move
hg6 because it does look like it wins
the game for white
yeah crazy stuff and uh well very well
still quite early doors here but we see
uh karjak in there
i think he is going to take a little bit
of time
h4 once again uh appearing on the board
and
i like i like prague's play
very enterprising
um we are going to take our first quick
break of the day
uh for now and then we'll be back here
with all the action from wine 9 so don't
go anywhere we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to round nine
here at the tata steel chess tournament
and dania we just set it there towards
the end of our break i think we were
both
looking in one direction and that's the
top left but before we jump
into the magnus carlsen game uh what
catches ui elsewhere what do we need to
maybe very quickly update on
sure well i'll just do a you know a very
quick recap of all the positions and
then we'll go to get to magnus starting
in your top left corner with report
vidit we have that unconventional
catalan type situation and report is
indeed taken on d4 with the queen so we
might get that end game we'll revisit
that a little later gary shanklin we
haven't looked at but it's a very
symmetrical end game
uh not much to say there uh although
we'll stop by in a little while you can
see jkd castling queenside against
tessepanko that's crazy as well
and that's that seminimzo indian with
the bishop on f4
then we have a rue lopez in van forest
against dubov uh still a pretty
conventional position we have that crazy
london in prague kuryakyn where sergey
is still contemplating his response to
h4 fiona and the french between
grendelius and caruana where we see in
fact niels uh according to the
instructions of the great french expert
naredinsky has indeed
uh played bishop d3 applause
good stuff and yeah so some of those
games shaping up nicely but of course we
are going to take a deep dive on carlson
versus mamadiro mamadirov because
well we left us off a short while ago
but it has really come to life already
oh it absolutely has the full catalan
vibes here where black has done
everything in his power to cling to that
pawn on c6 and white is trying to reap
the benefits and establish full
compensation let's have a quick run
through so we saw mahmud yarov grab on
on c4 then we saw bishop b4 jack and a5
this is uh one of the
not the most popular line but probably
second tier in terms of popularity
okay magnus castling now we were
discussing the move bishop g5 here
but magnus playing e3 which is rare and
see this is exactly what i'm talking
about this is what magnus loves to do
he'll take a common opening and then
he'll find
very uncommon sidelines on move seven
move seven through ten generally
shock responding with rook a6 which is
not as bizarre of a move as it appears
what is the idea of this move well in
order to answer that question fiona we
have to understand the idea of e3 and
the idea of e3 let's make a random move
is to prepare knight e5
now the d4 pawn isn't hanging and black
has no way of defending c4 because you
can't play b5 you lose the rook now you
should be able to see why chakra goes
for k6 uh so that he can respond
galactically on pinning
and the second aspect of the prophylaxis
you might say well why didn't you go
over k7 then well if you go rook a7 then
after knight e5 b5 a4 you're not going
to be able to go c6 because white has
two attackers on that square so the rook
on a6 fulfills two purposes it unpins
itself
and it defends the c6 square which will
help chakri argos c6 in fact in the
current position in the game
um shankara has just gone
uh c6 and magnus has responded by
developing his knight to c3
and hitting shakira's pawn on d5 the
question now is whether sakura will
defend it by going rook b6 uh will he go
queen b6 or will he make uh some
different will he give up the pawn on b5
the engine likes bishop b7 for
example what's the idea bishop b7 so if
white now captures on b5
so takes takes takes
and now simply rook b6 according to the
computer
interesting so basically black's opened
up the diagonal for his bishop
and now black is the one after knight a3
who sacrifices upon with bishop b4 and
goes for the initiative if white starts
grabbing well if right grabs on c4 he
loses a piece if you look at his bishop
on d2
it's protected only by the knight and
after bishop takes f3
bishop takes before black and recapture
with the rook
and uh hit the queen on c4 so
uh that's an interesting approach not
something that occurs to me intuitively
it doesn't
i mean jarv has done so much to defend
the pawn on c4 and now to all of a
sudden give up upon b5
uh seems counter-intuitive
although if anyone could be tempted by
that it would be him of course i'm sure
if he if he saw those positions we got
to in the end with the initiative
um but yeah i'm very curious and if we
defend the pawn on on b5
which
option do you prefer rook b6 or queen b6
i prefer rook b6 because you know queen
b6 is a little inconsistent you've
already played rook a6 you made that
investment uh you know you might at
least squeeze the most out of that rook
you know that's like buying a bike uh
and then
commuting to work by car every day
um you already played rook a6 go rook b6
and what worries me though is that
magnus will redirect his attention to
the center and play the move e4
and these pawns are pretty intimidating
fiona i mean white can go not
pawn f2 to d1 but rook f1 to d1 this
bishop from d2 can migrate over to e3
and then you know there's going to be
the possibility of a central
breakthrough with d5 so mamadyarov has
to very soberly
evaluate you know these various options
this is a critical moment and i will be
very impressed if he goes bishop b7 here
we're impressed yes would you be
surprised
um not nothing shakur does or surprises
me anymore i mean he's so capable
of finding these kinds of moves that i
think it's totally within his
possibility i don't think rook b6 is a
mistake
uh but i i feel like bishop b7 might be
the practically best option and it might
be the one that magnus finds most
annoying
and well i think uh shakira as you as
you said i think he also understands
this is
probably one of the first critical
moments of the game so
very likely he will invest a little bit
of time here so that gives us time to go
back
to the bird's eye
back to the bird's eye view
and maybe we can check in with jordan
van furis against daniel dub of that
rory lopez which we haven't seen yet
let's do it uh absolutely that's our
only rue lopez game of the round
and jordan has by now established
himself as a specialist
in uh in in in various ray lopez systems
let's have a look at which line they
ended up going down
it started off as a main line fiona
bishop b7 rookie one b5 there should be
three castles
uh now when four is playing d3 which is
one of several anti-martial setups uh
the main move here is c3 and then d5
leads to the marshall gambit
uh so jordan going d3 to which duba
responds d6
uh this transposes back into the sort of
d3 system which is considered the main
sideline for white that sounds like an
oxymoron but i mean the most popular
sideline knight beauty two knight c6
these are all very normal rue lopez
moves nothing much to say here a4 b4
white carves out the c4 square four his
knight
um
a5 and bishop b3 repositioning the
bishop
back onto b3 where it's perfectly safe
because black doesn't have the move
knight a5 anymore
and dubois playing rook v8 this is the
position currently on the board fiona
and one option that
uh jumps out at me straight away here is
the move d4
move d4 what if white tries to blast
open the center
and what could happen here
is
b c b c c d c d
and white could take on d4 but i can't
capture back
but why can try a further breakthrough
with e5 i don't know just an interesting
idea and let's just show why we cannot
capture on d4
uh because that bishop on b3
whoops
yep that bishop on b3 is hanging
but uh this is common on the right lopez
i mean you often play d4 with the
intention of recapturing later or not
recapturing at all
and this certainly looks scary
you know
after takes takes that pressure on f7
grows
immense
and there's a fork on c6 so probably
black shouldn't take on e5 black should
move this knight to d5 but this has to
be calculated very carefully by both
players
for sure and if we go back to the moment
where you put well
after d4
does black have to initiate all these
exchanges at all
probably not i mean black
i guess has the
queen c7 here
black i guess has the move queen c7 here
but
that allows white to play d5 and shove
this pawn forward and then the knight
doesn't have any good squares i mean
knight d8
oh 98 there's a really cool tactic
actually so a takes b4 should probably
be thrown in
and then white can play knight f takes
e5
and if d takes e5 white pushes the pawn
through d6 and you can see how
unpleasant this became white black is
just really passive
uh so
i find d4 to be very attractive and
i think that van forest is you can sense
the wheel spinning in his head i mean
he's he's thinking about it for sure
because i think just when we joined that
game we saw eureka and we saw the the
jacket come off
and
very often that's a that's a sign
the players understand the game is
rolling up the sleeves exactly
that's the proverbial rolling up of
sleeves i'm about to take 25 minutes and
calculate something complex
exactly and i'm i agree with you d4 must
be what uh jordan
is looking at do you think there is at
the back of the player's mind like a
battle of go of ongoing of well our boss
magnus is here let's try and let's try
and impress him by taking out uh our
colleague
oh absolutely there's some competition
uh going on no question about it and
both of these players
you know i'm sure they're on very good
terms but you know the spirit of
friendly competition definitely prevails
among two seconds
uh no no question about that
okay well we'll leave jordan uh we'll
leave your then to it
uh bring back the bird's eye view
we haven't seen the anish uh geary
against shanklin game yet that's on my
part at least completely deliberate i'm
finding nothing to get excited there at
the moment but uh look at pregnant
um ooh h4 bishop g4 and he still played
h5
incredible yes
hey i don't know bishop on g4 do i look
like i care i absolutely do not care and
i i will say that in the gary shankling
game
the end game looks completely
symmetrical i think sam does have a
couple problems to solve so fiona i'll
give you the choice we can go straight
to straight to the prague game or we can
stop at the anushkiri hotel
look at that end game let's get the
hotel out of the way first let's go to a
niche and maybe uh just as we pull up
the game we'll also very quickly before
we dive in here bring up uh the
standings have a look after eight rounds
uh well at the top we see magnus carlsen
tied with shakhim ahmadirov of course
this is huge because they are facing off
against each other
today but then a couple of players in
close pursuit anishkiri and vidit
gujarati and well we'll see anisha's
game right now he has the white pieces
and he'll be eager to make the most out
of them
indeed we have a very tightly packed
field two very big ramen this round is
huge and someone in the chat says in a
niche hotel only draws are served indeed
in the hotel restaurant
you have draw soup and filet mignon of
draw
it's actually incredible no how long
this reputation has
it is crazy and you know what it's
perpetuated by these by these
commentators for constantly harping on
it even though anish uh has changed
himself in the last couple of months and
has put together
uh several performances that have
nothing to do with his old self and yet
these
you know these terrible commentators
just keep on harping on it you said
couple of months i don't know
did you mean couple of years or did you
mean a couple of years no i mean there
was a there was a last year's status
deal i think last year's tata steel was
the turning point um if if you remember
i think we were talking about it then
he he won a couple of games there that
you know in a style that he hadn't
played yeah uh for many years and i
think max warmerdom uh who
don't quote me on this but i think he
was the second during the tournament was
talking about no marx was the second of
jordan and ervin lammy was the second of
anish
or evan or somebody was talking i think
one and i was still talking about
anishin and sort of his change in style
so that's what i would date it back to
almost exactly a year
and i i think really anish got this
drawing wrap at what candidates
tournament was it 2016 when he drew all
his games uh
that's worse
oh the meme of the the made with the
queen and king
that is hilarious
you know what i love the most you know
what i love the most about this photo
fiona it's something perhaps
that that isn't immediately obvious it's
the the smile and you should the gleeful
like you know it's like that expression
in descartes or just business like all
right mate anisha is smiling gleefully
well today he isn't smiling gleefully at
least just yet we'll see if he has more
reason to do so at the end of the game
but uh dania you were saying that this
position maybe isn't as dry as it looks
magnus would love to have this with
white no white is definitely slightly
better no question about it uh this
comes from a reverse king's indian or
kings indian attack
uh let's have a look at how an end game
was reached so quickly sam
uh now anish actually allowing a reverse
perk generally white plays d4 in this
position are c4
and each allowing e5 and this one could
say transpose into a perk with colors
reversed where you know sam has played
g6 now by the way
this is a viable system uh from the
white side as well if we just
you know pretend that black had played
the perk
uh the system
with with g3
uh
in
in this position in these types of
positions is is very common
uh so knight f6 and now g3
and this is considered to be a pretty
foolproof way of getting nice position
with white now let's call those reverse
things are a little bit different
because white is an extra tempo but
anyways e5 d3 knight c6 e4 and sam
accepting initials offer uh to get the
game into an end game takes takes bishop
g4
c3 covering the d4 square
knight f6 and bd2
castles threatening knight takes e4 so
anish moves his rook away
sam activates his bishop we have a trade
and in this position anish is
threatening knight takes e5 as well as
the nesting of knight g5 uh so sam
deciding to trade another pair of minor
pieces and the reason i say that white
is slightly better well there's a couple
of things first of all white's bishop is
not that bad uh it can drop down to g4
if it wants to and if you look at these
light squares you know it can also move
down to e2 and later to c4 the knight on
c4 i really like as well and i like the
possibility of uh migrating it over to
d5 potentially so i think white is a
tiny bit better but if sam is careful he
definitely should hold this position and
make a draw i mean you've mentioned it
so many times before sam
uh he's uh
calculating these i think one of the
players it's always interesting to to
follow him
if you aren't doing so yet do it go
follow him on twitter and other social
media because i think he's very open
about you know his um
his work and how he approaches thing and
a really interesting guy and so hard
working
and uh yeah
we've seen him defend perfectly against
uh magnus carlsen two days ago
and today i've got faith i have to say
in sam here
yeah he's one of the most hardworking
players that i know maybe the most
hardworking he's
written two books now
uh which have been very well received
and this is on top of maintaining a
punishing tournament schedule
uh you know and i'm very happy for sam
he he worked so hard to cross 2700
uh he was in the sort of 2600 swamp for
a very long time but he kept at it uh
and he he's trained very intensively
with jacob ogart which is a
collaboration that he's written about
and talked about a lot
and and that really sharpened up his
play obviously i think what he's known
for the most is his opening preparation
which really is second to none
yeah and no wonder magnus got him
on his team a few years ago for now
we'll leave anish
to it anish doesn't look too impressed
right now we'll see
yeah i mean anish is probably saying to
himself i have to grind out
you know this long end game which is
very likely to end in a draw
uh but he's also not risking
yeah so we'll come back here
in a bit let's go to pragnanda and
karyakin now where absolutely
it looks like sergey is still thinking
and look at prague's clock times
could it be that this is still his prep
it absolutely could be um i don't rule
that out he's got an hour 38 he spent
two minutes in fact i think that's the
likeliest scenario and i'll tell you
more
after bishop takes h5 the engine
suggests something absolutely crazy
which is
just to play rook takes h5
and the point is not that there's
checkmate immediately the point is
you're going for a long-term attack
you're going to castle along
on the next move you're going to play
rook h1
that pawn is going to be essentially
indefensible and the long-term attack
down the h file combined with the
excellently placed knights the first
knight can come to d4 the other knight
can come out to e5 and white has
essentially both positional and tactical
compensation
for
the exchange i think it's very likely
that this type of position is what
prague is shooting for now objectively i
don't think black is worse here but if
you you know if you're dealing dally
around for a couple of moves
uh you could get under you could get put
under tremendous pressure i mean for
example if black pushes this pawn to a4
that only helps white go where he wants
to go anyway knight bd4
e6 rook takes and now even f5
already looks pretty overwhelming and
rook takes h5 knight g5
white's got very serious play on the
king side if this is in fact prep fiona
this is
very impressive work
by prague and his team
not just very impressive also very
worrisome for karjakin when you
are in this situation and karyakin he
knows that that prague is still familiar
with this and this can get scary very
very quickly
i guess taking on f3 i guess some people
might be tempted to inflict those
triples f pawns
um but here i guess white is going to
make use of the the g file
yeah i mean look white still has an
extra pawn let's not forget that and
you're absolutely on the money why can
you use the g file why can use those
tripled pawns as battering rams white
has to move f5 in the future
uh if you think about it if black plays
a move like e5 i would very seriously
contemplate
uh playing f5 maybe not in this exact
position but
the point as you indicated is that the g
file opens up and i mean this position
is already lost like king h8 and now
there's rook takes g7
and the classic zigzag queen g5 queen f6
followed by the lobster fencer mate with
h6 so that's totally going to happen
that's how the game is going to end but
this is just an illustration of white's
attacking potential when you're
attacking you care a lot less about the
pawn structure and a lot more about what
open files you have and what pathways
you have for your pieces and also
the potential that you have to use your
pawns as i said as battering rams to
shatter your opponent's game position
that's what prague is trying to do here
and well we've looked at both both
captures and i have to say none of them
look super tempting to me so
what are the other options for for black
well i think between the two captures
bishop takes h5 is far likely i mean g
takes h5 is
is a possibility uh that it wouldn't
rule out necessarily but it just doesn't
look appealing prague is going to
centralize his knight and this bishop is
anchored to the pawn but it's also tied
down to it and white has ideas like
knight h2 later on
not appealing
um if black doesn't touch the h pawn
well i guess a move like a5 can be
considered you know starting starting
the queenside play and the funny thing
is the engine likes to move h6 so the
engine just proposes closing down the
king's side and essentially claiming
that white is up a pawn and perhaps even
castling king's side that's what makes
this scary for black it's like black
doesn't even have material
to show for uh getting attacked black is
down upon and white seems to have his
own compensation
i am loving this uh for prague here
so far
i have to say i'm rooting for him a
little bit not in this game in
particular but in the tournament uh he's
towards the the bottom of this landings
but he has one win against neil's
already he's been showing some really
interesting chess and um i'm loving what
i'm seeing and
uh
go prague overall not just today but i'm
i'm a fan
and
yeah he's and he's i mean he's such a
sweet
kid such a nice kid so wish him
wish him
can speak wishing him all the best let's
go back to the bird's eye view dania
indeed and i i have i met him virtually
and i can confirm you know very mature
uh
very sweet and uh you know
players like that are so easy to root
for and he's got so many years of
promising chess ahead of him okay well
let's have a look at that bird's eye
view we see
developments in quite a few of the games
we can see in the carlson mounted yard
game over on your top left
uh chakriar
has
uh decided on rook b6 and
you know as we were discussing carlson
did indeed play e4
and grabbed control of the center so
we'll keep an eye on that one but it's
been a while since we checked in on two
games duda ecepenko which has really
gone in a very interesting direction as
well as glendalius against caruana which
of those games catches your eye fiona
let's maybe start with uh dude i see
panko there in the top right corner and
then we can come go from there too
guandelius
carrana but yeah this one ever since
white castle queenside
i've gotten a lot more excited here
yep knight d2 knight c6 we we saw this
moment a3 we had a trade and andre
indeed orienting himself toward e5
but yeah do that this is not a mistake
in the transmission he has castle
queenside this early in a nimzo indian
you don't see that every day queen e7 e3
e5
and the bishop
repositions to g5 both players very
likely well yeah definitely out of
preparation if you look at the time
stamps
um
well the most tempting thing for andre
here is is probably to go h6
and then
meet bishop h4 with either g5 or fiona
there's an interesting idea here knight
e4
uh quite a typical little shot in nimzo
indian positions this forces a
transition
into an endgame now the bishop on f1 is
under under fire so
black white has to take and black takes
and the set game seems
a lot closer to equality really than to
anything else and yes
as i say that yeah
he's got h6 now we'll do the take on f6
nope he's gone bishop h4 and now i
really wonder if andre it seems in his
style to play an id4 a very solid move
but definitely he can also throw in g5
which is a more ambitious approach g5
bishop g3 and now go 94 it really
depends on
how he's feeling today i think and well
let's have a quick look actually at this
position after g5 um bishop g3
94 the queen will have to move where
we'll go to
yeah i don't know i mean queen c2
queen c2 bishop f5 there is bishop d3
so
but but the engine is suggesting that
black can start with e takes defense i
mean that's very brave opening up that
e5 like that definitely
but the point the point is that now
bishop d3 is not a move it because you
give up the d4 square the d4 pawn
so concretely works out for black and
for that reason
it might be more circumspect
for white to drop the queen back to e1
okay queenie one now the question is
black
i guess we don't have to take on g3
immediately because that bishop is going
nowhere uh so i wonder do we just
develop the uh the bishop from theater
can we try and um push h5 and see what
what white does
yeah h5 is interesting it essentially
forces white to to play f3 that's the
only way not to get your bishop trapped
then we'll have a trade and you know
white's got a lot of pressure down the
eight down the h file black's king
doesn't have any safe squares so it's
probably high time in this position for
black to go for the queen trade so we
have we'll have a queen trade
and this is another interesting type of
end game where both sides have their
have their pros and cons you know white
is pressured down down the h file and
black has
slightly flimsy kingside pawns but on
the other hand white has this pawn on d4
which is a concern
and if you defend it with your rook then
you leave the e file wide open and black
is immediately gonna occupied with his
rook once again i think the closest this
is this end game is very close to being
dynamically equal
so a big decision here for mr esapenko
for sure
he will also i think be investing some
time here as the two main options we
just saw g5 or knight e4 lead to very
different types of positions
shall we move on to niels grandelius and
fabiano carolina
particularly because some interesting
stuff is happening there
we have a positional pawn sacrifice by
fabi now look at the time situation
niels with an hour and a half heavy his
58 minutes after only 14 moves
that's interesting
wow fabiano is spending a lot of time do
we know where that time is starting from
a4 he invested quite a bit into every
move
i think he took a lot on a4 and then he
took even more on
so here we go he decided to be the first
to release the tension with c takes d4
now he's gone h6 which is a bit of a
cryptic move i think what he's doing
is preventing niels from ever really
putting a knight on g5 because this idea
can get very very scary
but i have a couple of questions about
h6 first of all are we not scared are we
not scared of
creating that hook
and second of all is it is it not going
to also of course uh impede with our uh
plans of playing f6
yeah no it's extremely committal there's
no question about that now to answer
your first question we have to
understand under what circumstances
white would be able to exploit that hook
and to me
the only thing i could possibly do is go
for example knight f1
now let's say black goes rook c8
and white would have to play the move
queen d2 otherwise the sacrifice
wouldn't make sense but
in response to green d2 black can go
either queen a5 or even knight a5
and uh the point of knight a5 is to meet
bishop takes h6 with a fork on b3 so
either queen a5 yeah or or knight a5
bishop takes h6 and now knight b3 and
black will simply not touch this bishop
instead black will go after
after the rook so i think that's the
consideration fabby had in mind but it
took him a long time i'm sure uh to
figure these things out
in any case neil's uh going queen e2
coordinating his works that way and
b5
that's another
very interesting move what happens if
white takes
i think fabi's idea is to
create b-file pressure with a move like
queen b6 followed by rugby i don't think
niels is going to take that
now i would also i mean at first sight
and it's easy to say that's sitting here
my eyes it's like
i'm worried of course a bit about
getting tunnel vision but my eyes are so
firmly
uh
on the on the king side here and i'm
just wondering what's the best way i
would love to at some point get h4 and i
would love to arrange my bishop on c2
and the queen on d3 and
and just get it right that's the best
i think that's what you got to do i
think you have to be g3 and h4 i think
that's what niels is going to do
and this position i mean you liked it uh
already last time we we checked in but
the attack seems to be uh
somewhat dangerous at least
i don't like this for fabian this is
right up nils's alley he loves these
positions which in which he has the
initiative
he has all these tactical ideas and
black's queen side play uh kind of dries
up here i'm just not seeing
uh the appeal for fabi whereas white you
know has this incredibly long term
uh kingside play yeah
for sure looking very very promising
for nils we will come back here and to
all the other games after a short break
um don't go anywhere and during the
break we'll check in with the
challengers
section with our producer big bringing
you some highlights so we'll see you
soon enjoy
[Music]
yes welcome everyone to the challengers
check in my name is walter bick i am the
esports producer for chess.com also the
producer here in vikanze so if anything
goes wrong you still know who to blame
and today the blame is going to be that
we're going to have a fantastic
miniature to look at uh each day next to
the master section we also have to
challenge your section and in the
challenger section the winner will be
playing in the master section next year
which will be 20 23 so there's a lot to
play for and we're going to have a look
at a beautiful game again from paulina
chuvalova against daniel darda we
actually viewed the game of him
yesterday he also had like a small
miniature and today
is something else let's have a quick
look
about what happened uh funny enough uh
polina played the tarash
which also happened in the magnus game
in the magnus game we had we're taking
on d4 after that with queen a4 check
first bishop d7 queen takes pawn takes
and i believe queen takes d5
but here comes the first blunder of the
game
that polina didn't follow back this game
if you see magnus taking on d4 you're
gonna do it back no she took on d5 which
is obviously uh a good theoretical move
obviously but
uh
it's just making some fun
like if i sit next to the no we're not
gonna do that we're gonna go down that
road we will go down the road of this
move bishop to g5 bishop to e6 and after
this move we're already having a nice
structure this is a glorified pawn for
now but it is looking at the queen side
and this white bishop is just staring at
the pawn
just like when i forget my first
apartment when i was 21 there was this
big tree i was so happy when they uh
took down the puppy because it was just
blocking my view just like this pawn is
blocking the view of white's bishop and
after knight e5
queen a5 check
uh that's not a check i apologize enough
to take take
we went back
c6 and after g3 now here's a very
interesting position it's actually very
fun the best move for black right now is
bishop to a3
you're like well
why is that a good move i can just
ignore it obviously you cannot take if
you take
will take on c3 with a check we're
attacking the king the rook the pawn so
you cannot play queen d2 queen d2 you
lose that rook there so we're not going
to do that
you have to play someone like knight d2
and you take him on a3
i wouldn't recommend playing king e2
either because then we'll get big queen
b2 check and then this is going to get
all nastiness you cannot castle anymore
so that's not a good move queen d2 is
the best move here you're protecting the
pawn you're protecting the air
then you go back to d6 and after let's
say
a simple bishop to g2 you play b5 and
you start barreling down this road and
as you can see you cannot play a3 if you
play a3 we have b4 and this rook is
unprotected the queen is no longer on d1
the king hasn't castled yet this rook is
unprotected so you cannot take
or we will get this rook again so that
is very interesting
why am i saying that why
can't you display bishop d6 instantly
why did he go a3 and then d6 well the
big difference after bishop g2
b5
i actually can play a3
this doesn't work anymore
for the simple reason that the queen is
no longer on d2 as in the previous one
it's still on d1 protecting the rook so
that quick bishop a3 is actually a
brilliant move very fun to look at
unfortunately in the play
bishop f5 was to move here
and a3 immediately played we do not want
the bishop on a3 or b4
and after a few moves we're going to get
through this quite fast and rapidly
we had b4
this knight can jump to f4 which is a
very strong spot and you can see all the
attention he's here on the queen side uh
well i wouldn't do this on paso i know
this chat is screaming already i know uh
i know my audience you guys are reading
ambassador that's a bad move don't do it
uh because you have to get somewhere
like rook t7 you gotta start defending
that
playbook c8 and
suddenly all the attention is on the
queen side when black actually wants to
make some push on the king side so
that's not a good move
what had happened was
uh b4
queen to c7
the rook starts lining up
this is so cool queen a4 and this is
where you think like well
could it get any worse for black we
already have a beautiful attack ongoing
uh the rooks are going to line up well
it is getting worse it's like you're
driving in a car
uh into a pool of lava and you don't
know how to get the seat belt off the
damn thing gets stuck
knight to b8 which is a huge blunder
there's just no
no way to pour it in softly um this is
just a huge blunder unfortunately 98
missing the beautiful move
knight to b5 and what happened in the
game she did play it out which is
fantastic i love to see mate on board
queen b6
queen takes a7
check
queen takes a7 and
checkmate on c7 a beautiful miniature a
beautiful smaller mate
well played
by daniel darna
very interesting opening the middle game
with the bishop a3 as well
just a beautiful game altogether and a
beautiful game to look at so this was
just before the rest day an hour after
the rest day we're on round nine now uh
only four more rounds in the master
section at the challenger section things
are heating up let me quickly take a
look at the standings
and we can still see that arjun is uh in
the lead with seven points are there
still games ongoing actually no arjun is
an absolute beast he is going really
really well he's probably going to win
this but can someone catch up we'll find
out tomorrow when we come checking again
but for now let's bring it back
to daniel nerdetsky and fiona style
anthony
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to round nine here at the
tata steel chess tournament
and dania things are starting uh to heat
up
all over the place i think we'll go back
uh to magnus is there any other game
that you you want to say something about
for now
just a couple of things uh real quickly
over on the uh top right hand side you
see duda asapanko they're following the
one of the lines we analyzed with g594
and queen e1 uh so we'll keep an eye on
that one as it unfolds and nielsen and
elias has indeed opted for uh the plan
with g3 uh followed by h4 and h5 so he's
got a great position
and uh you know concerning turn of
events here for fabiano uh we'll be
updating you on that as well but
uh the star of the show the stars of the
show carlos and mamidyarov uh have a
very interesting position let us revisit
that and see where they're at wow that
even rhymes
not
my second career as a rapper is about
start
stay tuned for some new drops
coming out soon
um
yeah so uh i was a little bit uh
disappointed well i guess both moves
rock b6 wasn't much um whereas bishop b7
would have maybe led to some
um
even sharper lines but shark deciding on
would be six and this is where we had
left enough
and now i'm now i'm zoning out and
thinking of rhymes because magnus
playing the catalan he's really battling
um
i like the there's a suggestion for your
rap name in the chat from captain wicked
little narrow
yeah i know that's i feel like narrow
lends itself that you're controlling the
center just like his men are
uh shocker activating the rook just like
you read in a book okay anyways um let's
continue to actually analyze the game
now i'm embarrassing myself
um
so
we were discussing the c4 move and
what's interesting is that magnus drove
that pawn down to e5
lil ditski is so good
[Laughter]
i mean
i think that um somebody in high school
proposed dinero because that means money
in in spanish i like d dashner that's
good that was my nickname that was my
nickname in in high school actually i
like that that's very that's very clever
that's good i like that it is it is
clever
now
i i need to understand something
which i'm i'm having a hard time
understanding which is that in this
position
okay so a takes b5 has been played
and most likely we're going to see
knight before intermezzo
get the queen away and then take on b5
but
take on b5 but when i didn't understand
initially magnus could have taken that
knight
and the point is that if you take with
the queen you lose the game uh knight g5
wins the queen it threatens checkmate
but after c takes d5 you drop a five
with a pin and
and this actually is not a blunder but a
very deep concept by chakria
what would he have done here well he
would have gone b4
and if you actually look at this
position it becomes clear that black has
fantastic compensation for the exchange
maybe not sufficient objectively
speaking but a hard position to play for
white why why do i say that well first
of all if you look at this d4 pawn
that's a very weak pawn and not only can
black attack it with the knight but
later on black can drop the queen back
to a7 and then reroute this bishop to b6
and if the d4 pawn falls well the rest
of white's position is going to collapse
along with it and then if you look at
these pawns c4 and b4 those are two very
impressive pawns uh very mobile and the
light square bishop could come out uh to
a6 potentially an x-ray the rook so a
lot of
tactical and positional potential here
and for that reason magnus deciding to
refrain
from accepting the exchange sacrifice
and he plays a takes b5 now if chakrayar
plays c takes b5 here then i think
magnus is going to go for that position
although even here fiona i'm not sure
that i'm so convinced in
in white's position i think it's kind of
a similar type of
compensation i mean
i
really i always struggle with these
positions where you give up material the
compensation i think so many of us
myself included if i saw knight takes d5
and i saw you can't uh you can't capture
with the queen because that just loses
on the spot and if you take with the
pawn i'll win the exchange i would just
go for it uh immediately but of course
he has seen this coming and surely he
must think
that
[Music]
that the compensation here is sufficient
if magnus doesn't go for it here in this
line um
if he still doesn't want to take the
exchange what are his
options well the only other thing i saw
was 94 but i i don't like this i think
black goes knight before and here black
is doing great
i mean the queen has to drop back and
then the other knight comes out and the
thing is white can make one made threat
um and black doesn't even have to go g6
and weaken his king side well i can
stick a knight on d3 and intercept the
queen and this is just really really bad
white's position collapses here
so
i don't see magnus doing anything other
than taking in in case chakra takes on
b5 i think the decision shakira i was
trying to make
is is whether or not to go for this
position
or or to play knight b4 in in this
position and this leads to
queen e4 c takes p5 and now magnus can
take this pawn with a rook
which also
i mean leads to a tremendously
tremendously complex situation but here
i think the queen
uh jumps out to g4 and i like this
actually less
than the exchange sacrifice so i'm my
vote my vote is is c takes p5
well another crucial last time we left
it off we we said it's maybe one crucial
moment already to decide between rook b6
and bishop b7
but here definitely another
critical moment and from shaq's demeanor
at the board he senses this as well
yeah he really does both players are
down to a little bit over an hour so
plenty of time remaining on the clock
and it's interesting we got a
word that they were following a game
between two very strong computers i
think up until
i want to say the tenth move
yeah but now they're definitely novel
territory it's very interesting because
magnus he said in his pre-vik interview
that he has people on his team who work
a lot more with computers than he does
but of course his main uh
second his main coach peter heine
nielsen who is also here in vikenze with
him i think he is uh very interested in
following very closely what's happening
in this world of
the engines and ai and neural networks
and you name it so i wouldn't be
surprised
if he at least was familiar with that
game and passed on that knowledge to
magnus of course
and it's the next generation of
preparation you know initially when
strong engines appeared uh one of the
first
matches that i think of where engines
played a huge role was kramnik lako
in 2004 and already in that match there
were several games that were simply
decided by
one of the two players
uh spending longer uh plugging in a
certain position to the computer
um and everybody used kind of the same
engine now uh it's unthinkable to use
the same engine you have to use
you know at the very least three
different engines
uh because they all have different
approaches to the same position and the
top guys
uh they have a dedicated person
tasked with you know plugging different
positions across
many different engines not just three i
mean there's a lot more engines out
there that people don't know about and
they're incredibly strong
it's just that you know stockfish
uh and leela have overshadowed them but
that doesn't mean they don't have their
unique perspectives on certain positions
sure danny i have a funny story i was
going for a walk with the nils on the
rest day and he was telling me a story
that earlier this year he was talking to
a colleague a former number one player
in the world who shall remain unnamed to
just last year he was still using
stockfish seven for his preparation
and niels was like what are you doing
and he said well i tried stockfish eight
and nine didn't like them and then i
gave up i'm happy with doctor seven now
we are at what stock fish
fourteen yeah fish fourteen yeah
hey was that uh jose real capoblanca by
any chance
exactly
right
so not everyone i'm willing to move with
the times but i think the players who
want to compete at the very
top these days they basically have no
choice
yeah i mean there's something to be said
for using an old-school engine although
talking about stock fishing is old
school is a little weird fritz though
yeah it's like using a hand grinder you
know to grind your coffee up
there's a certain charm to it
but it's just that when you
realize how good stockfish is
you you cannot imagine it's the same
thing with flip phones and smartphones
you know you used to text uh i used to
send long texts on flip phones you know
i did it now i tried texting on a flip
phone like a year ago and i couldn't i
couldn't type out a single word
uh so it's all about what you get used
to and you cannot revert back to the
olds
uh once you're in with the new
yeah it's uh
i think not a bad comparison at all and
also the engines it's all moving
uh
so so fast but these two guys for sure
and they are up to date i'm sure with
the latest uh latest developments
and well shakia he's still thinking
we'll come back we'll come back here um
let's go to the bird's eye view
i saw a couple of requests in the chat
to check in with vidit we haven't seen
that in a in a little while uh what else
is going on
yeah we can take a look at at vitid i
like that what jordan is doing he's got
a very nice position he's got
centralized pieces i think he's got a
for sure an advantage out of the opening
against uh daniel
uh but but we can we can have a look at
the fitted game and then and then we can
migrate on over to
um
forest game with fabby game so
uh not much has happened in the in the
uh vivid game
and the reason is that both players have
been taking oodles of time did it with
52 minutes
and he hasn't even made 10 moves yet
that is extremely concerning we can
remember that against jordan
you know of course jordan played a very
nice game but that was exacerbated by
vidit's severe time pressure now
they actually did go down the line that
we had discussed queen takes d4 and vin
deciding against
trading queens there was something about
that end game that he didn't like i
can't really blame him he went bishop d7
rehard castling there's there's no hurry
uh to recapture the spawn that pawn's
not going anywhere black is not going d5
in a position like this and that's
unthinkable
um so instead focusing on developing his
king side knight c3 and this is the
position on the board and it's an
unpleasant one for minute no question
about it why do i say that well there's
two main reasons the first is that
white's the encountered bishop is so
much better than it's counting look at
that bishop on d7 it's not a bad
defensive piece but it's incomparable to
the catalan bishop on g2 and the second
thing is
uh file control white's going to put one
rook on d1 he's going to put the other
rook on c1 and he's going to have
basically total domination in the center
fiona this is very concerning for
bennett he's gotten himself into
a super nasty position
and he he's already getting low on the
clock you know he needs something
favorable to happen here yeah he's just
gone knight c6 but
as you've just shown rapport i think
we'll just pretty quickly take uh yes on
c4 and yeah i'm very concerned uh you
mentioned the time situation he
blundered on the time pressure against a
jordan near the end and today it looks
like richard's richard reports uh
offbeat play straight from the get-go
literally on move two he played the
unusual g3 and that spot is definitely
paying off at it as it looks like fitted
maybe got slightly confused and couldn't
quite figure out which of the
transpositions
he wanted to go for and now this just
seems like a very favorable
version
no i think that's
i think you put that perfectly uh part
of the appeal of the slime forward is
exactly is precisely
yeah exactly is precisely the
number of transpositions which makes it
confusing it wasn't just confusing for
us it's just objectively very confusing
and
vivid doesn't play everything so
he has to keep in mind the fact that
it's possible to get
as they say move ordered into a line
that you don't play
so all of that mush in your head and you
know he ended up mixing up the lines and
okay he's got rook c8
i think rehard is probably going to go
rook d1 i was making these moves
beforehand
there's nothing really to fear along the
c file black is no clear
clearly dangerous discoveries
yeah no this is uh
black is not losing i mean it's not
terrible but it's it's very unpleasant
for sure so we'll come
we'll come back here but a great outcome
of the opening for widget report and
let's go to that urdan against the nil
game
yeah
um well we were checking in around this
moment where jordan positioned the
knight on c4 and the bishop on b3 the
weak light squares
uh quite concerning for black and you
know in these types of positions bishop
b6 can always be met with knight g5 so
it's not so easy to take control of the
light squares
uh duboff going rook b8
and jordan still maneuvering his knight
to d5 that's a very very nasty
very nasty knight h6
bishop c4 the bishop potentially coming
to b5
and now the move knight h2 swinging the
knight around to g4
and daniel going 97 trying everything he
can to get rid of this knight on d5 but
what jordan has done he's done just in
time because i think he can now go
knight g to e3 support the other knight
and if you have a trade well you can't
take on d5 with the knight because your
bishop gets trapped
and if you take with the bishop
well then you basically forfeit
permanently forfeit control over the
light squares i i think this is highly
unappealing as well white is better no
question about it white is better
so we've seen a couple of i mean
in that position if knight e3 happens
none of the takes and none of the
captures on d4 look appealing
um
can black ignore
that knight on d5 for now does white
have threats
well i was thinking about this move
knight b6 but something fascinating
happens if black does this white
transforms the advantage
white actually trades on b6 looks
positionally bad you know why would you
and now you've given up control over the
d5 square
right
but this is one of the most important
things to be able to do is to say okay i
had one type of advantage but now i'm
going to realize that
my opponent is not prepared to meet
uh the opening up of the position so you
get this knight to c4
and then after rook c6 all of a sudden
the queen comes out to g4 boom
and then you're attacking e6 and h6 and
black can't defend both at the same time
i mean black can play king f7 but then
in comes the rook
and this is already basically losing so
man oh man this is if if you aren't
plays knight g3
i think he's going to be in phenomenal
shape here
very nice uh position uh
for jordan who's handed the position
great you had highlighted earlier
another tempting plan to go for d4
he's found another plan which also seems
to have given him uh a position with a
slight edge so uh good on jordan and
let's go back to the bird's eye view
while he ponders his next
move and what do we have in nils
grandelius against fabiano fabiano has
just come
queen b6 maybe we can
jump there for a second
absolutely let's take a look at
fabiano's attempts to orchestrate
and we came just in time because the
second our camera zoomed in on this and
niels went h4
all right well we pointed that plane out
this that is what one could say the sort
of absolutely classic canonical way of
dealing with that knight on g6
and what i think fabi is going to do in
fact i can bet a a silver dollar is
going to do this he's probably going to
move the rook on f8 the reason why is if
you play b4
guess where your knight is gonna have to
go
i don't know about this square fiona i
don't know if fabi is entirely on board
with that so he might take this
opportunity to go either rook b8 sorry
that was a mouse slip but rugby 8 is
also a candidate move uh or rook c8
and
meet h5 with knight f8 and he has
he's gone
rook c8
rook c8 but what if niels just goes g4
what if he says i'm gonna checkmate you
i'm gonna go g5 this queen is gonna go
around to g2
and
black's king
is not entirely unsafe i mean it's
surrounded by pieces but in the long run
if black doesn't create something on the
queen side really in the next three four
moves uh this could end up being
just a checkmate
i mean i completely understand why you
would move the rook to free up that f8
square but somehow the last couple of
move queen b6 rook c8 all those pieces
are going to to the queen side i'm a
little bit concerned for black uh
there's not so many pieces left
defending the king and i love your idea
to just just go for the throat
the engine suggests a another move which
is king h1 also very powerful and the
point is very clear
you want to play h5 g4 and then you want
to be able to go rook g1
and blast through with g5 and it's
giving a very clear advantage to white
and if anything the engine often
underestimates these positions because
it's myopic in the sense that it doesn't
always see
uh how the attack is going to unfold and
how strong the attack is going to be so
i am very concerned for fabi and i feel
like niels is so confident in these
types of positions and as you said he's
really got nothing to lose uh he's
playing to win
and
unless we see a big turn around here i
feel like niels has great chances to win
this game yeah nils he is still looking
for his first win in the tournament and
what a boost that could give him with
four rounds still to come to to take out
fabiano carana let's see does he go king
h1
does he go h5 will keep an eye on it um
and let's bring up let's go back again i
think to the bird's eye
view
my eye is drawn a little bit to do dicey
panko where same
something is happening maybe we just go
there and i look
sorry just before we go that look at the
second well the middle board on the
bottom row pragnanda against karjakin
that exchange is gone and we're in for a
treat there as well i think
we absolutely are that's actually what i
was going to point out and carl another
exchange sacrifice in carlson mamiyarov
we have indeed mamidar has indeed gone
down that path so two separate exchange
sacrifices what around already unfolding
but yes let's have a look at
deuterosepenko
in the meantime
uh because they've gone down a pretty
interesting path
okay so what's happened here uh sepenko
has decided not to go 94 he went g5
94 and indeed queen e1
and now we've had a trade on d4 this is
the position on the board fiona a lot of
tension in the center
a lot of tension in the center uh as
black how do you resolve it
let's first my first question is going
to be what if black captures the bishop
on g3 is that something you want to do
or not
yeah it's a it's a viable move but i
think there's no hurry so black should
probably wait until
white plays the move f3
and the reason is that white now has the
f3 square potentially for his knight now
if you go straight into the end game
after king f8 yeah i think the presence
of knight f3
uh
gives white a pretty stable advantage
and the point is that g4 which looks
like it wins upon can be met with the
intermittent not really an intermediate
but the counter blow d5
and if you calculate this out why
doesn't lose a pawn here because fg
bishop g2 defends e6 after bcgf white is
definitely better i mean black has the
worst pawn structure on the king side
uh and this is just not the kind of
position essepenko would want to have if
he wanted an end game he would have
played knight e4
uh for that reason i think
black is best advised to play a move
like bishop f5 just developed
uh his last remaining minor
duda might push the pawn to d5
and this is a very hard position to
evaluate knight e5
i really don't know what's going on here
it's it's very unclear
very messy one question the black king i
guess will
go queenside in this
and in this line at least
it's hard to say
it's hard to say
maybe it will even stand maybe it'll
even go to f8 and
sometimes you want to go to fa because
you want to make sure the queen on e7
has a defender otherwise
bad stuff might happen down the e-file
so
a lot of intuitive decisions have to be
made by both players particularly andre
who's down to 46 minutes
um
that's not a lot of time to have after
13 moves
now we'll see uh what he come he's
looking quite tired today we just saw
him yawning there leaning back now
staring us down again let's move on here
i am intimidated i think we should check
in with the two games where we have
exchange sacrifices on the board
for sure let's start with our world
champion and as i flip to that game i
would just add that sometimes during the
rest day what can happen is you you're
so pumped that it's a rest day and you
can finally sleep in
that you stay up until you know 4am
watching
uh the news the new season of ozark and
or watching whatever football match i
guess in esopenko's case and before you
know it you wake up and it turns out you
haven't gotten great sleep because you
don't really want to wake up past 11 a.m
uh you want to make the hotel breakfast
uh so that that's often happened to me
where i'm actually in a weird way less
rested
after the rest day than after a normal
day because then you're kind of
disciplined because you have to be also
let's not forget it might have been we
don't know how andrei dealt with the the
loss against aneesh but of course
that will have occupied at least some of
his thoughts uh on thursday
for sure especially the
the fact that he had a a four straw
i'm sure that was something that ate
away at him throughout the day now
the the exchange sacrifice by shakur
mamidar this is a slightly different
version of the sacrifice than we
originally discussed but i think it's
still quite effective for black what
does black's compensation actually
consist of here well there is two main
things the first is that the pawn on d4
is a very serious weakness it's
currently being attacked
and if it's defended
in the wrong way then black can pile on
the pressure with bishop g4
threatening to take the knight and then
take the pawn and white has to
uh delegate some of his heavy pieces in
particular the queen
uh to to defending the pawn on d4 that
brings me to the second factor which is
the fact that black has a pawn majority
on the queen side which she can use
uh playing b4 or maybe rook c8 and later
on
in the near future
creating a pass pawn with c3 so
you know the engine does give a small
advantage to white i wouldn't put much
stock in that i think chakra has played
in a very practical manner but carlson
he goes rook a8 and he says i don't care
about the d4 pawn i care more about not
letting you develop your bishop i guess
if knight takes d4
magnus's point is that he's going to
take and then he's going to swing the
rook to d1 and win the d5 pawn i don't
like this option for black at all i
think chakriar should still move the
bishop out of c8 even if that means
allowing a trade of rooks it's just
played a quiet move h6
for bearing bishop e6 but he's allowed a
really interesting option which really
reminds me of carlson's game against
geary in the second round fiona
guess what magnus can sack the exchange
back with
c8
and i think this option has been missed
by chakriar rook takes c8
and um
the point now is
queen f5 the queen jumps out z5 why is
this good the reason this is good is
that e6 is coming on the next move
and black's position starts to crumble
just a little bit for example rook d8
e6
and
black's king is in trouble just like
gary's
king in in that second game if people
remember that if i go to to f8 instead
of d8
does that help my cause at all
um let's see so you mean
yeah i was thinking about the king after
i take c6
okay so
instead of rook d8 you're proposing rook
f8 yeah maybe that's better and then
after e6 the thing is that this pawn on
f7 is now defended
so you're able to go knight b4
but
let's say i just take on f7 and after
queen g4 the engine still gives a big
advantage to white because if you look
at these light squares as well as the e5
square as well as the e file
black's king is just going to end up in
a long term
you know having long-term problems
what an exciting moment here
we'll see if magnus goes for the counter
exchange sacrifice we'll find out after
a short break all the games really
coming to life here you don't want to
miss it
yeah very exciting we'll see in a few
minutes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the chess.com rapid chess championship
is a brand new world-class online rapid
event series for the top 100 players top
10 women and top 10 juniors in the world
watch as the very best compete for their
share of twenty thousand each week
culminating with a one hundred and fifty
thousand dollar prize final it all
starts at 9 00 a.m pacific noon eastern
on saturday february 12th right here on
chess.com for more information head on
over to
rapid chess go.chess.com very exciting
new venture you will not want to miss it
and your weekends will never be boring
again fiona we hope that your week is
not boring and how can it be boring with
a round as exciting as this you're
watching tata steel round nine and
things are heating up
indeed the players are certainly trying
their best here
we saw during the break the camera was
on it magnus not going for the counter
exchange sacrifice on c8 but after rk1
which she has played the position still
looks like uh it is a little bit better
for him i suggest we go there but go
back there a little bit later for now
where would you like to start
all right well having a look at our
bird's eye view here
um definitely the prague game would be
something
uh to look at we have van forest
continuing uh to to nurse that advantage
we have anish and sam still in that kind
of insipid end game so we could save
that one for later uh neil's still
contemplating his move after rook fc8
let's go to the um
let's go to the prague game let's go to
the prague game and see
delve a little bit deeper into that
position let's do it so we left it off
here i think after
h5
yep so sergey did go for a5 which we
mentioned
prague
uh heading over to d4 and they kind of
transposed into
this exchange stack
frog going queen e3 now that move
is a little bit strange to me i guess
he's trying to
meet
or prevent discourage e5
i mean that must be the idea do you
think there was something more concrete
like
fascinating king queenside and bringing
the rook
yeah i i thought castling was was the
most natural i mean was and i didn't
think e5 has anything to worry about i
mean f takes e5
and if bishop takes c5 and white white
just has queen g5 and then
knight f5 and uh
this is
i mean this just looks completely
winning so it's not amazing
yet
actually just how do we after f6
yeah just queen takes h5 i think in rook
h1
that looks convincing
so not sure what exactly he was worried
about but in any case he went 23
and sergey sergey
and continuing to expand on the queen's
side with a a4 lone pine
uh gaelic style or a4 and after what is
the idea of a4 well he's clamping down
on the b2 pawn so after prague castles
first of all he he does have the option
of going a3 and trying to induce uh
further further weaknesses or he can put
a rook on b8 and make it harder for
prague
to to defend the b2 pawn in the long run
of course after rook h1 i still feel
like white's attack
has to be a lot stronger than black so i
i don't think sergey is out of the woods
but we saw
that
it's not maybe completely reminiscent of
prague's game against magnus but there
as well like he had this shot with uh
knight g5 which we talked about plenty a
chance he didn't take so um
maybe i mean his position probably is
still good but do you think sometimes
there's just this um
i don't even know what word i should use
but
this undecides in to like this failure
to take immediate action shall we say oh
yeah for sure and i think prague you
know this tournament he has had you know
his share of very promising positions
most notably against magnus i mean
uh not to keep reminding everyone of
that but you know that moment when he
could have played knight g5
that was a very serious chance to put
the world champion under
you know under under big big fire
and you know in this game it's going to
be very important for him to act
decisively and i think to keep a good
amount of time on his clock for
uh the moment when the game heats up and
that's exactly what he's doing as he
castles long i like the speed with when
she played that movie didn't overthink
it
and and you know white has to go down
this path of castling going work h1 and
attacking down the h file sergey now
with 34 minutes will the minister of
defense step it up and one way that
black can try to do that is go queen b7
and and pile up the pressure on that b2
pawn and try to force white uh to deal
with it uh and thereby stopping you know
any immediate
attack so something like this would
force the queen to drop back and defend
the pawn not sure if that's the best of
black can do but sergey will have to act
decisively and quickly
yeah having said uh what i said about
pregnant i like you i still like his
position i think that karjakin is
already under quite a lot of pressure on
the clock here let's remind everyone
it's only move 18 karakan still has 23
moves to make uh before he gets an extra
50 minutes there you see the time
control the longest i think on the tour
so on move 40 the players get an extra
50 minutes then on move 60 an extra 15
minutes and they also get their 30
second
increment from move one
and uh well we'll leave sergey to it for
now but uh
prague definitely putting the squeeze on
here today
absolutely he's played
very well great preparation and uh if he
can win this game that'll really erase
all of the regrets that i'm sure
he must be feeling about
about his previous games
and let's go back once again to the the
bird's eye view because today it feels
like you never know where the next
strike is going to happen yeah
i see on the top left corner shakir has
now made the move we talked about
earlier bishop e6 we see that the bar is
creeping up and up really liking
magnus's position do you want to quickly
update that
yeah i i think we should talk about why
that is because at least visually it
looks like black's position is pretty
watertight
and and i do think that in this case the
bar might be
slightly over valuing white's advantage
now there's no question that white is
better
probably even much better but you know
parroting the computer eval here doesn't
tell the full story of the position it
really doesn't because the d4 pawn is
still a weakness
and black black's position at least
visually remains very very solid so if
you put yourself in magnus's shoes here
i'm sure he's not thinking
that oh i'm totally winning in this
position and anything wins
probably
he has to drop the queen back here and
defend the pawn on d4 i just don't see
an alternative i mean at first i was
tempted by the move rook a6
but that doesn't actually stop knight
takes d4 because that hits the queen
uh so
probably he should go queen d1 i mean at
least that's the
the engine recommendation here
and then chakra could keep the tension
and and play a move like before
uh just expanding on on the queen side
and i'm really not
convinced that white is that white is
totally winning here or anything like
that and then from here on out if you're
black
once again i'm curious to hear your
thoughts what what's the plan do you
just sit tight and wait for white to
make a move or do you have a follow-up
in mind about maybe pushing one of these
queen side pawns even further
yeah i mean i think both can be true at
the same time it really depends on what
white does black has this idea of going
b3
and then c3 trying to break through like
that
or going c3 immediately so if we make a
random move
uh in fact i think b3 is the better
option it's more flexible
because it opens up a pathway for for
the knight to drop to this outpost on d3
um so i think that's the likeliest
follow-up and that is why
uh the engine was recommending starting
with rook a6 and chasing the queen away
and then when the queen moves back you
play b3
freezing black spawns and you do allow
c3 but now the knight can drop back to
e1 and blockade the pawn
from c2 so if white can
fully deal with black's pawn majority
yeah then the compensation is going to
start
fizzling out but
you know we're still a long way away
from that
for sure um
well this one
very very interesting struggle here
between the world champion and uh
i think magnus he understands these
positions so well but he is also happy
to have the the active uh position here
i think he will not be as uncomfortable
as the bar seems to indicate i think a
lot of people i will get excited by
seeing this plus 1.8 it says which is a
huge advantage but yeah very doubtful
shock feels anywhere near
as bad we will come back to this one
um
what is going on niels is still thinking
long think after rook c8 at the bottom
right corner
um anushkiri against sam shankland maybe
we can
quickly update uh that end game
let's have a look at that end game and
see who has benefited from
all of these transformations now we last
checked the position around this moment
sam
uh maneuvering his knight to d6 which
makes a lot of sense and i was a little
bit surprised
that anish did not go with his initial
idea of 93 followed by knight d5 i'm
actually very surprised he decided to
well he gave a check and then he traded
on d6
and i guess his point is that the pawn
on d6 yeah it's a backward one it's one
could say a weakness but it can be
easily defended by the king from c7
anish following up with a nice move rook
e3
getting the stroke active and then
moving it to f3 forcing the knight back
to d8
and expanding now on the king side with
h4 i still think that white's position
is very very pleasant
uh make no mistake and in fact the
longer i look at it the more i realize
something which is that black's king
would love to be on e7 if it could get
to e7 it would take the burden off of
the knight
guess what i keep trying to play king
decent it won't let me is that i
probably need to refresh oh wait a
second that's illegal and not only is it
illegal but the bishop isn't going
anywhere it's just gonna stick on this
stick to this diagonal and white could
follow up by going to rook f6 tightening
the screws even further so i was
dismissive initially but the more i look
at it the more i i begin to appreciate
uh how gary has handled this this is
quite unpleasant for sam
yeah all this time you were talking i
was trying to figure out how can i
untangle like can i
somehow defend the f7 pawn with the rook
then move the knight then bring the king
via d837
but it all
doesn't look so so easy to actually
achieve in practice
yeah i mean that's a
nice concept and you could go rookie a
rookie seven
but you're right i mean white's gonna
stick the rook on f6
okay black
can throw in h5 at some point but let's
say black goes rookie seven now a niche
probably will play h5
and even though you've succeeded in
moving your knight out of the way i mean
96 doesn't work because after hgh bishop
e6 black loses one of the pawns but sam
has made a move
he has made a move and that move is d5
so he's actually
he he senses the trouble five
and he breaks through
that's a d5 yeah my first question is
what happens if i if i just take that
initial take this will happen and sam
wants to play f5 that's his idea he
wants to play f5 and guess what he's not
recovering the pawn
this is a genuine sacrifice and after
king d6
c4 black is down a pawn but at least
black gets very very active and now sam
can go e4
and this knight can come to e5 via f7 so
a very interesting practical decision by
shanklin i really like that decision i
think he senses the danger and this is
not a desperation move this is a very
well calculated well thought out
sacrifice
uh that is made for peace activity
and anish he is thinking
he i think we both agree we'll take the
pawn on d5 but he's already going to be
thinking then after that how do i meet i
think even before he takes he wants to
be sure that there is no he can't get
into trouble after f5 and the knight
jumping out
uh yeah i'm very curious how this pawn
sacrifice is gonna work out i would
always be terrified to make a move like
this as black and a loud white uh a past
pawn
an extra pawn as well
um but yeah the alternatives didn't seem
too tempting to just sit and defend
passively so good on sam will come back
and see how this works out uh for him
yeah with the rook landing on f6 as
you're just pointing out
sorry go ahead i was just going to say
very very quickly that the reason he had
to play this now is if the rook had
landed on f6 then d5 would be
meaningless because black wouldn't be
able to go f5 so sam
seizing the opportunity while he still
has it uh good on him
sorry about that now we can go back no
indeed yeah let's go back to to the
bird's eye view again maybe this time we
can take
a little longer maybe danny i know we're
not before a break but i'll just ask you
anyway i'll uh to give us maybe a very
quick tour of what's going on in every
in every game
absolutely let's start up on the top
left with the world champion who is who
has just played the move queen d1 shakur
has sacrificed an exchange
uh he's got
definite compensation but according to
the engine it's not nearly enough
compensation i think the evaluation
whether it's plus two or plus three
according to the higher depth computer
uh i think that's an overestimation the
game is not over and uh magnus is still
gonna have to prove
uh that he can contain black's queenside
initiative but there's anybody equipped
to do that it's the world champion
uh over on uh second from the last we
have report against vidit a unfortunate
opening for vinid who has dug himself
into a bit of a hole here both on the
clock and on the position he's just very
passive rehard has the kind of classic
catalan advantage shares he's probably
going to put a rook on d1
we just saw sam shanklin sacrificing a
pawn in the end game to avoid getting
into a passive and unpleasant position
love that decision um i think that move
is going to serve him well
in duna estepenko we have a potential
queen trade on the cards as both sides
jockey uh to prepare themselves for what
seems to be an inevitable end game we
can see that queen 91 agree on e7 uh the
end game is probably going to be quite
balanced uh over on the bottom left we
have bonforest against duba a game that
really
uh was in jordan's favor from the get-go
currently he's got the two bishops he's
got that big hole on d5 and his bishop
on c6 is doing yeoman's work he can
always drop back to b5 he's better but
daniel
uh of course very resilient he's going
to try to contain white's advantage
prague against karjakin moving to the
right
uh prague has sacrificed the exchange
fascinating plane he's got big big
compensation for it sergey low on time
he's in trouble but the minister of
defense is known to step up in these
kinds of situations and finally uh
bottom right corner we have niels
gundelius against fabi uh fabi playing
the french clearly going for the win uh
and taking a serious risk that risk
right now fiona doesn't seem to be
paying off neil's building up
massive kingside pressure and right now
he's been taking probably over almost 30
minutes at this point trying to figure
out what the most effective and
efficient way of kicking off the king
side attack is whether it's h5 or
whether it's a preliminary king h1 or
king h2 to vacate the g1 square for the
rook in either case very dangerous
situation for mr caruana yeah i think
for nils it's a case of him having a
couple of tempting options here of
course he needs to be careful that the
time doesn't drop too low sometimes you
can get there just lost in all these
calculations and considerations
and i think we're not going to go back
there until he's made a move where would
you like to to take a closer dive
well i'll just point out we don't have
to go there uh that shakur has indeed
gone pawn b4 which was understandable
it's really the only way to follow up
and magnus we see over on the bottom
left deep in thought so we'll keep a
very close eye on that game
um
we can go to the
i mean i wish i think niels is gonna
play is gonna make a move very soon so
let's go to the niels move after he
makes a decision for now let's go to the
event forest dubov game because we've
had a transformation in that game uh the
last time we looked white still had a
knight
let's go there so um we saw this mass
trade trade on d5 happen let's go back
to to where we left it off
uh jordan did indeed play knight g3 as
we expected
yet daniel taking on d5 with the bishop
so he accepts the long-term weakness of
the light squares but at least he
eliminates that incredibly pesky knight
and then he he chases the bishop with
knight b6
bishop c6 rookie six this is the
position on the board and jordan going
rook b b1
adding pressure down the b file and the
point is that if black attacks the
bishop with queen c7 he does have this
outpost on b5
uh for the bishop and again it's very
clear that white is better
is white much better or just
clearly better it's hard to say and
daniel could consider changing the
structure by playing the move d5 that's
very risky to do that because you're
potentially walking into bishop c4 ideas
this is very unpleasant for black but
you know again i guess the next few
moves will determine to what extent you
know how big white's advantage actually
is
and also i think once again if we look
at the camera of duboff
uh he's the player i feel that you can
kind of tell when he's and not too happy
just doesn't have that that same zest it
feels
yeah that's a good word and you remember
when he was beating magnus in those
online tournaments i mean he was pumped
uh and here he just seems
kind of nonplussed as he twirls that
pawn around i think that's a pun
yeah
i was funny enough my eye went there as
well it's quite impressive twirling uh
technique
yeah it really is i mean i never really
mastered it i know gelfon does the thing
where he just like throws a piece up in
the air as i'm doing right now
and then catches it but the thing is i'm
focusing all my attention on it he
literally does that as he's thinking
about a move and he even just does that
in blitz which is crazy
that is crazy indeed but he had
daniel here
considering his options and then none of
the moves we've seen so far looked
particularly
tempting
look at that camera work
elaborate gyrations and acrobatics being
performed with that pawn there
but uh yeah no i i'm it's uh maybe it's
trying to hypnotize hypnotize jordan
or impress him
this is something if this had happened
in in the karpov courtship match from
the 70s there would be accusations of
hypnosis maybe jordan will soon get out
his sunglasses
oh yeah bring it all bring it all out
michael it's all style
okay well we'll come back here but
jordan looks like he is in a great shape
so far
and i think we'll just go once again to
uh to the bird's eye view
my eye keeps going to nils gondalius but
he's yet to make a move
um
yeah he's gotta be careful actually
because
we don't have to go there i'm just going
to update
people on how much time he has left he
has
37 minutes left on his clock fiona he
has been thinking for half an hour or
more even
over 35 minutes already
wow that is
that might backfire because let's say he
takes another 15 minutes all of a sudden
you've got 20 minutes for 24 moves
what meals is what niels is essentially
thinking i think is okay if i find the
correct move here
this basically might be checkmate so
he's investing this time in the hopes
that he's going to be able to play fast
and he's going to be able to carve out
uh the proper strategy for the next
couple of moves that's a very risky uh
approach to take against someone like
fabi who knows how to complicate things
at a moment's notice
yeah and it doesn't even look like we've
gone there with the camera now it
doesn't look like he's
ready to see it of course a move could
come at any moment but we don't oh
well
way to prove me wrong
yep there it is just
i mean they wait for us to say it i
swear
f1
okay the engine did not like that move
at all but as i said i wouldn't trust
the engine in these closed positions
uh because
again the engine is short-sighted
uh in terms of evaluating the the attack
properly now what is the idea of knight
f1 the idea is to swing this knight
around
through h2 to g4
and you called the fiona a long time ago
when fabi played h6 that opened up
the long-term possibility of a sacrifice
on h6 and i think that is what niels
is orienting himself toward but let me
be honest i'm very surprised he didn't
go king h1 i felt
that this idea is so appealing h5 g4 and
then get this
and when you get a rook did you want to
the g-file open them
juicy
yeah i'd be curious to know how much
nielsen's decision is affected by his
result entertainment i think in general
uh niels is someone who copes quite well
uh with setbacks like these and he
doesn't let uh let it get him down too
much but i think it's difficult for uh
for such a result not to not to let it
affect your your confidence
at all and um
yeah i don't know if knight f1 if
indifferent if it was round one would he
have played king h1 how much does the
tournament situation have to do with it
but yeah the position
still all to play for the attack is
still there but i also liked
your suggestion of going for it straight
away
in the most direct fashion it it remains
to be seen
uh whether knight f1 pays i mean for
fabby knight a5 is probably the most
obvious move along with b4 and then
trying to get this knight to c4 i'll
make no mistake i would still prefer to
be white and and the game could still
still end in checkmate uh so the other
the other move here is b4 this is what
fabi has to decide which of these
uh moves
offers more
promise on the queen side uh so it's
possible that fabi will take a pretty
long think in return he doesn't have
that much time
either but i can confirm from first-hand
experience
you know the moment that
you begin to think you know i'm actually
pretty darn close to getting a winning
position against
fabi or mamadiarov or one of these guys
you feel such a level of anxiety you
feel that the butterflies in your
stomach
and sometimes it takes a couple of
minutes just to calm yourself down and
just say okay i gotta stay objective
and because you know that if you make a
single inaccuracy you know this golden
opportunity to score the win of a
lifetime could be taken away from you
yeah for sure and well we'll come back
uh to this game i think let's go to the
bird's eye view and maybe pick
one last game and after that um we'll go
on a short break
absolutely that sounds good
um you see magnus still thinking after
b4
we have sergey bringing the rook to b8
as we had expected let's take a look at
the duda as a banker game because
you know that still has not reached an
end game and yes panko does have the
possibility now of declining the end
game altogether
let's go there let's
let's let's have a brief look at what's
happening here in fact i think it's
quite likely that andre at this point
will refrain from trading queens at all
he has gone so there was a tr huh yeah
he's sorry he did just play knight e5 so
indeed the queens are going to stay on
the board but let's catch up
yeah the queens are going to stay on the
board that's uh
quite quite surprising uh knight f3
yeah and i mean he didn't want to take
on e1 and allow
allow the rook to recapture with check
so he ends up castling long
yawn going d5 and now again trading
queens would give white full control
over the e file not desirable
and so he goes 95
will
duda take that knight i i don't think so
and there's a very interesting idea c5
undermining the knight on e5
and white actually threatens to
push the spawn
all the way down to to c6
and tear
tear apart the king position so
yeah i really don't like this for andre
and look at that bishop on f1 it is yet
to make a move in this game but if c6
lands on the board that bishop is ready
to to join the game with some
potentially decisive
action via ie6
absolutely and and the engine is
suggesting this idea g4
um
knight takes knight and now the inter
mezzo queen g5 check
and
white can cover with the rook white can
also cover with the queen after d takes
e5 we have another potential queen
traitor another standoff but if you look
at white's pawn structure that is that
is a very very nice
uh pawn center the white has going
definitely
a positive turn of developments for duda
and coupled with that the fact that
andre again is down below 30
minutes will he lose the second game in
a row he's definitely in quite a bit of
danger here especially if eon follows up
with c5
indeed i think a lot of players today
putting on the squeeze from the from the
white side so we'll come back to this
game and all the others everything is
still going on we're two and a half
hours into the game almost
so you don't want to miss it don't go
anywhere we'll be back in a few
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome again in vikings a shrek stands
for forbidding for bending here in the
door in vaikanshay my oakland fans
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to round nine here at the
tata steel chess tournament and uh well
this time without going to the words of
you dania we've just dived into
the richard report game against fitted
gujarati because things are heating up
there
they definitely are and you can see that
the time situation has essentially
flipped which is quite shocking now
it all started in in the position after
rook c8 queen f4 and h6
to be honest i was expecting rich
richard to quickly go rook d1
uh but maybe he didn't feel that this
gives him enough of an advantage and
after something like bishop c5 black is
very much in the game
but after a very long think richard has
gone knight b5 and i simply think that
he missed
uh vidit's response which came very
quickly and it's incredibly strong and
that's the move night before
well that opens up an attack on the
night
and originally i'm pretty confident that
richard was relying on 96 check right
but what actually happens here black
takes on d6
gets this knight to c2
and then if you look at the standoff
between the queens black can use that to
play bishop b5 creating an attack
against the e2 pawn and if black
captures that pawn he also traps the
rook on f1 so
white has to drop the queen back to e5
that looks pretty strong it defends the
pawn and attacks the bishop but in comes
black's queen to d5 and this is a very
awkward situation for white because if
you trade the queens you're gonna have a
hard time defending e2 if you look at
how active black is that bishop the
light skirt bishop which was so passive
is now the strongest piece on the board
and i think richard is calculating that
and it might be the case that the best
option for white is just to bring the
knight back to c3 it's not ideal it's
not what he wants to do i'm sure
but i think knight c3 does preserve
a pleasant position for white but he's
down to 27 minutes after 11 moves i was
gonna say i mean it's absolutely insane
that we're only we're two and a half
hours into the game only 11 moves have
been made i think knight c3 is a move
that's so difficult to make from a
psychological point of view because
you've literally just gone
2b5
and
i think it is a good skill to have
to just make a retreating move and admit
that maybe your move wasn't the best but
it's not not an easy thing to do
yeah my my old coach gregory kaidano if
you called that saying sorry you know
knight c3 i'm sorry and saying sorry at
the chess board it's embarrassing and
you gotta swallow you really have to
swallow your pride now not none of these
players have a problem with that so it's
less that he's thinking oh knight c3 is
going to make me look a certain way and
more than he's just reticent to lose
lose a bunch of tempe the funny and what
i think he's reluctant to allow
is
uh vitis knight from swinging to d5
because this is pretty serious progress
for black now you have a nice knight on
on d5 but i don't think that it's a
problem white goes queenie fine that's a
nasty move uh because it stops the
bishop from coming out
and white is definitely still not
risking here and is still for choice
yeah i actually can we put that position
on the board one more time there that we
just so after knight d5
i have been inspired here dania by
by people giving up material everywhere
so after the capture in queen e5
i was wondering can i give up upon here
is black sorry after queen e5 can i go
something like bishop e7 or is that just
silly will you just take that poem and
say thank you very much
i i will uh but it's it's definitely not
silly it has to be considered and the
line goes bishop f6 fortunately for
white the queen still has a square on g4
and now black could continue tossing the
queen around
uh with the move h5 but my guess is that
after queen e4 there isn't objectively
enough compensation and the king is
maybe just a little
too unsafe yeah and the knight is coming
to e5 now a move has been made and it's
actually not not knight c3 not knight d6
it's rook d1
which was on my radar it pins the bishop
but i was concerned about queen b6 in
this position i think this is what
bitted is going to do
queen b6 unpinning and hitting the
knight on b5
and now again there's a choice between
playing knight d6 check
and then going back to c3 in this
position which
um has the appeal of preparing 95 but
still blocking go knight
bd5 and you get kind of a similar type
of
type of line knight takes d5 and queen
e5 is still very possible here
so
it's it's hard to make heads or tails of
this position it's very common yeah i
mean it's it's such a messy position and
i
if i had to predict something here i
wouldn't predict a result per se but i
would predict that this is going to be
the size that very likely by some
mistake as time takes down
because these players right
sorry michael go ahead
no i was just in that's a good that's a
good prediction
it's just incredible like 28 moves
report has to make video 29
and
they already
report down to 25 minutes with it to 36
just incredible as so there will be some
big big time trouble looming here but
now let's bring back the bird's eye view
i was thinking actually during the break
in every single game unless things have
changed white is pressing in every
single one of them
absolutely i mean
and by the way we see that uh duda has
gone c5 so white's pressing there van
forest is better you're right there
pragnanda has been pressing the whole
game as well and of course niels
uh with an incredibly promising position
as he has gotten his knight to g4
completing the maneuver that he started
with the move
knight f1
now wait a second fiona i'm looking at
the shanklin game
and i'm not understanding what's
happening can we go there
yeah let's have a look because
something terrible just happened
shankland made a huge blunder
sam made a huge mistake now remember
this position
he had to go e4 you have to go e4
immediately and here's the point
if white brings the rook up to f4
now you can go knight f7 as shanklin did
a little bit later and the point is that
if white tries to play g4
and g4 is a very nasty move because it
breaks through the pawn chain if white
can get rid of the pawn chain black's
not going to have anything to show from
pawn but here there's the move king e5
and the rook is trapped and white can
resign
uh for that reason it was very important
to go e4 but sam didn't sense the moment
and he played b6 thinking uh that he's
gonna
you know prevent all sorts of c5 ideas i
think he completely forgot about g4
that's a devastating positional move
it might not look that bad now if you
play e4 in this position then white has
to move rook a3 the pawn on a7 is
hanging and black cannot defend both f5
and a seven at the same time and
obviously this is a tremendous
concession because now black is left
with a very weak pawn on e4 and there's
just no compensation for the pawn
uh
if black goes f4 here
then in similar vein white can go rook
a3
and then drop the bishop back to g2 and
this is a very undesirable pawn
structure for black black is never going
to be able to go e4 as long as the
bishop controls that square
sam
deciding on knight f7 which i don't
understand at all
simply giving up another pawn
and he follows up with g5 that was his
idea
but what if anish just goes rook a3 and
gets the rook away from the knights line
of fire
i think black is just losing i think sam
has completely lost it here
i mean this has happened so fast
and it shows you once again
how quickly you can lose the threat of
the position we were actually praising
sam's decision to give up a pawn to get
active uh play and then just one moment
you play b6 you think okay
i can always play e4 and bring the
knight to e5 later and then g4
and suddenly you realize
you're in huge trouble if not uh just
lost and then very often i think those
uh mistakes they just come as a
as a chain um once
yeah
sorry i feel like i keep it nothing no
no no not at all
i was just gonna say i saw in the chat
people taking issue with me calling this
a blunder i i stick by what it is a
blender all right and and what's
important to understand is that not all
blunders involve you know leaving a
piece hanging
at this level
allowing something like g4 which takes
the position from perhaps slightly
better to completely winning or not
completely winning but just winning
uh that that still is a blunder and sam
would be the first to admit that you
know and labels don't matter you can
call it a huge mistake but i think
blunder really
signals the fact that it completely
changes the tenor of the position it
totally changes the evaluation
yeah i mean i would say that uh
in general uh especially you have so
much experience as a commentator as a
streamer i don't think you use the term
blunder lightly and
i guess that in general
most of the times you have a a better
understanding of what is a blunder than
chat so
um
i'll have no
no choice but to decide
uh with
you here bigfoot i was gonna say you
have so much experience in blundering no
not at all
yeah in fact
i'm generally very conservative about
calling stuff a blunder because i'm
sympathetic to to the players and you
know i don't like just looking at the
engine evil and really if this isn't
about the engine evil it's just clear to
the naked eye that black the wheels have
completely come off as
sanklin has now done two pawns
he has some chances because he still has
control over the
you know the c5 and the d6 squares but
uh anisha has plenty of time here and
and he's going to use it wisely uh the
next couple of moves are pretty
important and maybe now is a good moment
to bring up the standings very briefly
once again because most people know that
we have two players in the joint lead
and we'll go back there in a second
because they are playing each other
that's magnus carlsen and shahid mahmoud
but if that game were to end in a draw
who is looming there lurking in third
place well it is anish giri and vidit
gujarati
and both of them today anish already has
a
probably technically winning position
vidit has great chances
as black in a position where anything
can happen which is surely what he would
want um so we could see a shake up there
at the top of the standings today
we absolutely could and
uh speaking of a shake i mean for magnus
that makes it even more important
uh to try to win this game and and
extend his lead uh just because these
you know hungry third and fourth place
people are trying to win their games how
dare they
i mean anisha so let's let's remind
everyone anish has won three games in a
row of course one of them was against
lubov which wasn't played but still
even two games one on the board and
potentially
well looking very much like he will make
it a third today that's hugely
impressive of course
absolutely and let's return to the
magnus game because um i was looking at
this more deeply during the break and i
have concluded they actually went down
the line we were discussing earlier
and i've concluded that muhammad yarb is
in fact in very serious trouble
because his worst nightmare has come
true white has completely frozen
uh the queenside pawn so what happened
chakrayar did indeed go before
and magnus went b3 that is the crucial
move not allowing black to shove this
pawn down to b3 and create the potential
of uh putting a knight on d3 chakriar
has no choice but to play c3
uh and magnus dropping the rook back to
a6 and i can
i can bet that once the queen moves back
he's going to follow up with 91 followed
by knight c2 and perhaps even knight e3
and in a funny turn of events it might
be black's center pawn uh that becomes
the serious weakness whereas the c pawn
is going absolutely nowhere it is
totally blockaded white is on the cusp
of being technically winning here and to
add insult to injury shocker are very
low on time
yeah this one
isn't fun against anyone but especially
not against magnus carlsen i think a few
people i don't know what your feeling is
danny i've seen a few people think uh
well opined that magnus hasn't been
quite as as ruthless
as of late as he
as he used to be i mean he used to be
known to be so clinical what's your take
on that
man he barely won the world championship
i mean it really came down to the last
game
um just made all draws against jan
then he had a terrible rapper to blitz i
mean
is magnus even capable of winning a
tournament anymore
uh i i think you know to testify mark
twain rumors of magnus's decline have
been greatly exaggerated
um and i think
you know people tend to take his wins
for granted but uh if you think about
magnus's round two for example who can
be geary like that can you name a player
who can do that to anish giri because i
can't
and
one could argue that there are very
specific instances where magnus
perhaps isn't quite as accurate at
converting advantages he gives maybe
marginally more chances to his opponent
uh in the last couple of months but i i
strongly disagree with the idea that you
know and i know it's floating around but
you know he's leading this tournament
he's very likely to win this game
uh what more can you ask of me
the expectations on him are
are so
insanely high that anytime there's even
the slightest deviation from them uh i
think people tend to tend to kind of go
to extremes very often
i agree and i think today will actually
be a an interesting in an indicator not
an indicator but um today is the day
where magnus has the chance to uh from
here on out i think this is a position
that suits him well he has a chance to
beat his co-leader with the white pieces
take the solid here
and i think he is so eager to win uh an
eighth title here in viking zoo which is
incredible
he's got seven under his belt already
last year jordan won two years ago fabi
um and i think magnus
he thinks
it is time and here we see uh well
what's at stake this year the goal at
the words 2900 that isn't actually going
so great at the moment because magnus is
just too high-rated he needs too big a
score to to win rating
yeah he needs to farm these guys and an
interesting point by somebody under the
screen named gm
hess i don't know if i'm pronouncing
that correctly
uh the opening changes we've seen from i
don't even know why i'm reading this off
the opening changes we've seen for
magnus in 2018 sveshnikov and 2021-22
catalan have been awesome for him in
particular and chess as a whole indeed
uh euchan magnus has never really been
known as someone who puts you know his
main emphasis on openings and yet his
opening choices have been incredibly
wise he seems to always
uh choose a repertoire i mean his
repertoire obviously has changed from
year to year and it's incredibly vast uh
but it just seems like he's able to
funnel the position in the right
direction and and get exactly the kinds
of positions that he thrives in the most
the catalan fits him like a glove in
particular
yeah and i think we've seen him have
quite a lot of
fun with those opening
uh games i wonder if in a way magnus at
the world championship was even
disappointed in a way
and
just how easy it was in the end but i
think here yeah he's um
very eager to win this tournament i
think he doesn't just want to win it but
he wants to make a statement he wants uh
to get a big score and he wants to take
a first step towards twenty nine hundred
we will come back here but shakia
looking like he is in quite a bit of
trouble let's bring back the bird's eye
view we see that anish has gone rook a3
indeed and maybe uh
maybe daniel we can go back to nils
grandelius against karani at the bottom
right corner there because things are
heating up
absolutely let's go to that game and it
does seem to me that nils is
uh his his strategy is backfired
um first of all again down to 22 minutes
now fabi has responded so well to nils's
move knight f1 what is fabi done well
fabi immediately went before no more
time to waste neil's continuing the
maneuver fabi getting his other rook to
b8 h5 knight f8 knight g4 and fabi
uh i think he strikes at exactly the
right moment one more tempo for niels
one more tempo and the plane would take
off you know this
reminds me of
of the scenes where you know they're
like shooting at the airplane the
airplane is taking off
um and fabby right on time takes takes
and queen b two and this forces white to
respond now an end game is unthinkable
here for neil so he has to decline the
queen trade but if he does if he plays
queen f1
then that queen is
not going to join the attack any time
soon it's sort of excommunicated and
maybe it can go around through h3 but
that's slow and fabi can use this
opportunity to get the rook into the
game with rook b3
the position fiona is incredibly
complicated but it's very clear that
fabi has gotten clear-cut counter play
for the first time on the queen side and
white still has a lot to prove on the
other side of the board i really think
that neil niels made a very serious
mistake
and it's a different pushing the jeep on
yeah and i think it's a difficult spot
for nils uh to find himself in because
he invested so much time if we go back
to that moment where he ended up playing
knight uh f1 maybe you can show once
again you uh we were a big fan of the
move king h1 to simply immediately
vacate the g-file getting ready to just
throw everything at the black king nils
here spent
almost 40 minutes
and then
played knight f1
i don't know uh if he considered this
i'd be surprised if in 40 minutes he
didn't consider this or what he he
didn't like but even if he he didn't
know he these players sense of course
that
that they are doing well that there
should be something
and then suddenly you make a few moves
and that feeling has evaporated queen b2
is on the board uh you have to either
retreat the queen you don't want to
exchange it and i think it's just
such a tough spot to find yourself in
also psychologically and well to come
back to this position queen f1 we don't
really like we don't like taking can we
drop something between
the queens yeah we can try
the problem is that there's tactics
against everything bishop c2
i mean they're
knight takes e5
and i take c5 oh that's very very strong
yeah because the bishop on c2 hangs so
that's out of the question
if you play bishop d2
then well at the very least black could
take on d4
but the engine also indicates that rook
b3
is very strong just keeping keeping this
move in reserve and if you play knight
d2 then
here definitely black takes on d4 so
essentially queen f1 is i wouldn't say
force because the only other move is
queen d1 and in fact maybe queen d1 is
better because at least that keeps open
a pathway uh potentially to g4 but after
rook b3 once again white has a lot to
prove here and i should just point out
that rook b1 never traps the queen
because the queen will always be able to
take the pawn on e3 and so there isn't
even a hypothetical way
uh to to trap the queen and after rookie
two there's a brilliant idea by black
black can even sacrifice the queen for
the rook and the beast
and the pawn on a3 is gonna be lost and
you can just see how active black is on
the queen side so even something like
this
is highly unpleasant to deal with
for white
yeah and neil's now in a very unenviable
situation with under 19 minutes on the
clock for as many moves 19 moves still
to
to make and once again uh we we are in
this situation uh we talked about prague
earlier the miss chance with knight g5
of what happens especially when you are
playing against a player like magnus
like fabiano these are the best players
in the world
you get a chance you just have to
to grab it immediately and once again i
know that's a lot easier for me to say
here but we've just seen it happen uh
over and over again when you don't grab
the chance immediately look what happens
these players they don't give you
another chance
no they don't they really don't and
that's not just a cliche in the hands of
these players you
you know you have this one shot and you
better use it and neil's you can kind of
sense the exasperation
um as his clock keeps ticking on down
and
you know at the end of the day fabi has
to be complimented on what is a very
gutsy strategy i mean playing the french
against nils is scary uh playing the
french against a very strong attacking
player
and it's way too early to call this game
i mean there's plenty of fight left
uh but
it's quite clear that you know in spite
of
the danger fabi
fabi's strategy has been vindicated
yeah and i think the reason that we
sound so
maybe pessimistic about neil's chances
is very often when the momentum starts
shifting like that it's so tough to to
reverse it
yeah
shall we go back to the bird's eye view
and see oh let's go back to anish
against sam because those black pawns
are just uh dropping like flies
they really are and um
let us indeed go to that game
well i think this one it might be our
first decisive result and our first
result in general uh mamadiara by the
way also is just his position is
tumbling down the drain now what's going
on here well sam in response to rook a3
he decided to take on h4 and at least
try to go for some counter play uh with
the combination of the knight and the
pawn anish bringing his king up to
defend the bishop and i think the point
is that after rook g8
um the simple truth of the matter is
that black has no threats there is just
no discovery and so white can take this
opportunity to push the f1 down the
board f6
and if you
come around and take that pawn
then you know black relinquishes
whatever grip
he has on white's position knight takes
f6 and white can go after the last
remaining queen side pawn
it's like george washington's last tooth
king c5 rook c7 check
and you have an unenviable choice either
come back to d6 and allow rook c6 check
or walk forward to d4 and allow the d6
spawn essentially to promote i mean
after d7 the bishop and the rook both
support that pawn and then you could
send the other pawns down the board with
b4 c5 this is losing and gary just needs
a couple more accurate moves to finish
this game off
wow let's bring back the bird's eye view
i see someone in the chat saying and
niels has blundered i was wondering i
never know are we being told but he has
played knight he too
uh which i think we were saying uh
is no good
i mean i wasn't even thinking about this
move because of knight takes d4 but he's
found a really amazing tactic so if if
black plays knight takes d4
um white has knight takes h6 check
opening up the king now you you have to
take the knight otherwise knight takes
f7 and now queen shift
and the point is that after king h8
white doesn't even take on d4 white
actually takes on h6
and uh it's very very difficult it's
actually impossible to stop mate without
giving up a bunch of pieces so
um
so knight 64 is as it turns out bad
but black can prepare it black can
basically say okay this pawn is hanging
so let me make a prophylactic move let
me let me move my own king over to h8
so that knight takes h6 doesn't come
with check and now it's very very
difficult for white to stop bishop to
stop knight takes d4 white can play
queen f3 uh attacking the f pawn but
black just brings the bishop back to e8
uh and and once again knight takes d4 is
is essentially unstoppable since queen
f4 runs into bishop g5 and the queen has
to go back that's an incredible move
king h8
to have that foresight to think there is
a pawn hanging let's not take it
immediately
what should i do get my kick out of
trouble
i am so so curious to see if fabiano
finds the move here
we'll see let's uh once again i think
you're saying that shakira's position is
also crumbling that is of course our
main game of the day so let's go there
yeah
let's go there and i i think fabi will
find that move by the way because
i mean he will see that knight takes d4
runs into knight takes h6 and if you
sort of think logically it it's possible
to
uh to jump from that thought to finding
king h8 but yes let's get to the magnus
game because stranger out of desperation
has just played a move pawn f6 he's
trying everything he can to open up the
center
uh and and get his pieces breathing
again
but
it feels like magnus is just a couple of
accurate moves away from winning this
game now
he takes f6 here would play right into
black's hands and magnus is not going to
do that that gets the bishop out and now
the d4 pawn is once again in trouble
it seems that the correct move after f6
is not knight c2 as originally planned
but actually knight
out to d3
and the reason you diverge from the path
is in order to reinforce the e5 pawn if
black plays f takes e5 now
uh you have a very very simple tactic
now if you notice the fact that the rook
is x-raying the bishop on e6 and the
bishop is undefended so you can play
knight takes e5 knight takes e5 rook
takes c6 and the game is over the plot
on c3 is a paper tiger uh it can advance
to c2 but no further than that
uh whereas blacks the rest of black's
position crumbles to dust i mean white's
bishop is going to take on d5
black is already down in exchange and
more material losses are imminent if
magnus finds knight d3 fiona the game
is
will be very very close to simply being
over yeah so after knight d3
my question is what is the if black
doesn't take on e5 okay if he doesn't
take on f5 of course the question is why
did he play f6 then but if that doesn't
work
uh what else
well there's knight takes d4 but now
another simple tactic rook takes e6 this
time stacking the exchange back for
decisive pin
on the knight and if you defend it
uh white can attack it in in several
different ways actually the simplest
being that f4
um and
chakra is not going to go for this
really the key for magnus is define
knight d3 uh and and this move can be
hard because well you have to see that
the d4 pawn is untouchable and you have
to realize that the c3 pawn is nothing
to fear even if it's not blockaded by a
knight
we will see magnus
i think he is in that position where he
senses
there is something i mean it's insane
that the bar is telling us plus five i
don't know how much of an exaggeration
that is probably not so much i think
it's true
no and this is true i mean these lines
are very calculated this is not just
engine
you know some engine stuff it's it's
it's completely understandable black's
position is collapsing the bishop on e6
is undefended
and by the way the knight is also
uh threatening to swing to f4
i mean if magnus plays this move the
game is over let's be
let's be blunt
so well we have two uh our top two
players here in a big moment we're
expecting knight d3
uh for magnus and king h8 from favi
let's bring back the birds eye view
quickly dania if you can give us an
update uh
on the main games what is happening and
we'll take a quick break
sure well we've got anish giri on his
path to victory he's just a couple of
moves out as is the world champion
um two massive results if in fact the
games don't take a miraculous turn we
can see yam tristab duda
uh putting on the heat i mean that he's
got that pawn on c6 andre is in big
trouble things have taken a turn for the
worse in his game
um you know van forest dubob neither of
those players in contention right now uh
for first place but jordan continuing to
nurture
uh a clear advantage prague well his
game we haven't looked at in a while
shall we have a quick look at his game
before we go on break or do you wanna do
you think we should do that afterwards
uh i think we'll have a look after after
the break then we'll have a time to take
a deeper dive
absolutely we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to round nine of
the tata seal chess tournament
and dania we see on camera there oh a
result just popped up as we were talking
a draw between jordan van ferrace and
daniel duval
indeed let's have a look because jordan
has been better all game but it seems
like his advantage evaporated in the
last couple of moves let's debrief
everyone on what happens a pretty
serious mistake somewhere in there
because he was in great shape so we
looked at this moment dubov trying to
whip up counter play on the king's side
uh king h2 and now striking in the
center with d5
bishop d2 developing the bishop this
seems normal
and after d4 c4 somewhere around here
duboff started getting life again that
bishop coming back out to c5
jordan playing queen e2 bishop c5 rookie
d1 queen c7 i think this move bishop e3
i actually think jonah this might have
been a misjudgment
by uh
by van force because
what ends up happening
is he stuck with this bishop and you
know i like to compare this bishop to
being banished on on an island right the
island is nice it's like paradise but
you can't escape right you're basically
imprisoned and white's king is not
entirely out of the woods this rook is
exerting pressure you can see that the
eol bar is showing equality here
um and if you take on d8 then black gets
control of the d file you can't play
rook d1 so my guess is that white could
have preserved an advantage
by refraining from bishop e3 perhaps
going bishop e 1 and opening up the
default and later maybe even redeploying
the bishop with f3 bishop g3 in any case
i'm sure this will be analyzed more
deeply jordan he's going to be
disappointed he's been better all game
but good stuff by dubai now two games in
a row uh on top defensively uh
neutralizing two nasty positions that
pawn down end game against duda and now
uh a clearly worst position against vent
force the first result of the day is a
drop it's interesting he always senses
these moments as soon as he's back in
the game those draw offer is always well
timed we saw it today
it was literally the first moment where
he was not under pressure he sends that
offer to draw which was accepted we saw
the same of course in that infamous game
against shah
um but for now yeah let's go back to the
bird's eye view because i think there
are two other games which are on the
verge of ending and i think we'll have
to start with magnus carlsen who found
knight d3 and that knight is already on
e5 and danya this uh looks like it's
game over
we might see a resignation really any
second um and they're following the line
we showed first i mean if i take c5 rook
takes e6 i don't see any alternatives
for chakra are at this point is knight
is hanging on c6
i mean i guess i
guess he could play knight d8
but in this case the simplest one you
could probably go rook takes c6 here
you could also go rook a7
and white is
i mean there's domination all
over the board black doesn't have
even a sliver of counter play that pawn
on c3 once again is totally useless so
i'm expecting chakriar to resign either
here
or on the next move
uh he's also got 10 minutes really to
add insult to injury for 15 moves
and magnus managed his time so well what
a game today by magnus it was a
i don't know where exactly did it go
wrong for shaq because at first
we were saying this uh
exchange sacrifice is interesting you
know the long-term compensation and it
feels like
magnus made a few moves and shaq didn't
make an obvious blunder and suddenly
it was close to being over
exactly and i think that's another
reason why you know people who say that
magnus is in a slump
you know don't factor in a lot of a lot
of things and one of those things is the
fact that magnus wins
not only more games he wins so many more
games like this than anybody else where
it just seems like his opponent has a
fine position and chakra was playing
creatively and then two moves later he's
completely lost and you look back and
you say well he didn't make any obvious
blunders you know that exchange
sacrifice looked justified i think if we
reason objectively
h6 might have been
the biggest mistake of the game although
i'd have to take a closer look with an
engine
to tell you for certain but it seems to
me that in this position he had to get
that bishop out while he had a chance
not letting white coordinate
uh what he was afraid of here is rick
takes that fate bishop f8 and perhaps
knight g5 and that is indeed
quite scary and so chakra are saying hey
let me take a tempo and go h6 that one
tempo allowed white to bring the rook
into a1
um and
queen d1 is such a nice move and then b3
is just phenomenal you know the presence
of mine to realize that the pawn on c3
is totally innocuous and then rook a6 91
all of this played with filigree
precision
uh this is a classic magnus game vintage
technique a great opening idea and
everything in between and i have to say
i'm looking forward to hearing from
magnus because we heard from him
the last time in an interview after his
win against
prague where he didn't seem completely
satisfied he seemed exhausted as well
but today i think he has all reason to
be to be happy with his effort and i'm
looking forward to to hearing from him
yeah he really seemed fresh today he
seemed well rested just you can tell by
his play um there was just a certain
intensity to it that we're used to
seeing when magnus is at his best eight
minutes now for sakurai who is searching
in vain
for a single way to complicate the game
you can just tell by his facial
expression he ain't finding anything
and as his time takes down resignation
becomes the likeliest option
i agree with you for now let's go back
to the bird's eye view because we might
just not have another move here and the
other game which uh seems to be
almost over oh and
dania look at the bottom right corner
fabiano finding king h8 that's very
impressive
what a guy he plays king a trade he took
a while on it uh he sensed the
importance of the moment and neil's now
digging himself further into trouble
uh if he loses this game that'll be
intensely frustrating
um
and fabi he takes a sip of water you
know what that means fiona that means
he's satisfied with this position
yeah that water came out only when he
only after he played queen b2
before he was uh
what's the word like starving can you is
there an equivalent to starving for when
you don't drink
no um unfortunately not let's go to the
shanglen game though he's about to
resign i can i can tell that he's about
to resign let's go
there should be an equivalent of
starving for water oh and that game has
already ended
yes
it has ended let's see the last few
moves
i think they didn't put the kings on the
board immediately so we missed it but uh
you had already called it the last time
we were here and indeed uh there was
nothing sam could do
no there this is just over and rook c6 a
very pretty final move uh using the fact
that the pass pawns are too far advanced
if you take the rook
it's a classic case of trousers two pass
pawns unstoppable by the king
and if you move your rook away after b
takes c4 white has 833 past pawns and
all of them are promoting so
by the way thank you chad uh yeah indeed
there is a word parched
parched that's a good word
yeah so thank you to everyone educating
us or reminding us i think we both knew
it but
uh it didn't come to the forefront of
our mind so our first decisive result a
niche for under trot
currently he has overtaken magnus in the
live standings but that's not going to
last for long as shaq has actually made
a move c2 no
um well he took let's quickly go back
there
he has gone c2 and but magnus has
instantly responded with the correct
uh square for the queen queen e1 and
there's just a couple of lines here that
are easy to calculate if knight d3 that
looks dangerous
uh at first but white responds with rook
takes e7
and uh both queens are hanging and if
knight takes c1 after rook takes c7 it's
all over
um
probably bishop g5 is the best bet for
black
and now white could even just play d
takes e5 allow promotion and respond
where the rook takes c1
bishop takes c1
bishop takes d5
and white has two pawns up but on top of
that white wins a third pawn and perhaps
even a piece with rook c6 so
that's one way the game can unfold a
good chance by shock i mean c2 is the
best practical
practical chance that he has but it's
obviously not going to help
now and we see the time drop down
here and
i still think that now
maybe we'll see a handshake here shaq
has tried his last job but um
yeah there's just no more no more choice
here
and well we'll go back
to the bird's eye view i don't know if
we keep an a camera maybe on shock
because i expect this to be over
momentarily
and things are happening in the duda yes
panko game dania
yeah they are that game in the prague
game let's uh
let's have a look oh and there's the
handshake oh there's a result yeah
uh resigning in this position after
weenie one we see the two uh players
discussing some lines but what a game by
magnus who takes the sole lead here
tonight after round nine
indeed and as they
discussed the game pretty quickly a
resounding victory by magnus really
wired a wire and a great opening choice
the catalan is his new deadly weapon
um you can see him putting the mask on
there but the mask is off during the
game figuratively and literally magnus
in seoul first now with six and a half
out of nine a big win
huge win we see clearly disappointed
making a fast exit but
kudos to magnus and well so with those
three games ending almost cement
simultaneously we have four games still
remaining and the prague game has
changed a lot shall we start with uh
duda
yeah let's start with the duda game
because andre is in critical danger here
he's got less than 10 minutes for 21
moves and his position has deteriorated
i mean he's close to being losing in
this position now we saw
jkd going c5
andre moving the king aside and jan
kristoff moving that pawn to c6
forcing andre back knight d4 b6
and now among other things i mean white
could definitely
the tempting move here is as f4
the tempting move here is f4
and
this is definitely very good for white
but perhaps there's no need to rush i
mean here black can play g fgf and then
move the knight back to g6 and you know
perhaps black is still
still alive the engine suggests a very
patient move f3
just take the g4 square away from black
and then white can essentially go for
checkmate here queen b4 queen a4
and bishop a6 is a very powerful idea if
the bishops are traded then i mean
there's all sorts of mating threats
there's the lobster pins are made and
later on the night what are you calling
that i've never what did you say the
lobster pins are made i think icaru
might have been the the one introduced
so maybe it was excuse me earlier when
you said it i just i was like
just nodded away but i was like what did
he say no i was just too curious i never
heard that but it's a good one
the old 18th century term lobster pincer
mate
um no but yeah yeah sipenko here
in big big trouble and yanchez of duda
he hasn't had the best
start to the tournament but here he
is looking for that uh for that win and
i think he's a big favorite to get it
and we have a an interview so let's go
to anish geary he just beat sam
shankland with the white pieces um
straight off the out of the opening
exchange queens and i kind of like
wondered if you had something in the
opening
uh i don't know but definitely something
in the endgame so that's um that's good
i don't know
it's all droid in chess in the opening
everything is wrong
i've analyzed it all to the end it's all
draw
okay well the master said it himself so
where did it go wrong for for some
um i
i think i was slightly better after his
operation where he traded the bishops
and they gave up his bishop i mean i see
where he's coming from i do have a bad
bishop
but i could also keep the pair of
knights on the boards i mean i have some
pressure somehow his knight on c6 is
misplaced
just like in the italian the pawn on c3
dominates that knight on c6
and um so that's a bit of an issue for
him i think i was choosing for a long
time whether to keep the knights with
knight e3 or to take on d6 finally i
decided to play more concrete and that
paid paid off
the way the game went i can't complain
but i do think 93 also was a small
advantage
um
sam at some point decided to to give up
the pawn with d5 to to get some activity
that didn't really work out for him
yeah i think it was actually a pretty
good try at that point because i was
really wondering what his idea was so
far because if he doesn't uh follow up
with d5 uh i'm much much better i
thought
like i even saw some like i thought i'm
close to winning i even saw some ideas
that i can reroute the bishop and so on
but after d5 um actually i realized at
some point maybe not was not so bad had
he and he told me at the game he thought
he was completely fine if he wouldn't go
king d6 first of all go b6 i think it's
more like i think what should be better
pretty much anyhow but of course
i understand where he's coming from and
if i don't really break through
immediately it does get drawish but i do
think i have a bunch of options that
look attractive
i mean it's a pawn after all but i mean
i understand that he has good drawing
chances if he plays more accurately
after the pawn second i don't think the
pawn stack was actually pretty good
um
you won your game quite fast same for
magnus which is bit mama jaroff you're
keeping up the same pace but magnus has
like half a point extra
um how do you see the next few rounds
yeah so far it's like in the good old
days uh when you know i had those races
with magnus i had them twice in a row
yeah i'm definitely happy where i am and
somehow from what i remember when magnus
plays so well
um even though he's interrupting my
interview now uh
it does motivate me to to do really my
best and that's where i play the best
chess i'm looking forward to the end of
the tournament and to the next games
okay thank you so much
great to hear from anish geary who has
won four games in a row he is looking
forward to the end of the tournament and
interesting that he also thought that
sam's pawn sacrifice uh was actually
good but then the follow-up of course uh
some slipping there
absolutely and really the win over fabi
i think was the turning point for a
nation's tournament because it was a
very rugged start with for him even the
game with fabi wasn't that great but
since then
um he's just played like a new man i
mean particularly this game so smooth
and uh in the style that we have come to
expect uh he's bringing new life into
his tournament four wins in a row i mean
counting the duboff game as a win
let me see actually i think um
maybe we can give some of the credit to
to robert tess for that because anish i
think it was after his draw
against i know it was against karjakin
he came here he joined robert for an
hour and maybe that's what despite him
he made one more draw and then he got on
a winning streak
um but elsewhere
things are i mean today is going to be
crazy dania because
the four remaining positions are all
messy and
none of the players have time on the
clock
no i mean there's gonna be time
scrambles in every game so we're gonna
be toggling like crazy it's been a very
long time since we looked at the
karjakin game
um in that game it has really
transformed so let's have a look at
prague against sergey and once again bad
news for pragnanda i feel like his
position has deteriorated and he really
hasn't made much of that exchange
sacrifice so
what ended up happening he castled long
sergey went e6
and sergey gave up the h-pawn in return
for counter-play against white's b2 pawn
knight d3 back to defend the pawn queen
queen a6 is a very nice move sergey
swinging his queen to c4 that's a very
nasty maneuver and this is where prague
started going a little bit wrong it
seems like the move f5 uh was the only
way to acquire full-fledged counter play
and this leads to a complete mess after
queen c4 queen g3 threatening f6 but in
any case prague deciding on a3
that lets black's queen get to c4 with
impunity and sergey taking the
opportunity to take on d4 and force the
transition into an end game because you
can't take with the pawn the pawn is
pinned so you trade and sergey he plays
f6 which is a very important move that
stops the knight from ever coming to e5
again
prague moving his king up to c2 and in
comes the rook rook b3 g4 doubling on
the b file
and they currently have this position so
white does have a pawn for the exchange
uh but
there isn't much else other than upon i
would say rookie three
is is a viable move for for prague and
at first i thought that a repetition of
moves fiona was likely king f7 rook h3
king g7 but the longer i looked at it
the more it occurred to me that black
could actually play for a win but i can
go rookie eight and and and then maybe
h6 king g6
and it just seems like white's knight
doesn't have
uh
any any um
you know promise anymore maybe you can
go to b4 i was just gonna ask you
actually about that night before jump
but can we afford to do it with the rook
on e3 or should we avoid the exchange of
work says white yeah i don't think so i
think after ruxia that's not a glamorous
move but the thing is black breaks
through king g6 h5
um you know these positions with knight
against rook are just
they're so hard to play and the knight
doesn't have any further squares i mean
why can go b3 here and create a passer
but that passer is far too slow and it's
not even really moving past a7 in the
meantime
uh black can either
bring the king to the rescue or
uh go for something like h5 or f5 so
prague is not lost or anything of that
nature but
he must be disappointed here this is not
what he was looking for when he sacked
on h5 once again another incredible
opening but it seems to be headed in the
wrong direction once more and a
very i think it was a very impressive
defensive effort and what else did we
expect from sergey karjakin and uh he
will sense his chance here
uh the chat is begging us to go back to
niles grandelias and fabiano carana
because wow
three and a half minutes for nils for 16
moves
but more importantly
he has played knight to f6 what a move
what a move and i don't think fabby's
taking that night
no he's not he takes f6 it's crazy and
we have an interview with magnus sorry
daniel let's go there
you just beat uh shakira mohammad jarov
with the white pieces um
the exchange sacrifice by shaq is it
something you didn't expect at all uh
yeah i think the exchange sacrifice was
um was quite expected it was also his
style 100
but
maybe in hindsight
there
were other options there but um
for instance if he goes knight before
first i go queen e4
and the pawn is hanging on a5 i also
have
options of going like queen g4 then 94
knight g5 attacking um
so it was very
understandable that he chose to sort of
be
on the active side there sacrificing
material and to be fair he had already
offered the exchange once there which i
didn't
which i didn't take
i think
after that he had reasonable
compensation but he probably
went wrong
pretty early i felt when i managed to
establish
the rooks on the a file the queen back
to d1 i had very good coordination b3
b3 was nice and then
yeah c3 i think was uh
capitulation after that he has has no
hope but i didn't see what he could do
there um
anyway i think i was already uh in in
the driver's seat
um you won four games so far in vacancy
all of them were between let's say move
25 and 36.
um quite
like there's no long long grinds there
right so yeah it's a bit um back to um
what was working really well for me in
in um
in 2019 in that i i actually got after
the match i actually got very
interesting positions from
from the opening and i could sort of win
in a dynamic style so it's really um
really something that i've um that i've
missed
and
yeah it's going well
um anish giri also won his game
fourth point in a row
would it be like a big
uh fight between you guys you're still
half a point uh ahead of him
yeah i know he's showing his um
uh he's uh playing really really well
the last few days
he's also showing a tremendous
will to win um picking up three points
instead of playing games on three days
for instance
which is shows that you really really
want to win the tournament
um we already did a couple of interviews
uh during the tournament and i think
like this is like the one where you have
the most energy did something change
since uh rest day no not really um i've
generally felt uh felt pretty decent
every every day
so
i don't think you always have the
most energy after
after games but
i always
felt
felt pretty okay
[Music]
and to be fair i felt uh
i actually felt a bit tired
in the in the morning today before the
game so
i wouldn't read too much into it okay
thank you so much thank you
definitely a very different side of
magnus cards than we've seen here a
couple of day a few days ago after the
interview
during the interview after the prague
game he looked exhausted today we've
seen more of mischievous happier magnus
carlsen is back dania
indeed this is the magnus we all know
and love and is this the spark that
ignites another twitter war between
magnus and geary will there be a i mean
they've already thought they were over
the board so they need a different forum
and maybe gary will come back for
another interview now that he knows what
magnus said about him
um you know maybe geary needs to
amend his statements as well we'll see
i mean for sure it will make for an
interesting end to the tournament
because as anish mentioned we had this
race between the two players here a
couple of times before and i think they
do
push each other in that sense so
we'll see who can rake up more wins at
the end of the tournament but for now
let's take a closer look at knight f6
which fabiano has decided not to capture
yeah capturing was was a terrible would
have been terrible just because if he
takes f6 and the king
gets checkmated so fabi correctly takes
on d4
uh to which nils replies queen g4 so the
knight hangs
um once again you you can't
play g takes f6 here because
uh because of bishop takes h6 and
i mean there's checkmate impending
checkmate on
uh on g7
uh so so fabi instead of taking has to
move his knight away from d4
uh the question is where does he move it
and to me there are two tempting squares
the first is to go knight c2
uh and try to force white to give away
his light's good bishop and
he does in this position white probably
has to play bishop takes c2 but black
runs into issues so if rook takes c2
then you walk into rook ab1 if queen
takes c2 you allow the second sack
bishop takes h6
and this ends up being crushing
whichever way you take you get
checkmated either on g7 or on g8
depending on how you capture it so for
that reason the best move in the
position is to play knight c6
now white can still take on h6 but the
reason it's important to keep the queen
on b2 and make sure it doesn't move away
from the diagonal is because in this
position black has bishop takes f6 e
takes f6 and the queen
drops back just in time queen takes f6
uh now niels would have to move his
bishop and after something like queen d4
white's attack has not evaporated but it
has fizzled out just enough to give
black uh several tempe and
according to the engine here black is
better white doesn't have sufficient
compensation but guess what fiona the
game is very far from over and fabi
moves are coming in fast
so he's made another move another night
move and knight takes e8
okay
and i think we're gonna have a
simplification yeah so and fabi took on
the eight nils took on f5 so that's off
the board
and now can we simply recapture on f5
there's also the pawn on a4 hanging
which which of the two do you want to
take
well i think queen takes f5 is more
natural but then uh it allows this nasty
sequence d4 bishop f4 and then black's
knight emerges from the dead knight e6
and the point is that if you take on f7
you lose a piece knight takes f4 queen
takes f4
and then bishop g5 with a skewer
taking on a4 is not easy i mean your
hand reaches for the f5 pawn but niels
recognizes the importance of the moment
he is taking some time here so i'm very
curious to see what he will capture well
he's not going to be able to take too
much time because look at this he's got
three minutes on the clock we're only in
move 27 13 moves
still to go but the fact that he didn't
take immediately is already good news in
that he is considering oh but he has
taken on f5 he's taken on f5 and now for
fabi i it's important to to seize the
moment i mean if he gives white a single
tempo
niels will get his knight to f3 and then
you won't be able to play d4 anymore but
i think fabio has calculated this he
took a while on knight f5 and i think
this has been this was fabi's idea all
along i think we're gonna see d4
we will see uh d4 shall we stay here and
not tough to to go away maybe we can
bring up the bird's eye view just for a
second to make sure
we're not missing something
uh elsewhere
um but maybe
dania you know what we're gonna do we're
gonna take a very quick final break
before the the time control it will be a
super quick one promise we'll be back in
just a couple of minutes with all the
action here leading up to the the first
time control
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
fabiano carrana will he win his second
tata steel chess
it's not looking that way fabiano not
having the best of tournaments but today
a win with the black pieces against
niels grandelius would be huge
it absolutely would be and from the from
the get-go he has demonstrated his
desire
uh to create winning chances uh which is
why i love
you know this part of the tournament
it's where the players who haven't done
that great
but who still harbor desires of
finishing atop the tournament standings
really burn some bridges and fabi has
gone precisely down the line that we
discussed he's got d4
bishop f496 and neil's now below two
minutes on the clock
he can't take on f7 he has to deal with
this incredibly dangerous pass pawn on
d4 and he's got a big weakness on a3 uh
this is
extremely concerning even though
objectively he is probably not
that much worse i just don't see him
surviving this for for 10 more moves he
goes 94.
he's throwing in the knight and you just
mentioned the move number uh for our
viewers so this is move
30 meaning nils has to make another 10
moves until he gets his extra
50 minutes all the players gets 15
minutes extra almost 40.
indeed and 94 clearly allows d3 so that
has to be considered
now
here white can already take on f7
there's no skewer but after knight takes
f4
queen takes f4 black could make a the
simple move rook b to d8 and at least
according to the engine you know this
pawn on d3 is incredibly powerful and
the fact that white's rook on a1 is tied
down to the pawn on a3
also does not help white's cause so
this is unpleasant yeah
tough situation uh for nils indeed
fabiano
uh he senses that
the
this is his chance i think especially
leading up uh to move 40 and here dania
how do you strike the right balance your
opponent is low on the clock you kind of
want to make use of that but you also
want to to play the best objective move
so how do you strike the right balance
yeah you want to trust yourself so you
want to play perhaps more intuitively
than you normally would
um and you definitely want to keep a
time advantage like
fabi really doesn't want to
uh get
you know two to three two three minutes
himself so i would say you know in this
position i would take something like
three minutes
um and sometimes that's an effective
thing to tell yourself
you know i'm gonna budget away
four minutes and i'm going to make a
move uh by the time that i have nine
minutes if you tell that to yourself you
almost pretend that you have four
minutes and uh that way you kind of
encourage yourself to play intuitively
but i am curious to see how long fabio
will take on this move and whether he
will decide to sacrifice the f7 bond
that's not an easy thing to decide on i
mean you have to really figure out the
pawn that the d-pawn is worth
uh worth paying the price of a pawn for
if you don't want to sacrifice the pawn
on f7
um then what are the alternatives to
defend rook f8
you could go work f8 uh but i was
concerned about them of knight d6 here
and i guess you could just you could
just play king jam and you could defend
the pawn there's no question and in fact
that's a very much a viable option i
don't think that white has
anything resembling a serious attack i
was also considering knight f6 but after
gfef there's this very powerful
defensive move rook b5 involving the
rook in the defense and if queen g4 then
you can simply grab that pawn on f6 so
this seems to work out for black as well
but it needs to be calculated and i mean
we talked about needs being very low on
the clock but fabiano i mean 12 minutes
isn't a lot of time either so you can't
afford to spend too much time here we
will leave fabiano to it for a second
bring back the bird's eye view because
elsewhere the time is ticking
also
um maybe a quick update on duda where
the queen's off but it looks like that
doesn't mean black is out of trouble
no in fact mike is still in very serious
trouble and now he's in a similar time
situation to niels he's got four minutes
for 11 moves um
definitely a relief for for andre and
that he found a way to trade queens
rookie eight a four a six queen d3
and in this position he goes for the
queen trade
the issue of course is that well there's
two things first of all white's attack
uh has not evaporated in fact i would
take on b6 here automatically
and then i would worry at myself yeah oh
absolutely i would go rook a1
and then essentially i would consider
bringing the bishop back to d3 and
involving the second rook you could get
checkmated here very very easily so for
instance
um
for instance black could play rook he8
and after bishop d3
you know let's make a random move
it's already over i mean rook before
check
and if king a7 bishop takes a6 ends the
game takes rook b7 check hey crook takes
a six minutes just captured on b6
yep he sees that he's gonna take and
play with a1 i think
and the question is is there a defense
after rook a1 for black
i mean it i think practically speaking
it there really isn't
after rook a1 i would probably go
um
i would probably go 95 here i'd probably
go knight e5 here but that doesn't help
in fact it walks right into white's
hands it plays into white's hands
because you could drop the bishop back
to b3 and once again the other
rook will join the game dania let's
quickly check the two remaining moves
see what the time the clock situation is
there maybe we can start with a report
visit we haven't been there in a while
they were very low
already out of the opening meanwhile
well i'll let you talk through the
position in a second but on the the
clock and on the moves we'll move 30 so
10 moves to go here
yeah and you know this seems to be
fizzling out into a draw it
it appears that vidid has done a very
good job throughout this game of
keeping reports initiative at bay when
it seemed bad out of the opening uh we
won't run through the entire entirety of
the game because there's been a lot of
moves but essentially they went into an
end game and they've been trading pieces
ever since and rihard playing very
creative move rook d1 in this position
leaving his knight on b5 obviously
that's not a blunder the point is that
vidit loses back the piece because he
can't move the c6 knight you lose the e5
knight so what he has to do here he's
got a couple of things he can go knight
a7
and after bishop takes e5 he has a
decision to make he can take the e4 pawn
or he can take the b5 pawn
you can take b5 but you're going to be
slightly worse here white has the two
bishops and the pawn on b6 is kind of a
serious weakness that can be attacked in
the long run by white's bishops
uh the engine for that reason proposes
to take the other pawn on e4
and after bishop takes c4
probably white i don't know why either
has to play bishop e2 or bishop d4
and
park the knight on c8 sorry to interrupt
you apparently things are happening in
the fabiano games i think we are going
to go back there
so niels against fabiano
oh and things are tumbling down the
drain here for nils because fabi
he did play knight takes f4 and d3 man
fabi is just playing so well uh in this
late middle game you know after neil's
played knight f1 fabby has done
everything perfectly neil's responding
with rook 81
and i think he actually has blunt well i
hesitate to call this a blunder but
bishop takes a3 seems very very strong
and if rook takes d3 you can't take on
e5 immediately because the bishop hangs
but there's this intermediate move
bishop before and if you move the rook
that's it queen takes the five four
seven trade and the apon decides the
game
decides the game i mean fabiano he's
just been so precise ever since he was
given a chance and there he
uh there he goes he has just captured
he's taken it on a3
and this one is looking um 20 seconds
for nils yeah 20 seconds
maybe knight d6 is worth a try here
maybe 96 is worth a try in fact i think
that it is
let's have a well let's not have a look
actually because neil
he's down to his last second so we will
see a move be played here very soon it
was a night move so i suspect it is
knight d6 it is good stuff my nails
so knight d6 threatening the pawn on f7
does that mean that fabiano has to take
that knight
yes i believe so and i think fabi is
going to take it takes takes he might
also trade on 21 and that has to be
winning for black but how exactly well
let's have a look bishop d6 i think is
gonna happen and we'll go right back to
the game if this does happen but in the
meantime let's have a quick look at this
position
now the engine suggests a very enginey
move queen back to b5 in order to
restrain
the d6
pawn the point is that d7 is met with
the incredibly fiona cold-blooded move
rook d8 and now you see the point of the
queen on b5 it's x-raying the e8 square
rookie 8 is now impossible
uh and black will ultimately win this
pawn and win the game
i don't know if fabi will see queen b5
from a distance though so
man knight e6 is a great practical
chance for sure nin's trying everything
we see the engine says it is over but in
practice
practice it is a very different story
maybe while fabiano thinks we have a
chance to quickly go to the last game we
haven't seen a prague against karjakin
just to see have they made move 40
what's the situation there
um the black king is finding their way
in but the the bar has changed its mind
and suddenly there's prague h pawn
what's happening with that
well well sergey went for a very
committal option after rookie three the
engine wanted rookie 8 but sergey going
h5 essentially carving out the f5 square
for the king but in return of course
granting prague this passer on h5 i
guess fat uh
fabi i guess sergey uh
concluded that this pawn is too weak to
present any kind of danger but now the
move knight before is a lot more
appealing because this attack on c6 is
stronger with the pawn on h5 overloading
black's defenses now if you trade on e3
and go rook c8 here's the thing after
king d3 black is kind of paralyzed if
you think about it black's king can
pursue the pawn from behind but what
ultimately happens let's not forget
about the c6 pawn white uses the h1 as a
decoy and captures the pawn on c6 with
devastating effect that that's not an
option for black
if he doesn't do that
it appears that black is nothing better
in this position than just to repeat
moves just you know swing the rook back
and forth and white swings the knight
back and forth
i i think this is a very likely
path that the game can follow
and you know we're all rooting for
prague i hope he can save this game
um but he's down to six and a half
minutes this is another time scramble
not as acute as the one in grindelwald's
caruana but still something to keep an
eye on looks like it's a critical moment
will prague find night before we'll keep
an eye on it let's go back indeed two
nils against fabiano
yeah we'll wait it out until fabi makes
a move because he himself is down to
nine minutes and you uh nailed it fiona
i've been in so many of these situations
where you think i've got plenty of time
uh but it's deceptive you're only up
eight minutes and those minutes
evaporate so quickly in fact three
minutes have already come off fabby's
clock as he decides whether or not to
take that knight
the other candidate move here yeah you
can't move the rook you can play you can
consider going cafe
but the reason i don't really like that
is because after knight takes f7 check
oh but now you can play rook takes f7
and if queen takes f7 oh my goodness and
f2
but no white has queen a7 that's insane
and then black plays queen c2 and i
think bishop c5 here is unstoppable with
devastating threats against the f2 pawn
what an idea that's a crazy line but the
bar was after rook f8 it was shut up so
because but if you look at this position
with your with one's like human eyes
that a pawn is gonna be so hard to stop
especially in conjunction with the
pressure on f2 so i think this might be
very appealing to fabian as a practical
opportunity i mean white has to find
this move rook d5
which frankly is is just not an easy
move to play uh in this position queen
before offering the queen trade and now
queen c1 a lot of engine moves will have
to be found by nils
i mean this is insane and it shows once
again that for us sitting at the in the
comfort of our own homes seeing the bar
all the way down looks like an easy win
for bobby's also up seven minutes on the
clock um but things are in in reality
far from being so uh so easy
they are and and yeah knight d6 was a
fantastic practical chance with no time
on his clock
uh to have the presence of mind to do
that is impressive and i would also say
that anytime you see 0.00 that doesn't
mean it's a draw uh that just means it's
sort of dynamically equal that means the
game
the engine thinks the game should end in
a draw if they follow the engine line
which can sometimes be absolutely
meaningless because the engine line uh
is frequently unfindable even with a lot
of time on the clock so it doesn't mean
it's a dead draw or anything of that
nature
so the move that we think fabiano maybe
we can show that line once again it's
such a nice point with that queen b5 oh
i thought that the other um oh the other
one this one also is probably good yeah
but but the best move is bishop takes d6
yes so we should show the best move
according to the engine
is to to trade the rooks
and then you have to stop d7 and you
don't want to go d2 here this is
tempting but you lose the pawn after
rook d1 so the move is queen b5 it does
many things it defends d3 and it keeps
an eye on the d7 square d7 rook d8 and
the pawn and he has captured it
okay this is exciting
takes takes
and he's down to six and a half minutes
now is fabi
takes takes is on the board
they are nowhere near time control
no indeed so
the move we were expecting was another
another capture here
see the one pair of works come off
there's also a3 but i don't know what to
make of that move
let's have a quick look maybe we still
have some time with fabiano still
six-minute h3 looks very tempting as
well i mean that pawn is so far advanced
a3d7 and if you go rook d8
you allow the problem is there's this
queen takes f7 capture and this
threatens rookie a white actually
strikes first here and
black is in trouble
uh black could lose this game too i mean
all three results are possible here
let's let's be very clear that pawn on
d6 is dangerous
yeah and i think when you're fabiano the
nerves are starting to quick spin now
um
and we can even see it from his but he
has captured on e1
he's keeping his cool so far it really
is
queen b5 is a such a hard move to play
and i have a feeling that he'll find it
also so there's the move rook d8 uh to
me this is the more human move
uh but it's the wrong move because if
queen takes f7 and the difference is
that after queen b5 queen takes f7 uh
the rook is on a better square and you
play d2 and guess what black controls
the e8 square in the previous line white
had perpetual check with rookie a check
and then the queen can swing between g6
and e8 here the rook has to go to d1 and
now the straightforward queen e2 decides
the game this is the most important
moment can fabi find queen b5 he's down
in five minutes this is what we're all
here to watch this is a crucial moment
we have the full cam on fabiano
will he find queen b5 he's found pretty
much every single move yes and danny i
guess we have to both uh i think it's
got to he's gonna find it
i think he's gonna find it because i
think he's going well the threat is d7
and rookie a so
you can stop this at two different
points right you can prevent d7 um but
you really can't prevent d7 uh so you
can try rook d8 but he's going to refute
that because if queen takes f7 or you
can prevent that on the other end you
can try to get control of the e8 square
and the only way to do that really
literally is to bring the queen to b5
there's no other square from which the
queen can control the e8 square and so
that really helps babby out if he finds
queen b5
we take our proverbial hats off big time
i mean that would be really impressive
he's down to four minutes though
it would be very very impressive also if
he finds queen b5 i think then the game
and then there is very um
not so much not so many chances anymore
for nils who's done such a great job
starting
from this moment where he played knight
f6 he's created so many practical
problems for fabiano he's managed to
dodge every single one of them and here
this could be the last hurdle dania this
is the last hurdle and niels is praying
i wonder if neil sees queen v5 is one of
the most
uh disheartening one of the most
frightening feelings you see the winning
move
and you're basically praying that your
opponent doesn't see it three and a half
minutes now
for fabi
oh man this is the suspense is on
can i ask you a question that oh well
we'll see a move now
uh i was wondering in those spots if you
yourself as white sea queen b5 do you
mind go please don't play please don't
play please don't oh absolutely no i'm
literally repeating that phrase 100
you're saying that to yourself
and
man fabby now down to three minutes he's
about to make a move it seemed like no
now he's back to thinking
three minutes now this is nerve wrecking
extremely nerve-wracking seat belts
fastened and mandatory he's below three
minutes here he goes he hasn't played it
he's played
allows rook c1 and that seems to have
squandered the win after rook c1
but okay let's put it on the board rook
c1 but what happens after d2 once again
is that pawn is going to be
this is the amazing part white doesn't
take the queen because then y gets mated
right black goes d1 and then rook b
well no it returns to d1 with the rook
and the d2 pawn cannot be defended
because if you bring the rook back to d2
guess what white still has this d-pawn
black has no choice but to play a move
like a3 white captures d2 and the past
pawns cancel each other out this will
end in a draw if niels finds rook c1
that means under a minute as well
roxy one must be the only move surely
and queen b5 was really hard to find i
really don't blame fabi for that yeah he
played a perfect stretch of chess before
that but i think he would find queen b5
under a different set of circumstances
but nerves definitely played a role but
that's not
uh
he still has to find rook c1
and he didn't d1 he played
d1
and let's see it's so hard to say and
that loses according to the engine to
queen c2 and here's the thing after
queen c2 if you play rook c1 now the
opportunity train has passed black plays
d2 and forks the rook with d1 queen
oh man
both players are going to be kicking
themselves but especially niels fabie
will play queen c2 no doubt about that
that is such an insane coaster you're
correct niels he will be uh devastated
when he sees this fabi he has given
another chance but uh i agree with you
queen c2 here unlike queen b5 earlier
queen c2 looks like the natural move
it really does and what did nils miss
why didn't he play rook c1 my guess is
that he didn't see the move rook d1
after d2 he thought he had to take the
queen there and in that case yeah black
is winning there but
let's
wait for fabby he's gonna play quincy
two i'm confident he's got two minutes
and that's enough to find that move
so let's
well known let's not put anything let's
not put it on the road will wait for
fabiano who's uh
to taking down under two
minutes
do you think quincy two is the only
winning move in this position
i believe so i mean you could also
consider playing a3
but that seems to be too slow that let's
white play d7 queen c2 actually creates
a threat of capturing the rook and again
i won't make these moves on the board
just because fabi's about to play a move
but in our head we can imagine queen c2
rook d2
black puts the queen on c1 and then the
rook on b1 and that's deadly and here he
goes he's played queen c2
queen c two is on the board and now fabi
back in a winning position
um
niels now well i guess rook d2
has to be played or yeah you got to go
rick d2 and hope that there's no
checkmate there but there is rook d2
rook b1 check and then the queen can
drop down to c1 or up to c6
and threaten checkmate on h1 in both
cases
this is winning for black it's not
entirely over just yet let's see what
niels ends up doing but we see nils
there with the headshake and i think he
suddenly understands and i mean this is
just horrible you have 10 seconds on the
clock um
and
although the clock has now disappeared
out of you he plays queen d2
d2 i think a three
hmm
oh rugby one rugby one ends the game
immediately
oh but but here's the weapon rugby one
but rook b1 there's rook takes v1 and
then you actually don't take the queen
you have to take the rook there oh my
goodness that's insane
because if you take the queen you allow
d7 and white wins white promotes the
pawn because of the check on b8
not easy to see at all a good practical
chance by niels i also thought a3 in
this position is good for black let's
see what fabby does he's down to a
minute and a half three huge moves
remaining until time control yeah we're
on move 37 which means even four moves
to go for fabi uh and i think in those
moments it's really like fabiano he is
keeping his nerve but we see some red
color appearing i mean this has been
such an intense intense time trouble for
both players and he's played a3
and that's totally understandable that
is the human move rook b1 is not human
it's not human to play rook b1 and this
also wins the game a3 is the human win
because after queen takes d3 black
simply recaptures plays a2 and then
plays rook b1 check neil's out of
desperation here comes his pawn
fabby can just play a2
fabby can just play a2
and a2 the move that will likely appear
on the board as we see some spectators
there blocking richard
it was reported we're being told that
is on the board
now niels can take the queen and promote
with check but at the end of that line
the rook is going to be unable to
prevent
both passers from promoting at the same
time we might see a resignation in this
position i simply do not see a move for
white
wow what a painful painful game for
niels and he had a chance at the very
end rook c1 would have drawn the game
rook c1 was such a hard move
to see stepping into that pawn
pawn to to d2 is not a human once again
it's not something uh
that seems natural at all and here well
we see nils drop back the queen
uh two e one two
the move is d2 again not easy to play
because you allow queen e8 check
that's a gr another great chance by
niels oh tenacious
wow so d2 you're allowed to check on e8
yeah king
h7 cool as a cucumber
i mean that's that's easy to calculate
and then you take the rook on d1 and
make two queens but yeah cool as a
cucumber is the right expression to use
here allowing that check is not for the
faint of heart
two moves to go for fabiano this is move
39 so
he has to make two moves nils one final
move but if fabiano plays the two right
moves it will be over here and he sees
d2 i can just tell
he's got that excited
kind of body language but he's going to
take as long as he can just to calculate
out the details
my goodness what a game
what a crazy crazy game and he didn't
play d2 no we i was wrong we need two
oh
[Music]
now that's a really cool move that's
actually a really cool move it's
probably not as good as d2 as as d2 but
it also preserves a winning advantage it
stops the white queen from coming to it
yet and on the next move black is just
going to go rook d8 and pick off
that pawn on d7 the last move before
time control by niels
let's see what he ends up doing
he had 10 seconds on the clock for nils
but
uh fabiano i think we need to a very
human move and
nils goes king g2 but as you pointed out
now very probably rook d8 and um fabi is
just going to pick up
that pawn
i mean he can even move his own king to
h7 just to prevent
and that's the top engine move just to
prevent uh the pawn from queening with
check that's kind of funny
but let's see what fabian ends up
playing niels is probably going to take
his time now that time control is made
but he's going to come to tur if fabi
plays an accurate move here uh the game
is going to end
very very shortly and let's stick around
here because it is his final move very
important to not forgetting about the
clock time the opponent he has made his
40th move he's off the board it has
happened to many people before but
uh i think bobby is too experienced he's
in the zone he knows 24 seconds he will
have to have made a decision
he's gonna wait until
you know his time
is that just a couple of seconds you can
see 15 seconds he's going to milk this
all the way down
and here he goes
and the move king h7
beautiful what a move by fabi
and it's incredible stuff
and these guys have made move 40 let's
move on from here let's quickly jump
somewhere i'll just let you pick any of
the games remaining and we have made
the time control here let's go to the
other let's just quickly open all the
remaining games to see if we've made the
time control
i think we should have
reported that it just made the time
control and they're in an opposite
colored bishop end game that should be
drawn
but requires a little bit of work from
bennett
uh and then duda asepenko have just made
time control as well mu 40 has been
executed and duda has squandered his
advantage oh my god he squandered his
advantage i have no idea how this
happened but this position
it looks like black has made five moves
and white has made zero andre has
somehow doubled his rooks on the h file
he's opened the h file and he's gotten
his knight onto an outpost that's insane
um shall we go back
let's get a quick look at prague and
then we'll have time to sure so take a
deep breath and and check in catch up
wow this has also changed a lot what the
heck is going on here i had no clue and
this is ridic this is insane now what
happened is that prague
king e4 knight c6 rook c8 knight a7 or
a8
knight b5 king e3
and c6
apparently was the wrong movement
this is such a hard position to get a
handle on prague did have knight c7 and
knight takes e6 that was pretty natural
but he instead goes for c6 and sergey
uh breaking through with e5 this is the
position on the board after move 40.
they all made time control literally at
the same time
you mean they all made time control
after for
four hours that's shocking
i know it never happens
that absolutely never happens
and no but what of course what dania is
saying is all of those games were so
close everything went down to the wire
yeah i mean they all used all of their
time which is not a given no no no i was
joking but i knew what you were saying
but at first when you said that i was
like wait a second is it mathematically
the case that they have to make time
control after force then i was like well
not really right they can play fast
i mean they could make the time control
after 10 minutes right
you know i'm worried that prague might
be losing yeah
and you know why because
actually for simple reason rook c8 c7 d4
and a simple question how do you stop
the
the black pawn from coming to d3
so for example if you play h6 d3 check
and
the issue is if you think the pawn is
stopped no it's not rook g8 and there's
just checkmate on g1 so the rook comes
out
at exactly the right moment if the pawn
had been on h7 would have been a
different story but
the other thing is that if white gives
up the knight in any of these positions
even in the best possible version even
if white has pawns on e7 h7 and c7 none
of those pawns can promote or distract
the rook from the eighth rank
so
this is very worrisome
very worrisome uh four prague and uh it
will be a a pity uh for him once again a
very topsy-turvy
game dania before we check in in more
detail uh with duda and uh
with
today is the penguin but we're
approached with it we're gonna take a
quick breather uh after the time control
has been reached here um but what a day
and we'll be back with the remainder of
the action in just a couple of minutes
bobby
yeah robert
can you read devretsky's endgame manual
to us one more time yeah
no we got to get up
[Applause]
[Laughter]
it was you like i was i was going to do
it
[Laughter]
you know what they say though what
happens in salt lake
it stays in salt lake
exactly
cheers to my super gm friends it's been
good the world championship
on chess.com
let's do this
[Music]
yeah that was that was i was
yeah i'm great
round two
bobby
yes robert
can you read devoretsky's endgame manual
to us one more time yeah
okay okay
i just actually didn't expect you to do
it that time it's funnier like i thought
he was a one time
yeah yeah please okay okay i'm just
trying to add live with what feels
natural yeah
of course it feels natural wait so we
should expect that next yeah
okay just so i'm mentally prepared yeah
okay
what is this
it's eggs
i want an omelet with brie just [ __ ]
eat it
you eat it
we could turn a little bit on the
shoulder there
the
faster card and unibrow i just want to
thank my sponsors uh very much for all
they do to to promote chess
um sounds like a great future credit
card faster card yeah wasn't it fast or
hard
y'all are respecting the wood a little
too much
not fast or hard bobby oh boy i i can't
be with you anymore
okay
i mean i think it's i think it's
hilarious and don't you think people
would would buy this
no i don't think anyone's gonna buy that
tank that's the stupidest person in my
life well okay
i guess that's it
all right that's it that was great
keep it rolling okay
same thing
who is that guy who's that
he didn't come in with you guys
no
we're gonna be right back bobby
yes robert
can you read deboratsky's end game
manual to us one more time yeah yeah
i'm sorry
[Music]
that's so funny
isn't it cool when i predict the moves
you're gonna say because we all see
things in the same way in the same speed
on this show
isn't that cool when we do that
it doesn't make me very happy
[Laughter]
and let's bring up the analysis board as
we do that so ifon can give us her
thoughts on the uh
on the pet shop go aheady fun
uh well yeah actually that's a very good
question because i i was firstly trying
to
yeah danny
my throat's still dry
you're like you've already you've had
five glasses of water okay you remember
what happened last time
my throat's still dry
you've already had five glasses of water
and you remember what happened last time
it was an accident you peed your bed
[Laughter]
you're looking fresh man all six of them
again dude your haircut just looks great
wait did we start the bit
[Laughter]
you're not supposed to say that
that's what's the same
if black's a6 pawn was transported let's
say
good night guys
good night dad i'm good fabi bobby
[Laughter]
you know one more time maybe one of you
guys
i said i said it should i not said it
i think it's funny if people say good
night dad i mean bobby but we need to be
in sync
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back round nine here at the tata
steel chess tournament and the duda yasi
panko game has just ended in a draw and
dania that was quite a close shave for
a yosepenko shave indeed and we saw him
on camera just kind of shaking it did
that really happen
it did he was in huge trouble and the
cataclysm occurred so let's uh debrief
and walk through what exactly happened
when did duda lose his advantage
everything was going great until this
moment fiona a really really bad move by
duda before i'm shocked and i you know
you know that i usually try to take the
side of the players
um i and not the eval bar in this case
i'm going to go after him b4 was really
bad and the reason i'm so critical of
this move is because it blocks the
rook's path to b4 remember we were
talking about those lines where the
bishop drops back the rope comes to b4
to me the move bishop b3 seemed pretty
natural or you could start with rook a1
and then bring the bishop either to b3
or d3 that seemed to have preserved
something resembling a decisive
advantage maybe not totally winning just
yet but in esopenko's time trouble this
should have been enough for the full
point b4 is what set everything off
escepenko gets his knight to e5 now
andre goes h5 that's a great move
h5 f5 distracting duda from the king
side and all of a sudden look at the
counter play that andre has whipped up
in the span of three moves and now rook
e to h7 this detail might have been
overlooked by
jkd and he cannot keep this h pawn alive
g3 walks into a fork uh and once the h
pawn is captured
once g takes h4 happens there's a trade
now the f pawn is weak and duda has to
basically completely relinquish his
kingside play andre going back to e5 and
if you look at this position that king
on b6 is perfectly safe and black
strokes are now ideally placed to
orchestrate an invasion and then white
might have to start thinking about
equalizing duda
very wisely deciding to repeat moves
rook f4 rook d4 my goodness what a great
save by essepenko people are going to be
talking about duda's
uh dude his mistakes rightly so but
andre kudos to him in time pressure
finding that pawn storm f5 h5 and it's
so hard to do after he lost last game a
big recovery for him for sure kudos
indeed and he will be so relieved
because two games in a row uh in this
tournament is tough with especially with
four games to go and then the opponents
they are looking two pounds uh yeah
before
dude i will be thinking about that
moment again tonight but great save by
jesse panko and let's bring back the
bird's eye view we see that niels is
still thinking that's on the button in
the bottom right corner after king h7 uh
he's been so is for resourceful leading
up to this moment but unfortunately
and now that's the end of of the road
although the d-pawn is only one square
away
from becoming a new queen and let's uh
bring up the the big bird maybe
uh that pawn is going nowhere and the
black pawns on the other hand that's a
different story
yeah and the main line here i mean white
has to take the queen and go rook a1
unfortunately this doesn't work out
white is the tempo behind here you can't
take the pawn you have to go after it
with your king
and the simplest win for black is for k7
here i can resign because by the time
by the time that you get to that pawn um
the world's you know is going the earth
will have turned into a supernova and
black will have definitely captured both
of white's pawns
uh the rook obviously can never leave a1
this is a pretty classic scenario in
these types of end games and it's one of
the deadliest situations
you can find yourself in so i think that
neil's
is coming to terms with that a really
sad result for him i mean you have to
feel for the guy he had such a great
position out of the opening this one
mistake in the in the opening that
knight f1 it was a clear misjudgment and
all credit to fabi it wasn't mistake
free but can you really fault fabi for
missing queen b5 and can you fold mules
from missing rook c1 i think the answer
is no totally understandable in time
pressure at the end of the day fabi will
prevail i agreed i mean it was a treat
for all chess fans us included to watch
this time scramble which really had so
many
ups and downs it's heartbreaking
for nils but
fabi on his way to getting a big win
with the black pieces for now quick uh
quickly the bird's eye view let's bring
it back to decide
what is more pressing the rapport
gujarati opposite color bishop ending or
uh karjakins deep on running down the
word
well in the kuryakin game we kind of
looked at briefly so we'll let's wait
until sergey responds to d takes e5 he
can play f takes c5 or he can play the
immediate d4 or even rook c8 ball are
possible my guess is that he's going to
take a a pretty long time in that
position so we'll wait until further
developments let's have a look at the
opposite colored bishop end game to see
whether it's in fact is it a dead draw
does white have serious winning chances
and
spoiler alert i don't have a clear
answer for you and the engine does not
help in such positions it gives plus one
but as i've said many times does plus
one really mean anything in this
position no because either it's a win or
it's a dead draw there's nothing in
between in opposite colored bishop end
games
shall we see first maybe how we got here
we had seen it somewhere leading up to
the move 40.
so
vivid played knight d5 and rehard going
bishop richard going bishop c4
uh this is how this was all set up king
f7 king f2
h5 and apparently there was a better
move bishop d1
which would have prevented the king from
coming to e2 and the point is that if
white tries to transition now
black simply has bishop a4 with a draw
he wins the
uh but did it not i mean in time
pressure he played h5 that's an
inaccuracy it allows king e2
and now king d2 this forces the bishop
away from the diagonal you can't go
bishop a4 now because your bishop gets
trapped and once the bishop leaves
now reheart richard going takes takes
king c3 and after bishop d7 you have
king before what a nice
uh what a nice little sequence by report
there getting to this end game and now
the b5 pawn is kept alive fiona that's
where all the danger comes from that
pawn on b5 is a menace
and let me ask you a question so okay
we know that in general uh
opposite-colored bishop and games are
very often just drawn
draws but here white has the outside
past pawn on the on the b
uh on the b file and i'm wondering dania
if you have visited here you make move
40
after bishop takes b6 you get an extra
50 minutes
how do you
go on about this is this just pure
calculation like what do you do in in
with its truth
yes and no you have to calculate
concretely but you also have to find the
overall defensive approach and what that
really means is you have to find the
right positions for the king and the
bishop that's what it means to find the
right defensive approach here now it's
natural to put the king on d7
uh and you also have to understand where
the danger might be coming from how
could white potentially win this game
well the answer to that question is
yielded by a scenario where black does
nothing which by the way is always a
viable defensive approach what if black
just swings the bishop between e6
uh between e6 and h3 well what happens
then
uh what can happen then is after
something like king c5 if you go back to
e6 white's already winning king d6 then
the king goes to a7
and the pawn is going to be unstoppable
so somewhere along the line
black has to prevent the king from
reaching a7 and the last moment at which
he could do that was here black can play
the move bishop f1
anchoring himself to the pawn
if white plays b6 prematurely black can
probably get away with bishop a6 and
vinnette wouldn't even mind giving away
the d-pawn if it means that he had a
permanent blockade going on b6 so that
would be one possibility but my guess is
that he's not going to sit around and
wait my guess is that he's going to play
bishop f1 as quickly as possible i think
you should put this bishop here
i also think that he should probably and
now i think you should play king d7 and
you're going to get a position like this
it's about a 50 50. i think white's got
winning chances uh and it's no fun for
vida to defend this that's for sure yeah
this is a long torture ahead uh for
vetted and
as
so often i mean he's had some tough uh
defensive calls to make leading up to
the time travel now he has made move
forward he's gotten his extra 50 minutes
20 of those are already gone and he
could be
thinking for a while longer here well
absolutely he could even take half an
hour even more
and let me tell you richard is enjoying
his life right now because he cannot
lose this game he can walk around and
watch the other games and for him
the moves are very simple like he has to
go king before and he has to bring the
bishop back and then he has to play king
c5 so
uh this is one of the nastiest types of
positions to defend where your opponent
doesn't even really have a choice you
are the one who has to really choose the
defense of construction
so let's uh well first of all let's see
if niels
has made a move and then we can check in
with the prague game and then we also
have a question from our producer and he
has actually just uh resigned just as we
go there um there were a couple of more
moves a couple more moves were played so
let's just
um very quickly and we see i mean it's
so so tough for nils and this is the
first time in general he's
a very cheerful person even most losses
but i think today was
really really maybe his toughest loss of
loss of the tournament because he knows
i think that in the opening he had some
chances uh and then he fought so
valiantly maybe he sensed that he he
could almost hold it in the balance
somewhere between
before the time trouble and then um
after
after that one
rook d1 move it was all all gone
yeah it's and obviously niels came into
this tournament hoping to score some
upsets it's always
such a great opportunity
to play this kind of event and you know
to lose as many games as he had is going
to be a great disappointment i'm sure he
holds himself
to the highest standard but
uh that's just how it goes you know
that's just how this tournament goes
these tournaments go and you're not in
ideal form
you called it fiona you don't get more
than one chance during these games and
sometimes you don't even get a single
chance and this game is a great example
of that i guess neil's had a chance at
the end to draw the game but i don't
really count that these big chants came
in the early middle game once that was
squandered
fabiano you know went beast mode
maybe we can very quickly just show how
the game concluded so we left it off
after king
h7 yeah he did end up taking the queen
and going over k1 i mean this is
the pathway that we outlined and he
resigned after rook a7 because yeah
fabby's gonna go g6 and open up
uh the pathway toward white's remaining
king side pawns and
white isn't even close to being in time
to take that point maybe we can very
quickly go into a bit more detail here
because i see a few people in the chat
saying they don't understand why did
nils resign so let's just try and make
some more moves and try and explain uh
why the position is so lost
so let me describe this from a high
level perspective and then i'll show
some specifics why is white laws the
reason why it is lost is the fog white
has to go and take this bond right
otherwise white is always going to be
tied down
by the time that white captures this
pawn
essentially black's king is already
going to be so far advanced on the
king's side that white's going to lose
either two or all three of his pawns
now you might say but i don't get how
the king is actually going to get
through g6 and that's why black plays g6
in order to open up that pathway that
avenue now white can play g4 but that
doesn't actually help because now the
king has a slightly different path that
can go through f6
and you know after king king b2
actually king g5 is not the cleanest win
because the rook and the king can trade
places and white can still pretend to
play on
but the king can go after the f1 king f5
and for instance take stake stakes and
hear either king g4
or king f4 and that's it all of white's
pawns are lost and similarly if white
takes on g6 it's really the same thing
um
white has to go after the pawn and then
black's king is just going to go through
f5 to g4 and
in the pawn end game
it's not even close white's king is
literally on the other side of the world
yeah
that clarifies it i see another question
from tunde mike uh one of our mods who's
doing such a great job throughout the
tournament he's saying can't he still
draw if he doesn't go for the rp i'm not
sure is does rp stand for work pawn yeah
well let's take a look so let's say i
guess what mike is asking is like what
if white just
stays afloat
uh it's the thing is that white's king
alone cannot hold on forever so for
example let's say we place king f3 first
black is gonna push the king away
and then black is just gonna slowly push
his pawns and his king until white is
blown off the board so for instance king
f1
king g4
king g2 and now why black can push the f
pawn
white is in zouk swan right you can't
push the f pawn because you give up g3
you have to bring the king back boom
king f3 and eventually you're going to
get a situation like this and black is
going to go rook b3 followed by rook b1
the king is going to be pushed to the
first rank at which point it's either
going to be checkmated or if you go to
h2 then you have to give up this pawn
and uh the rest is easy right
also black can go
toward white's rook by the way like
another approach the black attack is
just to go all the way to b2 so
uh it's just not defensible now you
might say well why did neil's not play
this out because he knows that fabby
sees this this is a very typical type of
end game and none of black's moves in
that line were even remotely difficult
so his resignation is totally not
premature
and from there well let's go now to
prague you're correct karyakin is still
uh thinking but let's try and
and see if we can uh figure this one out
maybe even until the end
yeah i mean the thing is that um he has
to decide
uh between a couple of moves that f
takes e5
the question is does this give white any
additional options well it does it gives
white the option of throwing the knight
on c7 rather than the pawn
and the point is that if rook d8 happens
after f takes c5 d4
this knight on c7 actually is a very
valuable defensive piece you might
wonder why well let me explain h6
d3 check remember this position fiona
black used to have this mating move now
white has a check on d5 this dislodges
the king on a3 why is that important it
is important because now the king has
the d2 square white throws in h7 and it
appears that white is able to draw the
game i mean rookie one check
actually loses so black needs to go rook
h8
and now the computer line is 97 rook
takes h7 c7 and now black has to resort
to a perpetual check once again king e3
the knight swings back to d5 so my guess
is that that is what is bothering sergey
and if that is the case
black can actually start with the move
rook c8 this looks crazy but it's really
not it prevents knight c7 it forces the
pawn to move to c7 and now sergey can go
down the line we outline in fact i think
he's going to play rook c8 and now let's
compare and contrast
look at this position
and obviously compare that to the
position after
rook g8 here here white has an id5 check
there the knight is on b5 the pawn is on
c7 and even if you promote that doesn't
help it doesn't distract their work from
checkmate rook c8 seems to be the
winning move although don't quote me on
that maybe white has something crazy
along the line and last thing if flight
pushes the epon black takes on c6 and
picks it off regardless of whether you
play e takes f6 or e6 this is what these
end games come down to fiona these
nuances these subtleties that's why you
can't rush in the end game how many
people would automatically take on e5
many
many indeed
and i i think i saw from the corner of
my eye i think that d4 immediately which
might also be tempting is in fact not
good and maybe we can try and figure out
why
yeah so here i mean there's some crazy
computer computer moves but
i think white i mean let's say white
plays h6 and just pushes one of the
passers let's try to get a handle on the
position the king actually should go to
b1 here of course because king d1 gets
checkmated so there's no choice and
after d2
the knight is in time to stop the pawn
and essentially you're going to get a
situation where you have the three pass
pawns against the rook
um and it's
not i mean if black plays rook g8 after
e6
i mean this position is so crazy with
the tree right
but you can end up losing this really
easily like if you if you move the rook
away from the eighth rank the pawns are
going to be overwhelming
um so this is a hard situation to
uh
to deal with now you might say well why
can't
why do this after rook c8 c7 what's the
difference how does this help
the way that this helps
is that okay let's say you play h6 right
after d3 king b1 d2
the inclusion of rook c8 c7 means that
black can simply take on c7 and then
take the knight on c3 and promote with
check and it looks like there is fork
yeah
but but just simply king e2 or whatever
king d3
and it's it's it's winning the the the
pawn promotes
and
being the rainbow uh our producer
bigfoot has just brought my attention
back to something he had let me know a
while ago so
um
question
i'll just forward it to you dania so i
don't have to deal with this and be
trapped with whatever he's got prepared
for us trapped or checked
question from the producer what was the
biggest
opening blunder this round
and he also said answer is i will answer
once you come up with one
wait i don't get it he will answer i
think he's saying well you're gonna say
something dania and once you say
whatever it is you say
i'll tell you
i see so he's leading me on he wants me
he wants me to make a fool of myself i
see the biggest opening blunder
so the biggest blunder that occurred in
the opening
yeah huh
so grandelias carawanda
didn't really have any blunders report
vidi
i mean carlson mom and yara the the
mistakes occurred in the middle game
duda as a panko i can tell you i mean
i'm sitting next to i'm sitting next to
the keys
rubbing his hands he's got a white smile
on him very pleased he's very pleased
with himself he's very pleased
all right thank you you're the man of
the hour please share all right you have
my attention
now he's telling you check the screen i
will show you
okay well i'm looking at the screen
oh my goodness
oh this was terrible oh my god i can't
believe goodbye
i mean i look at the chat and the first
thing i see producer is so cringy
daniel has left the building
okay i'm off as well we're calling it a
day here
bye sorry yep
all right fine
i said i want to keep my job
well that's the only reason i'm still
commenting
i was actually i was thinking is that
gonna be it no that would be too late
but he took the gamble further
i knew it was something like that i mean
i i know bic too well to think that it's
actually something chess related so i
knew it would be something of that
nature it just it just slipped my mind
oh well we've made him happy that's all
that counts at the end of the day it
really is we gotta make big smile more
you know that's that's our goal in life
i mean i'm just gonna go and drown
myself in the sea here bye dania it's
been good knowing you
likewise yeah
that looks like a pretty comfortable
seat
you know more comfortable than
trying to answer bix questions
in any case kuryakyn in the meantime
he's still thinking now we've talked
about the situation many times he's
probably going to get into time pressure
again but he's correct to think about it
for as long as he has because
this is the game deciding moment right
here and right now
and rook c8 seems to seems to be the
move
and
i think he is of course here completely
justified in taking his time because he
is trying i think this is one of the
games where you can just
basically with brute calculation just
calculate your way uh to the end of the
game and so here it makes a lot of sense
i think to take
pretty much almost all the time if you
can find the first uh a first one
yeah and i mean the position is
complicated but it is not as complicated
as it looks i i'll put it that way i
think it the human can process it uh
like if you notice this idea of the
knight stopping the pawn
then it makes sense to go rook c8 you
also have to see f takes e597 i think
the easiest thing to miss
is this move knight c7 which
looks incredibly unnatural because it
blocks the pawn um if you see this move
then you're going to play rook c again
yeah and let's go and see uh if um if
vidit has made up his mind because we
have two people spending a lot of time
on move forward oh my god
he's down to 20 minutes
crazy
he's down at 20 minutes after two moves
of the time control
and something tells me that he's in big
big trouble i mean it's so hard to
defend this position i mean he's only
made one move basically so the only move
he's made is bishop f1
yep
before
now
the engine in such positions always
recommends
you know crazy stuff that's really hard
to find i mean in this case it's saying
go bishop g2
induce f4 and then try to orchestrate
pawn trades with g5
but
i think again the engine is very
short-sighted in these end games and i
think this
might backfire due to bishop d4 that
hits the f pawn
where it hurts and it's understandable
to want to put your pawns on the light
squares in an opposite colored bishop
end game you're guaranteeing that they
can be defended by your bishop but after
king c5 i mean this does not look
appealing at all
no i mean i don't know
uh
i think yeah that line the problem was
just there were too many holes and i
don't know how you keep the white uh
king out
so that is not appealing i mean
neither does vidiq he's been taking he's
below 20 minutes now
and
for a report he's got 47 minutes and
like like i said it's not because he's
playing
in a sloppy fashion he literally has
only moved he had to play king before
right
so
yeah i'm pessimistic about it his
chances here
yeah especially because i mean i think
the
the honest truth is that we are not sure
is this um
is this a win is it a draw it's so hard
like
i don't even know dania when when if you
were given this as a
as a study like
how do you do it even let's say that it
had the help of the engine which isn't
always necessarily very helpful how do
you get to the the truth of this
position
i mean you just gotta like
brute force a bunch of different
scenarios i mean it's less about the
individual what makes this position so
hard to analyze is that it's less about
the individual moves
and more about the the concepts like
there's many different types of
positions and i guess
other than deciding where the king and
the bishop belong what makes this
position even more complex is that black
has to decide how to arrange his
kingside pawns and almost every
arrangement
you could make a case for like you could
play f5 g6 right and put the pawns on
the light squares the problem is that
and there's always going to be a
drawback with any arrangement you choose
you could try going g5 as the computer
seems to suggest you could play bishop
e2 and induce f4 or you could go without
that you could play h4 there's like six
or seven different arrangements and it's
entirely possible that the draw is
yielded only by one of these
arrangements so me saying that i'm
pessimistic is not a knock on
vidit's calculation skills which are
immaculate i mean he is
an absolute beast and anybody who's seen
any of his games knows that
it's just that this task might not even
be
manageable by as you said a human
working with a computer uh in the
comfort of one's own home so uh if it
manages to save this i will be
tremendously impressed yeah i mean it's
such an an unenviable
position he finds himself in
looked like he was about to make a move
we see richard is just pacing back and
forth there in the background
and um
yeah i guess practically speaking with
its chances of holding are very very uh
little
yeah yep and this just shows you that i
think people
overestimate the drawing tendencies of
opposite colored bishop end games they
think that every
ocbn game is a draw and yes you could
set up a position for pawns down that is
a draw so there's a high probability of
blockades and fortresses
but that really does not mean every end
game is is automatically automatically
drawn and i really think that uh let his
guard down just a little bit in allowing
richard's king to get to b4 just to
reiterate where the mistake was
again don't call me on this but i feel
like the move h5
it's good from a
sort of point of view of improving the
structure but it allows the king to
access e2 and e2 is the entry point to
b4 the move bishop d1 would have shut
the king away
from the e2 square and i think this
would have yielded probably the dravia
of fortress and with it reaching out
looked like he was reaching for the he's
got to move the jeepney has got to move
also i was seeing a comment in the chat
somehow i i completely lost track we've
already had three decisive results and
we could have two more so today could be
a day with five decisive results
potentially as vetted goes for g6
yeah g6 admitted choosing one of the
many arrangements uh and we discussed
this yeah he might play f5 and he he
puts his pawns in the light squares
where they cannot be attacked what is
the drawback of that arrangement the
drawback of that arrangement is that the
pawn on g6 itself is going to be a
weakness so if white's king is ever able
to infiltrate to f6 black
you know could end up just being screwed
on the spot
so for instance bishop d4
f5
king c5 looks very natural now black
doesn't have to defend this pawn black
has to go king d7 in fact
and now again the engines evolves swing
wildly but not because of a glitch it's
just because even the engine
needs to evaluate this at a very high
depth
and
b6
i think vivid could maybe set up a
fortress of bishop e2
and bishop f3 at least that's the engine
line and look at this fiona if white
plays bishop b5 looks winning right this
threatens b7 black gives up the d-pawn
and all of a sudden the bishop is
ideally placed this is a fortress this
is a total fortress because
black's king basically follows white's
king wherever it goes
as soon as white skin goes to c5 whoop
king comes back to d7 king goes back to
d4 thing goes back to e6 and there's
literally nothing that y can do so
make no mistake this is not an easy win
and the evaluation could change in a
single half move
i got really into that for some reason
i love that
um
someone who isn't
loving this
i have to credit credit this to chris
berman who is a uh
a famous uh basketball and sports
commentator he's the originator of the
whoop now he does that in a different
context but i think it's applicable to
chess
i didn't i don't know if you saw the
glasses you briefly had on screen there
i loved that touch
wait
shh
oh the whoop yep
love it
see bick is redeeming himself he is he's
trying his best
let's show some love to our producers
absolutely working so so hard especially
having to deal with these commentators i
mean they are just a menace aren't they
so hard to work with so unprofessional
i see i look at the chat and i see
the first comment i see is don't laugh
fiona you're only encouraging him
and it's also a fair point he shall not
be what does a
gm
i see
but his gm house was drowned
of course i misspoke
bourbon is a foot does american football
not basketball of course yeah no i
i misspoke he's keeping us on our toes
robert it really is let anything slip
you know he should be hired to
commentate this tournament sometime
i think he and you would make a good
good commentator
alas too late for that
shout out to robert um shall we quickly
see if kariakin has made a move and i
think very soon it will be time
just as he said that he played the move
rook c8 after 30 minutes of deep thought
he does come up with the correct and
probably the winning move of rook c8
rookie
and he gets up from his chair
and there he he comes back immediately
but rook c8 we thought
was the best move in the position
and um dania we are going to take a
quick break now i think we all need it
but we'll be back with the conclusion of
this game and at
the rapport with it end game so don't go
anywhere
and
we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the first time i came here in was 2017
where i played the c group and then 2019
i played the prequel and now this is my
third time here yeah it's a great
opportunity for me because you know i
can
i can learn a lot from these games and
i'm really looking forward to this
you know to have fun and
interesting games
i started to work with engine like
pretty late
after i became an
i am and mostly seriously after i became
a junior
i sometimes think over the board and try
to you know find human ideas and also
use computer as well
i use technology and as well as you know
use books and
and uh cnhs book i don't think computer
will solve just like um for now
definitely
and maybe later like they could solve
but for now i think
this won't be solved
i'm looking forward to play against
magnus in a classical game but also
other players like
karwana and
all the others as well
[Music]
hello and welcome back to the final
stages of this ninth round here at the
tata steel chess tournament although
dania i say the final stages i've said
this a couple of times before
but there is one end game which could be
keeping us here
for a while first off though uh karjakin
has played the move rook c8 and prague
is still thinking
yeah prague is thinking and i think he's
realizing i mean with every passing
second
uh i think the real realization is
growing that there is no salvation he's
now
down at 20 minutes and he's just made a
move king d1
so at this point i think his best bet is
to try to confuse sergey
and you know create as much of a mess as
possible
now f takes e5 could be thrown in at
this point
and after f takes f takes i i think that
sergey could probably just take on c6
and
it's possible that
knight d6 is prague's
intention cutting off the rook from the
sixth rank
but
i mean for example d4 h6 is actually
already bad for black if you play d3
it's the same problem white throws in
this check
and then white plays h7 and now white is
winning rook c896
um but it appears that in this position
um
if black plays king d3
uh he evades the check on f5 and h6 can
be met with the rook c2 swinging the
rook
uh to h2 where it's going to actually
restrain the pawn and threaten checkmate
so still
a lot of difficult technique required
for sergey so the game is not over yet
for sure still a few tricks there
uh
for prague sergey he's got quite a lot
of time he's got
27 minutes
but once again they can take down
quickly let's leave these guys for now
and go back to um rapport
and
vidit where village has decided to put
his king side pawns all on light squares
yeah and
they're coming close to reaching the
position that we talked about and i
think vidit actually chose the best
arrangement for the pawn side he has
very serious drawing chances now here's
the thing
after bishop g2 if white tries to get
the king
to a7 black immediately returns to f1
that doesn't work there's no way to make
progress right you can go to a6
uh you can go to a6 but you're not going
to make any progress from there because
the king is just going to be pinned
uh and if you drop the king to a5
then um
any time
you play b6 after king a5 black is just
going to go king c6 and response dead so
for instance
black could just move the bishop let's
say bishop b2 b6 king c6 and that's it
it's a fortress and as we discussed
fiona the main line here what vidit has
to see what vidit has divided
[Music]
is bishop f3 it looks like it loses
right this has to lose b7 no king c7
what if bishop e5
cutting off the king
black immediately goes d4 and this is a
complete fortress i think the vidit is
on the doorstep of actually drawing this
game but he's down to 13 seconds and
he's gonna have to
make a decision very shortly here
dania i'm sorry i couldn't i can't keep
a straight face no because i've once
again
received some input from our producer
that's so
he has another question
is visit making fragrance
uh
oh my god that was not a very pragmatic
question
okay um well on a secret serious note it
looks like he is i mean
maybe if he can find bishop g2
um
maybe there is just no way
oh white is there any way white can try
and
bring the king
to the king's side
um i don't think that there is a way to
bring the king to the king side the
point is that
any time you move the bishop away from
d4 and i need to reiterate this
uh it's crucial for black to go d4 this
is the mechanism that allows black to
set up the forces now why is that uh why
can't black just wait around well the
reason why is because of the smoke king
d4 and now after king e6 white plays b6
and this pawn on d5 obviously acts uh as
a detrimental force it prevents the
bishop from stopping upon the king has
to go back and then the king ends up
being overextended and white's king
walks in through e5 so
by playing d4
you are ensuring that
that the bishop keeps contact with the
b7 square and that means the king can
remain on e6
and as soon as the king goes to c5 as
we've already discussed black's king
returns to d7 this is a common type of
fortress construction
and i think bishop g2 draws the game
amazing and
sorry no go ahead
yes i i didn't mean to switch to the to
the other game yet uh but yeah
go ahead fiona now you go ahead
i was just gonna say that uh uh
is it it did record did richard make a
mistake somewhere i don't know uh it
doesn't seem that way maybe the move f4
was premature
or it may be the case that vidit
actually just found the drawing idea
which is to set these pawns up in this
way to me that's counter-intuitive
because the pawn on g6 looks like a
major weakness but if he actually spots
this idea of bishop g2 i am taking my
hat off this will be such an impressive
defensive effort by bidding
and i think he just might because to me
he doesn't look if we look at him on the
camera
uh
to me he looks more like he's double
checking rather than i think if he
hadn't seen that idea he would see him
more like you know
heads uh hands on the head um
[Music]
trying to calculate and to find but here
it looks he looks actually quite
quite calm um and also well he's gonna
have to make a move he just dropped
under 10 minutes he still has to make 16
moves
but if he's seen this bishop g2 idea and
he's just checking
that could explain
the body language here
yeah and i just want to point out one
more thing
and i think that it's just taking time
to double triple check everything here's
try this on for size so here white could
try king b5 and just sneaking this thing
in no no no no no no no you are not
sneaking that king into a6 black
response with bishop e to check
and this just continues the fortress the
other thing i could try
is pushing the pawn up to b5
um but that also doesn't help
uh and oh there was one idea where you
go king b5 here and after bishop d3 king
a5 king c6 you can make a tricky move b5
check hoping for bishop takes b5 b7 uh
something tells me that it is not doing
that and he goes king b7 but here's the
amazing thing fiona here white could
reroute the king back around and it
seems like white does indeed succeed in
infiltrating but here's the amazing
detail
even though white does infiltrate it's
still a draw and it's a draw because
black has the spectacular resource h4
now might say how does h4 what is it
what does it do well this helps white
but this helps black set up a fortress
if black takes on h4
white black can plant the bishop on h5
give away the d5 pawn i mentioned
examples of being three pawns down in an
opposite colored bishop end game and
still being a draw this is a great
example of that white has no way to make
progress if white ignores and plays king
b6 then much the same thing here you
will end up being four pawns down or no
still three pawns down uh but you just
plant the bishop on g4 and you can give
away
both the d5 pawn and the g6 spawn it
doesn't matter white there's just
nothing that white can do you can go
king c8 king b7 or bishop h3 bishop g4
one way or another seeing that is really
difficult fiona and i think this is what
bit it is ultimately focused on and he
goes king c7 he doesn't go bishop g2
um
and maybe he wants the same thing yeah
let's see what difference does this make
if black takes now an h4h4 by the way is
such a nice nice resource and i think
so useful
to remember this
at home i mean i'll try my best to
remember it
we'll see if i ever find myself it's
brilliant yeah really such an important
resource
and if white goes h4 then he just does
black's bidding for him i mean here
again vidit can plant that bishop on g4
and say i don't care about anything else
i'm just moving my king back and forth
that's it that's a draw i think he's
just found uh found that idea
amazing amazing stuff by that and this
just shows you why you can't trust the
email bar it's showing plus three white
is not winning here this is definitely a
hundred i'm 100 sure that this is a draw
and so just the question is after king
takes d5 is h4 the only move and does it
have to be played right now
well you can probably procrastinate
the question is can you procrastinate
with one move i think you can yeah if
you go h4 here
oh no you can't and here's why after
king f7 hg
it looks like yeah you can hg bishop
should be to drop why did the email of
our fall what wasn't forced well hg was
enforced white can go h4
and because the bishop is stopping the
pawn from promoting now it just takes on
g6 and promotes the h-pawn this is why
it's so much more important to set up
the fortress than to take the spawn
amazing stuff
that's incredibly amazing
that's just what an idea
what an idea
wow
i'm lost lost for words
uh which art he's still thinking did we
have any moves
in the other game
against sergey karjakin
fe fe and this is actually a super
important position
sergey has to find king d3 but that is
an easy idea king d3
h6 and you prepare rook c2 with rook h2
coming he's gonna find this any
day of the week
um
prague i suppose could try to at least
pick up the uh the a4 pawn
and by the way no this is where we're in
time to take me too yeah i was wondering
yeah i just forgot about that rook takes
b2 is the move knight c5 team d4 and
essentially the king stops this spawn
and then the rook stops the the h-bone
anytime that white plays h7 black
responds with rook h2 and
e6 uh black it makes this by a single
tempo i mean like there's no time to
waste and so sergey needs to operate
with tremendous precision he's below 20
minutes prague still has a little bit of
hope
you know crazier things have happened
the thing is if not king d3 and i
thought he was about to reach out to
make a move
and he is reaching out the camera is
ready is the king gonna step
one square
this side
what helps him is that there are no
alternatives i don't see a single other
move that is even remotely appealing
because white is threatening h6 and h7
he's been made to work very hard
uh by prague but he is close now i just
needs to keep his cool we see him double
triple checking
the question is if not kd3 then what
what happens
uh we looked already i think at d4 right
yeah d4 actually might lose um
and again it's because of the placement
of the knight on d6 kudos to prague king
d1 is a very very tricky move probably
the best
defensive move that he that one could
come up with yeah what as the evil of
our shows white is winning
and once again the reason is white
throws out this knight up five track it
forces the king backwards allows white
to play h7
and uh here white plays knight e7
amazing
threatening knight g6 check right and
then promoting and if black plays king
g5
knight g8 cutting off the rook and
promoting to a queen so it is still
possible to lose this position i don't
think sergey is going to do that he
might take another 10 minutes though
like he might verify beyond a shadow of
doubt that king d3 works
and well in that case uh what do you
suggest do we wait here do we wait for
king d3 do we go to report
let's go to reports game because rehard
has has done something very interesting
he's played bishop e7
and he has actually
prevented uh vivid from going
from going h4
uh he's played bishop f6 rather
bishop g2 and bishop e7
and
his idea is is that he he now wants to
make his way to f6
while preventing h4 very very crafty
concept
fit it was seven and a half minutes he
needs to hustle
so
if he gives the pawn away now
and then he goes king d7
i think this might drop i think this
might be the drawing mechanism
bishop a3 we already talked about this
this is the fortress right
so maybe richard wants to not take on
maybe he wants b4 check
but now the king goes to d7 see this is
very important if you go to b7 you allow
white's king to infiltrate in the ideal
version
so you go to d7 and it's a draw i think
d4 is the drawing move
and by the way uh as d4 here
is a crucial move in the other game
sergey has played the crucial move king
d3
yeah there was really no doubt um and by
the way it could also start with king b7
and meet b6 with with d4 i think both
games are actually about to end
he but he needs to watch out for for his
clock once the the fortress is set up
then there will be
nothing more to worry about but
uh only six minutes here for a wedding
yeah but he realizes that that if he
finds the correct move here it's a dead
draw so he's making an investment
uh in his position and you know
i i think he's actually doing the right
thing here he's just quadruple quintuple
checking everything and as you indicated
once the fortress is reached even if you
have 30 seconds even if you're playing
an increment uh there's just nothing to
think about you just make the same move
back and forth
so he's gonna take the rest of his time
here sometimes even in this
uh position king d7 d4
and then as the time ticks down you just
i think is there a difference
if so what is the difference don't make
me
pick the the
losing of the two moves or are they both
okay sometimes it's tough when you have
these couple of options
well it absolutely is you start
overthinking it you start freaking out
about it and sometimes you end up
playing neither and that's you know how
these crazy losses happen avidit is not
someone who's
who will allow himself to to succumb to
these
uh to these anxieties but it definitely
is a thing
um as we watch
him go down to five minutes now
we are expecting d4 or kd7 here within a
couple of
minutes what
do you
uh what which move do you expect and
which move would you make
i would play
i would probably play d4 i think d4 is
the cleanest um but it really doesn't
matter
it really doesn't matter
this has to make
one of these moves
yeah
and he sees that he's just
he wants to make sure that he doesn't
squander what will be quite an amazing
defensive effort
for four and a half minutes now
forbidden yeah i mean
very impressive i really thought that
his chances of saving this endgame were
very low but he's proven me very wrong
yeah i mean this is what why 2700s are
in a category of their own it's just
like these types of games
um the vast majority of people just they
wouldn't even really try to save it they
would just kind of play intuitively
vidit really hunkered down for as long
as it took
for him to work through all of the
details and here he goes nope he's still
taking his time
look at how clean the boards are you can
see even the reflection of the pieces
yeah that's amazing
it really looks like it just came out of
the package yeah shout out to the
orbiters who of course are sanitizing
all the boards all the pieces in between
the rounds and clearly they are doing a
great job i'm curious can we i know
we're waiting for vidi to make a move i
wanted to zoom out a little bit and see
his face is he getting nervous has he
got things under control
i am surprised that he is taking quite
as long as he's taking i mean d4 is
pretty easy to calculate although that's
easy for me to say and here he goes
looks like he's finally about to make a
move he's just teasing you dania but
he's done that several he's done that
for about five minutes now so
yeah he's
he's really letting himself
there he goes
he's on the board the drawing move and i
think richard is just going to
he's going to take the pawn and and he
might just stop for a draw i mean there
is really nothing to play for
because there isn't even a single chance
and what do you really i mean if you
were in richard's shoes
do you really feel there is nothing to
try would you not
no
no because
the thing is
in order to have a try there needs to be
a margin there needs to be a possibility
for air and here there is not because
again if you walk your king to a7
doesn't matter black's king just follows
wherever white skin goes and then the
bishop starts moving back and forth
conversely
i mean there's no other path that you
could take i mean you could go backward
to f2
and i guess you could try like h3 and g4
but even if black just takes it i mean
this is
only counterproductive and i mean
richards might take some time here to
to figure all that out but ultimately
it's he quickly captured the pawn on d4
video played king d7
and i think even from from richard's
face i think even when he came back to
the board and he saw d4
and had been played i think then they
just they know
yeah no king e6 pre-move
and uh the draw offer might be coming
very soon
and let's see in the other game uh
pragnanda
has not yet made a move after king d3
yeah yeah no he's he's
suffering in this position
i think at this point he's fully aware
of the fact that he's losing
and he's trying
desperately to find some way to
complicate the game but in vain there is
i don't see anything nothing dania we're
going to take our last quick break of
the day i will leave you i guess the
vivid game on screen or one of the two
games and we'll be back in just a couple
of minutes i think really it's the final
moment of the run
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to tata steel and as the
remaining two games are nearing their
conclusion
uh we would like to present to you your
rapid recap of today and fiona there was
really no question what game
uh we want to choose it is the battle of
the two leaders world champion magnus
carlson with the white pieces against
chakrayar mahmud yarov it was a short
game but it was a really sweet game
indeed the two have lots of history we
were wondering when is this game going
to explode into life from the opening
later on magnus opened with 1d4 and soon
he
got into his newly beloved catalan
indeed there was a big decision to be
made here knight c3 but no magnus going
for the catalan and chakra are choosing
a line that's not the most popular but
is still quite reputable he grabs the
pawn then he delivers a check on b4 and
supports the bishop with a5 uh you know
over a thousand games in this position
and essentially white goes for long-term
compensation oftentimes white doesn't
rush to win this pawn back and magnus
going with a rare line e3
this is what magnus loves to do
and here shakia sprung maybe the first
slight surpriser to our eyes surprising
move uh work to a6 and you might wonder
what is that rook doing but in fact if
we look at the powerful catalan bishop
on g2 that rook is getting out of the
diagonal on the very next move it
becomes clear after queen c2 now black
is able to play b5
uh without the rook being on a8
exactly and the secondary point is that
black can play c6 in this case
and hold everything together so magnus
refraining from 95 instead going for
queen c2 b5 a4
and instead of attacking the c6 pawn he
decides to attack the b5 pawn knight c3
in this position chakra had a very
interesting chance uh to sacrifice that
pawn for uh for a long-term initiative
bishop b7 maybe that was a better move
than what he played but he decides to
cling to the pawn and fiona this is
really the turning point magnus embarks
on an incredibly powerful plan in this
position
yeah so magnus he starts with the move
you were expecting playing in the center
grabbing some space uh with e4 and after
the black bishop dropped back to e7 he
takes even more space
advancing to e5
indeed and
black can't really drop back to d7
that's kind of unthinkable due to 94
with all sorts of threats uh so chakriar
plays knight d5 but this also happens to
be an exchange sacrifice chakra didn't
blunder e5 this was a conscious
sacrifice
the point is that if magnus
go ahead i was gonna say yeah magnus
could have grabbed the exchange if he
wanted by capturing the knight uh on d5
and we see that in the end the pawn on
a5 is hanging and screwing the rook and
the queen
exactly but magnus deciding to make a
very important improvement over this
position he first takes on b5 only then
does he do this thing and the point is
that the pawn on d5 fiona becomes a very
serious weakness and this essentially
cost mahmoud very dearly uh soon
afterward yeah for now it looked like uh
the exchange sacrifice might be
promising with some long-term
compensation some active play but let's
see after knight c6 magnus of course
takes the rook on uh b6 and here maybe
after rook a8 is the the moment that
shahia went wrong
yeah so first of all
taking on d4 is not good because magnus
recaptures and then plays rook d1 and
and he wins the pawn on d5 and black's
position collapses mommy darb didn't do
that we thought that he perhaps should
have developed on e6 immediately it's
possible that what discouraged him was
the fact that after bishop takes fa
magnus has the nasty move knight g5
still it looks like black is doing okay
after g6 probably worse but okay but
chakra plays h6 and that just turns out
to be too slow it lets magnus coordinate
his pieces with devastating effect
yeah magnus found a very crafty plan
here he started by bringing his rook
from f1 to a1 and from here on out i
mean magnus just played with absolute
beautiful precision bishop e6 the move
we were expecting a move ago suddenly uh
daniel the situation has changed
yeah and this is the whole point
the move h6 allows white to bring the
rook from f1 to a1 so that when magnus
plays queen d1 to defend the pawn
uh the rook would have been on f1 it
would have been locked out of the game
but as it stands both rooks are now
coordinated both of them are in it
and the real critical moment came after
b4
chakra wants to play b3 lock white's
pawn on b2 and perhaps even get the
knight through b4 to d3 but now a
brilliant move by magnus this basically
wins the game
b3 a beautiful move some of us might be
afraid to allow the black pawn to come
to c3 there's now a protected pass pawn
but magnus understood this pawn is going
nowhere in and now attacking the queen
and
yeah just
magnus judging from a distance this
prawn on c3 is not a problem and the
knight to e1 very soon dania that was
going to play a decisive role in the
game
indeed and the idea of course is to
block the plot on c2 and later swing
over to e3 the weakness of the d5 pawn
uh and white's dominance over the a file
contributes the to the decisive
advantage out of desperation chakra he
tries to open up the center with f6 and
now magnus at stopping on a diamond
switching ideas that's what makes him so
incredible not knight c2 but knight d3
the knight redirects in order to protect
the e5 pawn and it also threatens to go
to f4 chakra takes on e5 but fiona here
the positional play turns seamlessly
into tactics there are just too many
undefended pieces in the black camp
after knight takes e5 and there is
basically nothing shaq could do he tried
to take
on e5 but now we see the bishop on e6 is
unprotected that drop and there was
really no uh there were really no other
tries in this position
there weren't after rook takes c6
everything collapses d5 e5 we mentioned
it too many undefended pieces one more
try
by shockery rc2 but magnus responds to
the cold-blooded queenie one and in this
position chakra resigned uh if he goes
knight d3 magnus captures the bishop
simultaneously attacking black screen
there is nothing else to try if you move
the knight away bishop takes d5 uh and
white vacuums up all of black's pieces a
an amazing win 27 moves this is vintage
magnus fiona i mean it seemed like
chakriar he played an inspired game but
he really was never
in it indeed magnus carlsen what a game
by the world champion he is now the sole
leader he was very happy in the
interview afterwards and he has every
reason to be this was your rapid recap
of the day and meanwhile uh dania while
we were doing this one of the games
concluded you had called it uh which i
didn't try too much uh this game ended
in a draw and i have to say uh i'm so
impressed with how
uh defended this uh opposite bishop
ending
amazing and it just that's why chess is
great sometimes you even feel better
with a draw than with a win
and this is the kind of draw that is
going to feel like a win for vinovid
it's going to be sitting in his room
tonight and thinking man
the way that i saved that is he's going
to be impressed with himself he's going
to be patting himself on the back
obviously he can't relax he has four
more very important rounds so he's going
to get busy preparing for the next game
but
a very impressive defensive display
indeed by mr vivid and report's going to
be disappointed but i'm not really sure
that he missed any specific wins uh the
end game deserves further analysis but
in any case the draw is made and we're
on to the final
stretch of our final game pragnanda
unfortunately losing
and i think that this game might not
last more than just a couple of couple
more moves
so let's see uh after karjakin found the
crucial move king d3 a few moves ago
um
let's just go back there for a sec
prague tried to run with his king um but
here yes sergey just playing with
precision and can you take the pawn on
e5 yeah you can and you should and
what's ultimately going to happen here
uh after king h4
so
black's strategy is to push the d-pawn
and then at the last possible moment to
give up the rook for the h1 so for
example h64h7
now looks like the pawn is unstoppable
but black uses tactics rookie one in
order to
meet h8 queen with rook h1 check and if
the king goes to the pawns rescue well
this is a very straightforward win black
just goes d3
then d2
and ultimately yeah white is going to
force black to give up the rook but look
at where white's king ends up and this
is similar to the grundelius caruana
situation where yeah you know material
is technically equal but black eats up
both of these puns and wins the game
sergey without hesitation capturing on
e5 i think this is how the game is going
to go
yeah and
another it's a tough uh tough day for
for prague
who really had test chances i mean such
an interesting i think great opening
preparation
a very promising exchange
sacrifice
and then i mean also karyakin from the
moment he was put with his back against
the wall i think he found some very nice
um
very nice defensive uh resources
creating counterplay against the the
black king
and uh prague had some chances
in in the end game to hold but i think
this game at some point uh the
experience of karjakin just shown true
yeah he doesn't have the nickname
minister of defense for nothing he
really is
probably the premier defender in the
world
and his ability to turn these games not
just into draws but into wins is very
impressive how easy would it have been
to sort of mentally collapse after
prague plays h5 he was up 50 minutes but
sergey he was playing fast he found a
good opportunity to trade queens and
then he handled the end game exquisitely
really pouncing on on the opportunity
when he played e5 creating a pass pawn
and then let's not forget the move rook
c8
not easy at all there's such a
temptation to just take on e5 and allow
knight c7 but no he goes rick c8 he
spends a lot of time
and the rest is
history he takes the pawn
uh one more precise move required i mean
simply king c2 h6
and now i think
well many possible moves i like to move
rook e6 here
the point is that if h7 then rook h6 so
white has to play a move like knight f7
now you drop the rook back
and the knight on f7 is going to be
unable to stop the pawn at the end of
the line so
many many winning ideas by sergey uh but
this one is probably probably the
cleanest you could start with d4 also
this this also works
so yeah anything wins here
at the end of the day uh the king is
just gonna be too far removed the black
king is going to mop up those kings
those pawns on the queen side and dania
we're looking at the results so far here
in round nine and it's been another
tremendously exciting and decisive one
it really has been we had anish geary
with a nice win over sam shanklin sam
really kind of losing his cool in that
end game uh jkd is going to be
uh feeling
quite cross with himself
uh tonight he was definitely winning he
had andre on the ropes but andre kudos
to him great defensive effort von forest
zuba was a draw jordan we thought was
better throughout the game but just
somehow didn't make anything of it uh
caruana grandelius that was maybe the
most painful game of the day as niels
had such a great position and just maybe
he overthought it but fabiano he really
stepped up to the plate a draw and
reported it and uh sergey is going to
win so we are going to have four
decisive games as we look at the
standings fiona the world champion he is
ahead of the field i think for the first
time in this tournament magnus carlsen
is the sole leader but uh anish geary he
hasn't to take taken the foot off
the gas pedal he is keeping pace only
half a point behind the two of them have
played each other
already and uh behind them and yaroff
and vidigrati two of our early days
leaders they are still
looming just one point behind magnus
they are and uh as we have a look at the
pairings in round 10 vinitsave by the
way was also huge as he uh is close
behind he has white against prague
that's a game that he wants to try to
win and really put more pressure on
magnus magnus plays sergey with black
beating sergey with black is
that is quite the demand and i don't
think magnus is going to do anything
insane i think he's fine with the draw
we have shanklin against mamidyarov in
shock he will be looking to rebound for
sure he's going to be taking some risks
no question about that against i think
so too especially against some who today
had a a tough game a game against aneesh
things didn't really go his way there's
and uh anish at the bottom there uh
almost missed him for a second he will
be playing with the white pieces against
the ancients of duda
and yanchez of just not in
tremendous form this tournament you can
tell he's squandering some opportunities
making uncharacteristic mistakes
and anish is going to be looking to
build on this very impressive winning
streak which is going to reach fabiano's
sink field cup like proportions if he
manages to win another one
so
it's going to be a fascinating round
tomorrow absolutely and meanwhile prague
has gone
knight f5 so the knight uh looking to
support the h pawn but i think yeah the
d-pawn can just
uh run now
yeah i mean d4 the one
tough part for bla i mean you definitely
don't want to go king c4
it's easy to blunder in a position like
this because you allow the force same
same with king e4
um so black should start with rookie 8
and then once white's king moves away
the way that black can do this but i can
go rook d8 and then bring the king back
to c4 so that the rook is out of the
line of fire of the knight
and you're ready to play d3 and if
knight d6 check then you go king b3 and
we already know the drill here
h a queen the rook takes and the pawn is
unstoppable
so that's one way to win
one of many karjakin goes king e4 also
perfectly fine he stops h6 because
there's going to be rook g6 check
and karjakin from his body language we
saw the focus throughout
but now he knows uh this one's in the
bank he has figured it out until the end
and um you gotta feel sorry for prague
but i mean we talk about it every day he
is only 16 years old
this hasn't been his tournament
uh but he is
going to walk away with here with so
much new experience and he will be back
stronger than ever
for sure and you know if he wins one or
two games in the last four rounds he
still has the chance to salvage the
tournament rating wise i mean that's the
great thing about being one of the being
the lowest rated and trust me i know
you know you pull out a couple draws and
you know it's hard to lose a lot of
rating even though what's going to
disappoint prague from this tournament
of course isn't the rating it's the fact
that he did have
uh promising positions in a lot of the
games and so far not able to withstand
the middle game pressure maybe nerves
coming into play but he needs to acquire
more experience and he is going to be
back with a vengeance that's for sure
and danya i'm seeing a question in the
chat which maybe you might have the
answer to
from anubhav is asking where is kasparov
nowadays
uh you know i
i i did not i was not able to catch you
know this round because uh because i was
in i was doing a talk i was doing a talk
about ai and um
that's it you know i heard that uh the
commentators were bad anyway sarah
i am
i really don't think i missed very much
and uh
and uh yeah i mean
gary it's been a pleasure having you
here for a second thank you for making
some time in your very
very busy uh schedule and uh yeah we'll
have danya back now
all right yeah gary very rudely just
kicked me out of the zoom call and
you know he had to
what uh what a what a rude guy i mean
really he might be a legend but that was
that was unacceptable behavior
unacceptable behavior
and yeah king e5 uh prague is also down
two to four minutes so this one i mean
king g five king g fight this is true
mood point at this point rookie eight
and this is just easy when h6 or g8
king h4 the problem for prague is that
it's
it's not easy for circade to
to screw this one oh and there's a nice
move in this position rook g6 and
amazingly you can't defend the pawn with
either of these pieces i mean h7 rook h6
check
and uh the f5 square is covered i think
this is what sergey is going for
yeah okay it is already on the board h6
and this is gonna happen rook g8 shack
king h4 rook g6 and i think prague is
going to resign in that position
yeah there it comes rook g8 is on the
board
king h4 the only move to hold on
to the night and very nice move probably
to finish the game here
there it is sergey filigree precision no
chances yielded and prague about to
extend his hand
in resignation you can see the
disappointment on his face
and there it is he resigns and sergey
with a big win of the black pieces
very impressive dania how you called the
entire end of the game
everything up to the handshake
tough to see
prague there he's looking quite
disappointed in the end he definitely
had his chances
uh in this
tournament uh
but
sergey he was just showed some
immaculate defense
he really did and there's a lot for
prague to to unpack and analyze in this
game
it's possible that uh that you know
queen e3 early on was not ideal uh maybe
you know and it's so easy to say in
retrospect that he should have done this
this and this the position was very
complex and one of the biggest positives
for prague is his opening preparation
which has been really good i mean even
against mom and yara if you found a
really interesting idea just didn't get
lucky and sometimes it just doesn't go
your way i mean you put yourself in a
good position but uh sometimes it's it's
it's just not your tournament and and
this has been the case with prague yeah
and i think
it's a similar situation today almost uh
niels and prague both of them at the
bottom of the standings both not having
a good event
and they
both of them got their chances
and um yeah it's just at some point also
i think when you're down you're doubting
yourself more
and it's not easy to
to maybe also sense this those moments
uh quite as well
but yeah with that round nine here at
the tata steel chess tournament is over
we see the players
still at the board with karjakin being
asked a tricky question there it seems
my prank
right yeah they're analyzing you can see
the passion five and a half hours but
not enough they need more chess they
they need to grind further um that just
shows you how dedicated they are to
finding the truth but that
ends the games for today and what a
decisive day we have four decisive
results and three draws always good to
see more decisive games than draws fiona
indeed great day of action i mean so
many fighting players
in this tournament all of them
incredibly fighting for decisive results
of course the main one of the day is at
the bottom magnus carlsen winning his
game against
the one we just saw and karjakin against
prague we talked about uh nils
grandelius's loss uh against fabiano
carrana plenty
annie
he was the first to win his game today
he's won four in a row uh and if we look
at the standings he is now just half a
point behind the leader a certain magnus
carlsen with shahid
still looming on five and a half but
also fabio uh why do i keep calling him
fabio
fabiano making his way back up the
rankings
big win today against nils and uh as we
take a look at the pairings for tomorrow
a couple of huge games of course magnus
black against sergey i know who vidit uh
is rooting for vinit himself is white
against prague another brutal game for
prague anna a game that vida really has
to win uh if he wants to contend for
first place fabi is going to try to keep
his positive streak going against uh
richard report dubaf grindelius as a
bank of van forest and anish gary also
with a very important game white against
an off-form duda we will see how that
game goes as well fiona for sure and
finally before we leave you um let's
quickly have a look at the tournament
schedule so we'll be back tomorrow same
place same time round 10 we'll start at
2 p.m local time that's central european
5 a.m pacific and after that on thursday
we'll have another
rest day and the players i'm sure will
make the most of it before the final
weekend coming up we'll be here friday
saturday sunday for the conclusion of
this tata steel chest tournament for now
daniel it's been another tremendously
exciting day thank you so much for being
here thank you for watching us and i'll
leave you there the closing words
fiona this has been great always a
pleasure really from the first moves
this has been uh an incredible round we
have such diversity of openings uh we
have so many
interesting game arcs we have time
scrambles we have positional games we
have really fascinating end games and
you can see in every move that these
players play the effort they are hungry
uh they're hungry for victories from uh
the lowest rated player to magnus
carlsen it was an amazing round and we'd
like to thank everybody for watching and
of course bick for yet another yeah i
begrudgingly have to think for yet
another flawless broadcast so thank you
very much and we will see you tomorrow
for the next round oh and maybe just
before i forget uh i think stay on this
channel because title tuesday is ongoing
so i think we're gonna go there
so plenty more chess to look forward to
tonight have a good one we'll see you
tomorrow
i think the first time i heard about
the tournament here was
probably sometime in 1999
but the first tournament that i actually
followed was the one in in 2000
so i would say that's my like first firm
memory of the tournament here
probably my best memory from the village
here
uh
was the year that i i won and uh people
of baikon say song sang a nice little
song for for me i i really appreciated
that
i think there are people in
my team who are better than me at
working with
with uh and sergey kayaken you just beat
pragananda with the black pieces um
there was this
exchange sacrifice by by prague and the
opening um do you think you had
everything under control there
actually i have no idea what was going
on in this game it was just
a completely crazy game
i played a sharp line sacrificing the
pawn after knight h5 and
then
my opponent was
well prepared and he came up with this
idh4 which
i
at least didn't remember or maybe i
didn't know
i have to check
so
then uh i don't know maybe i should have
played something else and
later on he sacrificed an exchange and
it was very very dangerous position but
uh at least
there were no immediate win but it was
very dangerous for me maybe he had
something
and then later on we got the end game
which i first thought were you happy
that you were able to uh to exchange the
queens uh yes sure because i understood
that i'm not worth at least and uh
okay basically i thought it's a draw at
the beginning but later on i started to
think that maybe i can play this
position a little bit so
then
i decided not not
to repeat the moves but to play h5 which
is very sharp and
it's very principle but it's also risky
for black so because i sacrifice a
second pawn and
then when he played knight before uh
takes takes king for knight taxis six
i'm three pounds down so it's it's very
tricky and
then okay i think
it should have been drawn somehow
and later on after the time control
after i played uh
after i played e5 okay i understood that
i'm playing only one wins that's for
sure and later on when i played rock sh8
and if he plays c7 then d4
he played king d1 and uh
here i thought it should be winning for
me
um maybe he had some
small improvements but basically i think
it should it was winning already yeah
what i checked with the engine because i
had the privilege to actually follow the
game with an engine uh it showed that
like oh move 40 for black there was a
move h6 instead of c6 where white is
actually better like plus one and half
or something really
yeah so as i say that h5 it was it was
like crazy move to for this three
results anything anything could happen
basically okay maybe i should have
played rk8 if i didn't want to repeat
the moves but i think it's it should be
a draw and
yeah like what i did was completely
crazy maybe he was winning i don't know
but it must be nice to actually like
take take some risks in a game and uh
and to get rewarded
yeah yeah it's not actually very often
that i like to take risks
which i cannot be sure
but
this time i decided to go on and
why is that why don't you take so much
risks usually
i mean if you take much risk then you
can
you can lose
if your opponent is playing well so
that's very simple but i mean here i
thought that the position is very
interesting and okay let's go but
in another position maybe i wouldn't do
the same oh it sounds like you're you're
having fun here and where i can say
uh yeah i like likanza very much uh i i
like basically
neither lands amsterdam everything
how many bikes did you count yesterday
oh well
not much okay
okay i wish you all the best in the rest
of the tournament thank you thanks
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you